WE'RE GOING -- TO THESE ARE ALL
HOLD OPEN ITEMS TODAY WE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END
OF THE SESSION AS TO ALL ITEMS.
WE'RE GOING TO ADJUST THE THE
BATTING ORDER A LITTLE BIT IN
THE SENSE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE -- ISSUE NUMBER.
FIVE FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
FACILITIES FIRST AND THEN MOVE
THROUGH THE AGENDA STARTING WITH
ISSUE NUMBER -- ONE IN ORDER
FROM THAT POINT ON SO WE'RE ON
ITEM SIXTY ONE HUNDRED
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES.
PAGE IXTEEN ON THE AGENDA
.
OKAY IF YOU WOULD -- IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD
STARTING TO MY LEFT YOU'RE READY
MA'AM.
I RECOUNT MINOR WITH THE OFFICE
OF PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
THANK YOU ROOMS THE THANKS FOR
JOINING US.
KEITH IS ON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THANK YOU SERVICE EMILY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE IS
LEE THANK YOU [inaudible]
OVER FROM. FOR THANK YOU.
OKAY WHO WANTS TO START.
A GOOD START -- SO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES SEVEN
HIGH FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND. TO
PROVIDE SCHOOLS WITH --
FACILITIES BARRIERS THERE
PREVENTING THEM FROM -- OFFERING
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS.
TO ADDRESS THOSE IT BARRIERS
THAT ARE THAT ARE PREVENTING
THAT SO I'M THIS IS AN EXTENSION
OF A ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS PROVIDED IN THE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT --
ONE NOTABLE DIFFERENCE IS THAT
WE ARE ALLOWING THE SAVINGS --
FROM ANY PROJECTS ACROSS THERE
ARE FUNDS THAT AREN'T USED TO BE
USED FOR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND CONSTRUCTION
MATERIALS TO BUILD CAPACITY.
FOR THOSE NEW A FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS.
OKAY [inaudible]
HELLO.
CHAIR ANYWAY WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE YOU
SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED A HANDOUT
THAT I'LL BE REFERENCING
THROUGHOUT MY PRESENTATION THIS
MORNING.
STARTING ON PAGE ONE WE OFFER
SOME BACKGROUND ON FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN ENDS THE CAN GARDEN
FACILITY GRANTS.
AS BACKGROUND IN KINDERGARTEN
THE STATE REQUIRES DISTRICTS
OFFER KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS BUT
LEAVES IT TO DISTRICTS TO
DETERMINE THE LENGTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS.
PARTY PROGRAMS OPERATE BETWEEN
THREE TO FOUR HOURS WHEREAS FULL
DAY PROGRAMS OPERATE MORE THAN
FOUR HOURS.
I'M AS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
MENTIONED LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED ONE HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO CREATE KINDERGARTEN FACILITY
GRANTS.
THESE GRANTS WERE PRIMARILY
INTENDED TO ENCOURAGE MORE FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BY COVERING FACILITY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH.
DEEP KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS TO
FULL DAY PROGRAMS FOR INSTANCE A
DISTRICT ME RUN A MORNING
SESSION AND AN AFTERNOON SESSION
AND ONE CHAIR CLASSROOM.
BUT ONCE THAT WAS PART DAY
PROGRAMS ARE CONVERTED TO TWO
FULL DAY CLASSROOMS -- FULL DAY
PROGRAMS EACH PROGRAM WOULD
REQUIRE SEPARATE CLASSROOM IN
THESE GRANTS WOULD HELP COVER
SOME OF THOSE AS THOUGH IT
SUCCEEDED FACILITY COSTS.
IN THE FIRST APPLICATION AROUND
WHICH CONCLUDED JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR A TOTAL OF SEVENTY
DISTRICTS OMITTED TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO PROJECTS
REQUESTING.
THE TWO MILLION AND FINDING THIS
EXCEEDS THE TOTAL ONE HUNDRED
MILLION PROVIDED FOR THE PROGRAM.
A SECOND APPLICATION AROUND WILL
OCCUR NEXT MONTH IN MAY TO
ALLOCATE THE REMAINING FUNDING.
WILL SKIP PAGE TWO BECAUSE THAT
JUST COVERS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WHICH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ALREADY COVERED.
I'M MOVING ON TO PAGE THREE AND
OUR ASSESSMENTS WE OUTLINED
THREE MAIN CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE
AT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
FIRST WE ARE CONCERNS THAT THE
ADDITIONAL GRANTS ARE NOT LIKELY
TO ACHIEVE THE SEATS GOAL OF
HAVING MORE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS.
AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE FIGURE ON
PAGE THREE WE ANALYZE THE
INITIAL ROUND OF APPLICANTS AND
FOUND THAT 76% OF THE SEVENTY
APPLICANTS ALREADY RUN FULL DAY
PROGRAMS.
THESE ARE DISTRICTS APPLYING TO
LARGELY REPLACE EXISTING FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOMS THAT
DO NOT MEET CITY REGULATIONS.
AND THIS WAS A SECONDARY PURPOSE
FOR THE GRANTS.
THE LEGISLATURE WORD EXPAND THE
PROGRAM AS THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
WE THINK A SIMILARLY HIGH
SHERIFF GRANTS WOULD GO TO
DISTRICTS ALREADY RUNNING FULL
DAY PROGRAMS.
SECOND WE FOUND THAT DISTRICTS
ME OPERATE PARTY PART PROGRAMS
FOR REASONS BEYOND FACILITY
CONSTRAINTS FOR EXAMPLE SOME
DISTRICTS TOLD US THAT THEIR
PARENTS PREFERRED THEIR CHILDREN
ATTEND A PARTY PROGRAM.
ARE THESE PARENTS THINK THAT
FIVE YEAR OLDS ARE NOT ARE NOT
SEE READY FOR A LONGER DAY OF
INSTRUCTION.
OTHER DISTRICTS INDICATED THAT
THEIR TEACHERS PREFER PART DAY
PROGRAMS BECAUSE THE LEAD CLASS
FOR A FEW HOURS AND THEN PROVIDE.
AND ASSISTANCE FOR ANOTHER
TEACHER FOR THE REMAINDER OF THE
DAY DISTRICTS MAY ALSO USE THESE
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS TO PROVIDE
OTHER INSTRUCTIONAL ACTIVITIES
I'M SUCH AS INTENSIVE READING
INTERVENTION OR TEACHING MATH OR
SCIENCE TO OLDER CHILDREN -- IN
AFTER HIM.
GIVEN THESE ISSUES WE THINK SOME
PORTION OF DISTRICTS RUNNING
PARTY PROGRAMS MAY SIMPLY NOT BE
INTERESTED IN THESE GRANTS.
THIRD MOST DISTRICTS INTERESTED
IN OPERATING FULL THE PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO COVER THEIR
FACILITY COSTS WITH EXISTING
SOURCES OF STATE AND LOCAL
FINDING.
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS THE
SHARE OF STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
FULLY PROGRAMS GREW FROM 43%
270%.
A DISTRICT INTERESTED IN RUNNING
FULL DAY PROGRAMS MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING THROUGH THE
EXISTING SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM
WHICH IS THE STATE WATER LONGER
STANDING PROGRAM THAT HELPS FUND
SCHOOL FACILITIES FOR ALL GRADES.
OR DISTRICTS MAY RELY ON LOCAL
FIND FOR AYE DRESSING THESE
FACILITY CONSTRAINTS.
MOVING ON TO THE LAST PAGE. FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THE LEGISLATURE
REFRAIN FROM EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM AT THIS TIME WE DO OFFER
TO MORE TARGETED OPTION SHOULD
THE LEGISLATURE REMAIN
INTERESTED IN PROMOTING FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS.
FIRST THE LEGISLATURE COULD
REVISIT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
NEXT YEAR IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AFTER KNOWS MORE
ABOUT THE DEMAND AFTER THE
INITIAL ONE HUNDRED MILLION IS
AWARDED.
IF THE LEGISLATURE DESIRES TO
PROVIDE MORE FACILITY GRANTS
BASED ON ANY REMAINING FUNDING
WE RECOMMEND IT FOCUS THE
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY ON
DISTRICTS RUNNING PART DAY
PROGRAM DUE TO FACILITY
CONSTRAINTS.
SECONDLY THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER CREATING AN EVEN
STRONGER INCENTIVEFOR FULL DAY
PROGRAMS BY REDUCING THE PART
DAY PER STUDENT RAY UNDER LCF
OVER THREE YEARS.
CURRENTLY PER DAY AND FULL DTE
PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED AT THE SAME
PER STUDENT FUNDING LEVELS
DESPITE THE DIFFERENCE AN
INSTRUCTIONAL HOURS THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER WE
THE RATE TO REFLECT THE LOWER
OUR THE LOWER HOURS OF
INSTRUCTION.
EVER BEFORE LOWERING THAT OUT
ALONG THE PART THE RATE WE THINK
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD WEIGH THE
TRADE OFFS CAREFULLY SINCE SOME
PARENTS MAY PREFER TO SEND THEIR
CHILDREN TO THE PARK DAY
PROGRAMS.
WITH THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY -- MA'AM.
I RECOMMEND IT WITH THE OFFICE
OF PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
AND I'D JUST LIKE TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF INFORMATION ABOUT
THE APPLICANTS FOR THIS FIRST
ROUND A FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
FUNDING -- AS WAS STATED WE DID
HAVE SEVENTY TWO DISTRICT THAT
SUBMITTED AN APPLICATION FOR THE
FIRST THIRTY SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION OF THE FIRST OTHER
MILLION THAT WAS MADE A FULL.
SIXTEEN OF THOSE DISTRICTS OR
22% DID NOT PREVIOUSLY OFFER
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN.
THE STATUTE IS WRITTEN TO
PROVIDE PRIORITY TO THOSE
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE A HIGH
PERCENTAGES OF STUDENTS THAT
QUALIFY FOR FREE AND REDUCED
PRICE MEALS.
AND ALSO FOR THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT QUALIFY FOR
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP ASSISTANCE
WHICH ARE THE DISTRICTS THAT
DON'T HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO MAKE THEIR FULL
MATCH ON LOCAL FACILITIES
PROJECTS.
WITH THE FIRST ROUND OF THE
THIRTY SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
THERE WE IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO FIND TWELVE
PROJECTS.
AND ALL TWELVE OF THOSE
DISTRICTS -- QUALIFIED FOR
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. NINE OF THE
TWELVE PREVIOUSLY OFFERED FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN.
I AM IN THE FREE AND REDUCED
PRICE MEALS PERCENTAGES FOR THE
DISTRICTS THAT WILL RECEIVE
FUNDING WERE BETWEEN EIGHTY FOUR
AND 96%.
AND AS WE LOOK AT THE
APPLICATIONS WHAT WE DID LEARN
IS THAT THOSE DISTRICTS THAT
WERE PREVIOUSLY OFFERING FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN HAD APPLIED TO
THE PROGRAM.
WHERE THEY WERE HOUSING THE
STUDENTS WAS LARGELY IN
PORTABLES?
STANDARD CLASSROOMS WITHOUT
RESTROOMS AND OF SMALLER SIZE
THAN TO TYPICAL KINDERGARTEN
CLASSROOMS.
AND IN SOME CASES -- IN WHAT
USED TO BE A COMPUTER LAB AND A
TEACHER -- WORK AREA.
AND THE OTHER THING WE NOTED WAS
THAT FOR THOSE THAT WERE NOT
PREVIOUSLY OFFERING FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN THAT WILL NOT
RECEIVE FUNDING.
THAT IS LARGELY DUE TO THEM NOT
AB QUALIFYING FOR THE FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP OR HAVING A LOW
PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS WITH FREE
AND REDUCED PRICE MEALS OR IN
SOME CASES.
A BOWL FACTORS APPLIED.
AND WITH THAT WERE HAVING ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION [inaudible]
DR.
THANKS FOR THE INVITATION THE
DISCUSSION -- A GROUP OF
PRACTITIONERS AND POLICY
THINKERS NEARLY CHILDHOOD FIELD
IN OVER THE LAST. EIGHTEEN
MONTHS WE'VE BEEN EXAMINING A
VARIETY OF POLICY PROPOSALS AND
THE CHILD CARE AND PRE K. --
SECTOR -- I THINK MISS WINS
PASSED AROUND COPIES OF A BRIEF
THAT WE'VE JUST PUT OUT RECENTLY
WHICH TRIES TO LOOK.
AT THE DISTRIBUTION OF PULLED A
KINDERGARTEN PRESENTLY.
AROUND THE STATE KIND OF LOOKING
AT THE LANDSCAPE.
AND SECONDLY LOOKS AT THE
DISTRIBUTION OF TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN TKA PROGRAMS AROUND
THE STATE -- YOU HAVE BEFORE YOU
A VARIETY OF PROPOSALS FROM THE
GOVERNOR IN THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
SPACE -- WE THOUGHT THROUGH AT
LEAST TWO OR THREE CRITERIA THAT
MIGHT BE USEFUL IN WEIGHING THE
RELATIVE MERITS OF THESE
DIFFERENT PROPOSALS -- ONE IS
THE UTILITY OF LENGTHENING
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME QUOTE UNQUOTE
FOR CHILDREN ALREADY ENROLLED IN
PART DAY KINDERGARTEN.
OR PRE K. -- A SECOND.
THAT IS WHAT IS THE VALUE OF
MOVING FROM PART DATA FULL DAY.
WITHIN PRE K. AND OR
KINDERGARTEN.
SECONDLY WHAT'S THE RELATIVE
WHAT ARE THE RELATIVE LEVELS OF
UNMET IMMEDIATE NEED ACROSS AGE
GROUPS.
OTHER FULL DAY K. PROGRAM LOOKS
PRIMARILY A FIVE YEAR OLDS WE
KNOW THAT ENROLLMENT RATES FOR
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS -- ARE
MUCH LOWER AT THE PRE K. LEVEL.
ESPECIALLY IN CERTAIN REGIONS
REGIONS OF THE STATE LIKE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE INLAND
EMPIRE -- AND FINALLY A THIRD
CRITERION MIGHT BE -- WHO WANT
EMPHASIZE -- AS WE EXPAND EARLY
CHILD CARE AND EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION -- AND THIS IS SORT OF
A LEADING QUESTION FROM OUR
BRIEF IN TERMS OF LOOKING AT WHO
WHO CURRENTLY BENEFITS FROM FULL
THEY QUE.
BENEFITS FROM FULL DAY I TKA AND
HOW DOES THAT RELATE TO A MUCH
LOWER LEVELS OF ENROLLMENT. FOR
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS.
SO.
LET ME JUST BRIEFLY -- EMPHASIZE
A FEW FINDINGS FROM FROM OUR
WORK AND AND THEIR WATER CHARTS
AND FIGURES IN THIS BRIEF
HOPEFULLY THERE HOPEFULLY
THEY'RE DIGESTIBLE -- FIRST OF
ALL NEARLY THREE FOURTHS OF ALL
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS PRESENTLY
OFFER FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN --
WE SEE THIS AND FIGURE ONE OF
PAID ON PAGE THREE OF THE BRIEF --
THE SHARE OF SCHOOLS OFFERING
FULL THEY QUE IT'S BEEN RISING
IN RECENT YEARS.
WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL
FACILITIES DOLLARS AS BEFORE THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR.
INVESTMENT THE CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR -- THESE RATES OF FOLD A.
K. A. -- HAVE BEEN RISING --
THIS IS PROBABLY DUE TO THE
FLEXIBILITY PROVIDED THROUGH.
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING.
NEXT IF WE ISOLATE ON THE ONE
QUARTER OF ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS
THAT SERVE THE HIGHEST SHARES OF
POOR CHILDREN.
OVER 80% FOURTH.
THE SCHOOLS ALREADY OFFER FULL
THEY QUE THIS IS SHOWN.
IN THE LWER PANEL OF FIGURE --
TO AND AGAIN WE SEE GROWTH EVEN
IN IN THE MOST -- DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES -- PROBABLY THANKS
TO SOME TITLE ONE FUNDING FROM
THE FEDS AS WELL AS LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING -- IN THE MOST
ADVANTAGE COMMUNITIES OF THE
STATE IF THAT IS THE QUARTER OF
SCHOOLS THAT SERVE THE MOST WELL
OFF.
FAMILIES FULLY QUE IS BEEN
GROWING AS WELL OVER THE LAST
THREE YEARS AGAIN WITHOUT ANY
SPECIAL.
IN FULL DAY K. -- WITH OR
WITHOUT TARGETED INCENTIVES AND
I THINK THIS IS A THIS IS A
POINT THE LA I WAS ALREADY.
MADE.
ON PAGE FIVE OF THE OF THE BRIEF --
THERE'S A MAP FOR SOMETHING
CALIFORNIA -- THAT SHOWS THE
GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION IT'S SORT OF
JUST -- VIVIDLY ILLUSTRATES HOW
FULL THEY QUE TENDS TO BE
LOCATED IN LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES ON THE REMAINING.
PART DAY PROGRAMS ARE IN UPPER
MIDDLE CLASS AND AFFLUENT.
COMMUNITIES -- AS THE OFFICE
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION JUST
INDICATE IT'S THE TARGETING
LANGUAGES WORKING. TO SOME
EXTENT IN TERMS OF FOCUSING NEW
DOLLARS ON FOR COMMUNITIES.
ALTHOUGH THE BULK OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES ALREADY OFFER FULL
DAY.
K..
I'M WHEN WE LOOK AT TKD IS
HEADED IS ESSENTIALLY IDENTICAL
THAT IS WE SEE UPWARD GROWTH --
OVERALL IN FULL TKA -- ACCEPTED
THEM ONE THIRD OF ELEMENTARY'S
IN THE STATE'S POOREST
COMMUNITIES -- DO NOT OFFER T.
K. THAT IS WE HAVE A REMAINING
ONE THIRD.
A LITTLE OVER 33% OF ELEMENTARY
IS THAT STILL.
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES OR
WHERE WITH ALL TO OFFER FULL DAY
TKA -- BUT WE HAVE MUCH MORE
ROOM TO GROW OUT TKA FOR FOUR
YEAR OLDS AND WE DO. TO GROW OUT
FULL DAY FOR FIVE YEAR OLDS AND
AGAIN.
WE KNOW THAT A ONLY ABOUT HALF
OF ALL THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS
CAN FIND ANY SORT OF PRE K..
PROGRAMS SO I THINK IT'S BACK TO
THIS ISSUE OF RELATIVE NEED.
AND RELATIVE UNMET NEEDS.
SO THERE'S A COUPLE TAKE AWAYS
HERE ONE IS ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVES TO EXPAND FULL DAY K..
WOULD MOST LIKELY BENEFIT
FAMILIES AND BETTER OFF PARTS OF
THE STATE OR IN AREAS OF THE
STATE THAT ALREADY OFFER FULL
DAY K. AS YOU JUST HEARD -- NEW
FUNNY COULD FINANCE RENOVATION
OF ALL CLASSROOMS.
IN DISTRICTS ALREADY RUNNING
FULL DAY K. THAT IS WE HAVE WE
DO HAVE OBVIOUSLY BIG NEED IN
CENTRAL VALLEY.
INLAND EMPIRE PART DATE WERE
FACILITIES ARE OLD.
AND WE NEED TO RENOVATE THOSE
FACILITIES SO NEW FUNDING COULD
HELP IN THAT WAY BUT THAT
DOESN'T HELP US EXPAND -- FULL
DAY K. IT JUST ALLOWS EXISTING
DISTRICTS WITH FULL DAY QUE. TO
IMPROVE THEIR FACILITIES.
AND SECONDLY THERE'S MUCH MORE
ROOM TO GROW TKA FOR FOUR YEAR
OLDS AND TO GROW FULL DAY K. FOR
FIVE YEAR OLDS.
AND I JUST CLOSE WITH THE THIRD
POINT WHICH IS OTHER RESEARCHERS
OVER THE PAST QUARTER CENTURY
HAVE.
PRETTY MUCH DETERMINE THE FULL
DAY K. DOES RAISE KIDS EARLY
COGNITIVE GROWTH IN EARLY
LITERACY SKILLS WILL THEY QUE IS
EFFECTIVE.
BUT THERE'S A BIG PROVISO HERE
WHICH IS THAT THOSE EFFECTS ON
KIDS ARE MUCH STRONGER. FOR
YOUNGSTERS FROM DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS AS OPPOSED TO UPPER
MIDDLE CLASS.
GRAMS.
SO HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS OR
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION WHAT
DOCTOR WHAT WITH RESPECT TO WELL.
I GUESS LET ME AS THIS WHAT
WOULD BE YOUR SUGGESTION.
OR OF WHAT WOULD BE YOUR
SUGGESTIONS IN TERMS OF TRYING.
TO EXPAND FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
TO THOSE REGIONS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T CURRENTLY
OFFER IT TO THE PLEDGE ANALYSTS
TO SUGGESTED.
AB SUGGESTING THE THE RATES THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES IN THE US --
BETWEEN PART DAY IN FULL DAY.
AS ONE ALTERNATIVE YEAH I THINK
THAT HAS MERIT SENATOR -- NOW AS
YOU KNOW -- DISTRICTS GET THE
SAME REIMBURSEMENT SO TO SPEAK
WHETHER THEY HAVE PARKED THEIR
FULL DAY AND IN SOME DISTRICTS
TEACHERS ARE OPTING TO STAY WITH
PART DAY BECAUSE AND THERE'S NO
FINANCIAL PENALTY SO I THINK
DIFFERENTIAL REIMBURSEMENT RATES
RADIATE RATES -- FOR FULL DAY
PROGRAMS IS PROBABLY A GOOD IDEA --
IF THERE'S A WAY TO TIGHTEN THE
BUDGET CONTROL LANGUAGE. TO
BETTER ENSURE THAT THE MONEY'S
MOVING TO THOSE DISTRICTS THAT
DON'T OFFER FULL THE
DISADVANTAGED DISTRICTS THAT
DON'T OFFER FULL DAY AT THE
CONTROL LANGUAGE MIGHT HELP.
THE OTHER IDEA THAT I KNOW IT'S
BEEN TALKED ABOUT IN THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE IS TO TRY.
TO TARGET THIS MONEY ON TKA
WITHIN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WHICH WOULD GO TOWARDS
INCREASING.
ENROLLMENT RATES FOR FOUR YEAR
OLDS.
WHICH WE NOR MUCH LOWER THAN
CURRENT SERVICES FOR FIVE ROOMS
SO SORT OF DIVERT THE PROPOSED
FUNDING AWAY FROM.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FROM FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN TO THE T. CASE --
YEAH IT WOULD STILL PARTIALLY
ACCOMPLISHED THE GOVERNOR'S
OBJECTIVE OF OF EATING
KINDERGARTEN BUT IT WOULD RAISE
SERVICES AND AND ACCESS FOR FOUR
YEAR OLDS AS OPPOSED.
TO FIVE FINANCE WHAT'S YOUR VIEW
ON THE LA -- HAD SOME
SUGGESTIONS SOME ALTERNATIVES
AND IN TERMS OF SUGGESTING A
MOVE AWAY FROM PART TIME AND
TOWARD FULL TIME FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN.
YEAH I MEAN WE AT THIS POINT WE
KNOW WE STILL NEED TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AS AS AS A
SUBMITTED BUT WE DEFINITELY HAVE
ARE TAKING THOSE -- THAT
FEEDBACK ELLIE -- PROVIDED AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS BROUGHT INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE DEVELOP A
REVISION -- THERE INTO THE IDEAS
OR THOUGHTS IN IN THOSE.
IN THOSE REPORTS HAVE MERIT BUT
WE NEED TO DO AN ANALYSIS AND
YOU KNOW TAKE THAT TAKE THAT
TAKE THEM INTO CONSIDERATION
WITH ALL OTHER FACTORS A ME TO
PUT YOU ON THE SPOT.
I DO APPRECIATE YOUR POSITION.
SIR LIVE ANY QUESTIONS YES.
SO.
BECAUSE SHE QUE HAS NO -- JEWEL
BILL ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS --
LOW INCOME KIDS ARE NOT
PRIORITIZE SAT CORRECT.
SO THAT IN THAT THERE ARE IN
THERE WOULD BE NO REQUIREMENT
THAT THIS WAS DONE AT THAT AT
TITLE ONE SCHOOLS WHICH ARE
POOREST SCHOOLS.
SO I GUESS MY CONCERN IS WOULD
THAT BE THE BEST EXPENDITURE OF
OUR MONEY EXPANDING THE T. K.
PROGRAM.
I AM I GUESS MY MY CONCERN IS IS
WE WOULD ONLY BE BUT WE ONLY BE
HELPING.
KIDS THAT COME FROM FAMILIES
WHERE THEY DON'T NEED THE HELP.
WELL IF THEY GET.
FROM FROM OUR POINT OF VIEW IT
DEPENDS ON HOW PRECISELY CONTROL
LANGUAGE WOULD BE -- I THINK THE
THE THE OPTION WE'RE RAISING IS
TO BETTER FOCUS THIS ON FOUR
YEAR OLDS.
AND THEN -- TO THE EXTENT THAT
DISTRICTS IN LOW INCOME%
COMMUNITIES HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
BID FOR THESE DOLLARS TRY TO
FOCUS THE DOLLARS BETTER ON
THOSE.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES THAT
OFFER.
OUR DAY.
ANYTHING SOMETIMES THAT'S A
PROBLEM RIGHT WITH OUR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES THEY DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE THE CAPACITY AND
WOULD HAVE THE CAPACITY TO BID.
SO.
MAYBE WE NEED TO MAKE A
REQUIREMENT THAT WE'RE GOING
AFTER OUR MOST NEEDY CHILDREN.
THERE'S ALSO BEEN A HELPFUL
CONVERSATION I THINK IN CD E..
AROUND TRYING TO WORK WITH AN
INTERMEDIARY NONPROFIT WHO CAN
HELP BILL CAPACITY.
IN DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS BECAUSE AS YOU'RE
POINTING OUT SENATOR IT'S A VERY.
DISTRICTS THAT NEED THIS
FUNDAMENTAL THESE CAPACITY YEAH
THE BILL.
YES OKAY WAS JUST SOME FOOD FOR
THOUGHT YEAH THANK YOU WELL
MAYBE YOU COULD CLARIFY FOR ME
WHAT BY CAPACITY WHAT WHAT ARE
THE LIMITING FACTORS IN.
SOME OF OUR POOREST COMMUNITIES
IN TERMS OF IMPLEMENTING.
T. K. PROGRAM.
WELL THIS IS MY FIRST RODEO IN
THIS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE SO I
HOW JUDGE.
SO I THOUGHT IF I FIVE AS GOOD.
QUESTION IS A VERY INTELLIGENT
BEAR WITH ME.
I THINK PROBABLY OTHERS YOU'LL
HEAR FROM TODAY THAT ARE BETTER
INFORMED ON THIS I DO THINK THE
TEACHER SHORTAGE IS A PROBLEM --
TRYING TO FIND TEACHERS THAT
HAVE EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH
YOUNG KIDS.
IS A BIG PROBLEM.
ESPECIALLY IN MORE RURAL AND
HIGH NEED AREAS WERE SALARIES
MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT LOWER --
FACILITIES I THINK IS A STELLAR
CONSTRAINT TO SOME EXTENT
ESPECIALLY AN AGING AREAS LIKE
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
FAR NORTH -- BUT I IDEA I THINK
THE OTHER PROBLEM HERE OUT THERE
FROM SMALLER DISTRICTS.
IS THAT THEY HAVE TO CONTRACT
OUT WITH A CONSULTANT OR THEY
HAVE TO FIND AN ARCHITECT OR
THEY HAVE TO WORK WITH FIRMS TO
TO PUT THESE BIDS INTO THE
OFFICE PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION AND IT'S NOT LIKE
OUT LA UNIFIED THAT HAS AN ARMY
OF PEOPLE. TO TO MAKE THOSE BIDS
SO I THINK THAT'S THE KIND OF
ORGANIZING CAPACITY THAT.
THE PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
AND THAT LAST PIECES OF FACTOR --
ACROSS THE BOARD NOT JUST ANTI
CAVE.
IN OUR ENTIRE.
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
PROCESS FROM MY PERSPECTIVE -- I
HEAR THAT TOO SO THAT.
THOSE POINTS THAT YOU MAKE
SHOULD INFORM OUR CONSIDERATION
OF OTHER PARTS OF THE BUDGET
WHERE WE'RE THE GOVERNOR AND
MINISTRATION PROPERLY IS
ATTEMPTING.
TO INCENTIVIZE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF TEACHERS AND
PROVIDE THE MONEY FOR
IMPROVEMENT OF FACILITIES.
AT ALL DRIVES TOWARD.
THE T. K. OBJECTIVE IF IN FACT
THAT'S OF THE OBJECTIVES THAT WE
WANT TO TRY TO TAME.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS PANELISTS.
THANK YOU FOR THE GREAT
PRESENTATION I LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER TALKING ABOUT THIS AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE BUDGET IN THE
REVISIONS TO THE BUDGET THANK
YOU DOCTOR PARTICULAR FOR COMING
VISITS.
OKAY LET'S RETURN TO THE BATTING
ORDER ON THE AGENDA ISSUE NUMBER
ONE CHILD CARE AND EARLY
EDUCATION.
BACKGROUND AND CASELOAD CHANGE
--
I USUALLY I'M USED TO HAVING LA --
AND FINANCE ON WINGS.
GOOD MORNING IT IS STILL MORNING
THANK GOODNESS.
IF I COULD ASK YOU TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD STARTING
TO MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING SIR NOVEL MORGAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION THE WAR IN THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US.
GOOD MORNING WITH SOME RESIDENTS
YOU AT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU MA'AM GOOD MORNING SIR
BERNARD THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
AND FAIR CORTEZ WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
RITUS THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
I GUESS FINANCE.
YEAH I'M STARTING RIGHT -- TODAY
AND THIS ISSUE IS A GOOD MORNING --
ALSO BE SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT --
THAT'S HAT WAS DISTRIBUTED TO
YOU AND I'LL COVER A FEW PAGES
ON THE HAND OUT FOR ISSUE.
ONE AND THEN I'LL COVER THE
REMAINING PAGES FOR ISSUE TWO
AND ISSUE THREE CELL.
AND KEEP LOS I'M SO FOR ISSUE
ONE TODAY I WAS ASKED TO GIVE AN
OVERVIEW WITH SOME BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ON CHILD CARE
INCREASED PROGRAMS.
SO STARTING ON PAGE ONE WE HAVE
A TABLE THAT SHOWS FUNDED
CHILDCARE AND PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS
IN THEIR KEY ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS.
THE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS VERY THE
PROGRAM COULD HAVE AN INCOME
ELIGIBILITY AGE ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENT OR SO SHE DID WORK
REQUIREMENTS DEPENDING ON THE
PROGRAM.
THE TOP PROGRAM LISTED CAL WORKS
HEALTHCARE IN THE BOTTOMLESS
PROGRAM LISTED TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN ARE INTENDED TO
SERVE ALL ELIGIBLE CHILDREN --
TO SERVE ADDITIONAL CHILDREN IN
THESE PROGRAMS A STATE WE NEED
TO CHANGE THE ELIGIBILITY RULES
OF THESE PROGRAMS.
THE MIDDLE TO PROGRAMS LISTED
ARE -- WHICH IS THE ALTERNATE
PAYMENT PROGRAM GENERAL CHILD
CARE PROGRAM AND STATE PRESCHOOL
THESE ARE REFERRED TO AS THE CAP
PROGRAMS THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
SERVED IN THESE PROGRAMS ARE
DETERMINED IN THE ANNUAL BUDGET
APPROPRIATION. TO SERVE
ADDITIONAL CHILDREN IN THESE
PROGRAMS THE STATE WOULD INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN THE BUDGET.
MOVING ON TO PAGE TWO SHOWS OUR
ESTIMATE OF THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN SERVED IN THE STATE
FUNDED PROGRAMS.
WE ESTIMATE FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND CHILDREN ARE
SERVED IN THESE PROGRAMS WITH A
LITTLE MORE OF HALF OF THE SLOTS
SPECIFICALLY AVAILABLE FOR PRE
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
WE WILL NOTE THAT THE NUMBER OF
CHILDREN ELIGIBLE ELIGIBLE IT
FOR THE STATE FUNDED PROGRAMS IS
FAR GREATER THAN THE NUMBER
SERVED.
MOVING ALONG TO PAGE THREE THE
STATE PROVIDES FOUR POINT SEVEN
BILLION TO CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS ON THIS COME
FROM THE MIX OF STATE AND
FEDERAL FUNDS WITH THE BULK OF
FUNDS USED FOR THESE PROGRAMS
ARE STATE FUNDS.
ON PAGE OF FOUR OF THE FIGURE ON
THIS FIGURE SHOWS THAT THE STATE
FUNDS PROGRAMS IN A FEW
DIFFERENT WAYS.
I'M IN OUR FIRST BUCKET HERE WE
HAVE VOUCHER PROGRAMS IS POWER
CHILD CARE IN THE ALTERNATIVE
PAYMENT PROGRAM AND THIS IS
WHERE THE STATE PROVIDES A
FAMILY WITH THE VOUCHER.
AND THE FAMILY CHOOSES A CHILD
CARE PROVIDER THAT BEST MEETS
THEIR NEEDS SO FAMILY CONSISTS
FAMILIES CAN CHOOSE TO HAVE
THEIR CHILDREN RECEIVED CARE
THROUGH A CENTER BASED SETTING.
A FAMILY CHILDCARE HOME OR
THROUGH A FAMILY OR FRIEND
[inaudible]
ABOUT YOUR THROUGH THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE WHICH I'LL DESCRIBE
MORE ON THE NEXT.
MOVING DOWN THE PAGE THE SECOND
THE SECOND BOX HERE -- IT WE
HAVE DIRECT CONTRACT PROGRAMS
HERE LOCAL PROVIDERS TO WORK
WITH THE STATE TO TERMINUS TO
DETERMINE A SET NUMBER OF
CHILDREN TO SERVE.
THESE PROVIDERS ALSO HAVE TO ME
AN ADDITIONAL SET OF
DEVELOPMENTAL STANDARDS AND
DIRECT CONTRACTOR FIGHTERS ARE
REIMBURSED USING THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE WHICH IS SET
ANNUALLY IN THE IN THE BUDGET
ACT.
AT THE BOTTOM OF THE PAGE WE
HAVE THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA HERE DISTRICTS A REPORT
ATTENDANCE IN THE STATE ON THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- FOR THOSE
ENROLLED CHILDREN.
AND MOVING ALONG TO PAGE FIVE
SHOWS ANNUAL FULL TIME RATES --
AND HE'S GREAT VERY BY PROGRAM
TYPE SETTING THE CHILD -- THE
STE THE SETTING THE CHILD SERVED
IN AND THE AGE OF THE CHILD
SERVED.
SO THE TWO BARS ON THE LEFT CHAU
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE HERE
RATES VERY BY THE REGION IN
ADDITION TO THE AGE IN THE
SETTING.
SUN TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE IS BASED ON
A TWENTY SIXTEEN SURVEY.
THE SURVEY IS CONDUCTED EVERY
TWO YEARS -- AND THE DAY OF FOR
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN SURVEY WAS
RECENTLY MADE AVAILABLE.
THE NEXT TO BAR SHOW THE
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE AND
THIS IS SAID ANNUALLY BY THE
STATE AND THE LOS SHOWS THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA TO
HAVE A COMPARISON OF ALL OF
THESE.
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS FOR
THE OVERVIEW TRANSACTION BUT I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
NEXT HOW ARE YOU.
SO I'LL COVER SOME OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS FOR
EARLY LEARNING AND CHILD CARE
AND I WOULD ADD THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
INCLUDES MULTIPLE INVESTMENTS.
TO IN PROGRAMS FOR ZERO TO FIVE
YEAR OLD IN THE STATE AND IT
REALLY FOCUSES ON A TWO
GENERATION WHOLE CHILD APPROACH
THAT AIMS TO STRENGTHEN THE
VARIOUS DEVELOPMENTAL --
EDUCATIONAL FINANCIAL AND HEALTH
NEEDS OF OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES -- PAGE SIX
OF THE HEARING AGENDA DOES A
GOOD JOB OF OUTLINING SOME OF
THE ADJUSTMENTS THAT THE
GOVERNORS.
GOVERNORS BUDGET HAS IN THESE
AREAS.
SO I WILL BRIEFLY COVER THAT
THERE ARE SOME TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING MADE
TO COVER SOME FOR YOUR COST OF
CERTAIN SLOTS.
AS WELL OF IT AS WELL AS
ADDITIONAL COLA AND GROWTH --
ADJUSTMENTS -- WE'VE NOTABLY
INCLUDED A HUNDRED AND NINETEEN
MILLION DOLLARS AN ON GOING ON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT I'M
GENERAL FUND. TO STAGE TWO AND
STAGE -- THREE CAL WORKS
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS -- WE BELIEVE
THE COSTS ARE INCREASING BECAUSE
THE CASELOAD IN BOTH OF THESE
PROGRAMS CONTINUES TO INCREASE
AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT FEES
INCREASE IS DRIVING CASE.
POLICY CHANGES THAT WERE MADE IN
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT THAT CHANGE SOME OF THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROGRAMS.
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER MORE
QUESTIONS ABOUT.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BARRISTER NOVEL
MORGAN BUT THE EARLY LEARNING
CARE DIVISION AND ON BEHALF OF
STATE SUPERINTENDENT TONY
THURMOND UP THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AT WE WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO ACKNOWLEDGE HOW FAR
WE'VE COME IN THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
INTO THINK MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR COMMITMENT
TO EXPANDING ACCESS TO YOU AS
WELL AS THE QUALITY OF EARLY
LEARNING.
GRAMS ACROSS THE STATE.
THANKS TO THE LEGISLATORS AFTER
IT'S OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
AS WELL AS THE FORMER GOVERNOR.
INVESTMENTS IN THE EARLY
LEARNING CARE SYSTEM ARE NO
LONGER BELOW THE PRE RECESSION
LEVELS THIS IS DUE IN LARGE PART
TO RATE INCREASES ACROSS THE
BOARD.
INTO THE EXPANSION OF STATE.
THE SUPERINTENDENT IS EXCITED TO
SEE THAT KNOWLEDGE MEN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET REGARDING THE
IMPORTANCE OF EARLY LEARNING
CARE.
AND THE FOCUS ON SUPPORTING THE
CHILD AND FAMILY MORE BROADLY.
EXPANDED ACCESS TO QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING CARE WITH A FOCUS ON
SUPPORTING THE WHOLE CHILD AND
FAMILY.
WILL BE ABSOLUTELY KEY DOES.
THERE TO BREAK THE CYCLE OF
POVERTY CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP AND STOP THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE.
AS WE DROP INTO ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT WE REALLY HAVE COME A LONG
WAY OVER THE PAST COUPLE YEARS
IT WOULD BE OUR CAO WORKS CHILD
CARE PROGRAM.
AS THE LA -- MENTIONED ARE CAO
WORKS PROGRAM IS DIVIDED INTO
THREE STAGES AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND MINISTERS THE
SECOND TWO STAGES OF THE PROGRAM.
WHILE THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES ADMINISTERS
THE FIRST STAGE.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA CHANGED
ELIGIBILITY RULES FOR EARLY
LEARNING CARE PROGRAMS IN TWO
WAYS.
THAT HAVE INCREASED CASELOAD IN
STAGES TWO AND THREE ARE THE COW
WORKS PROGRAM SENSE.
OR WHEN WE INCREASE THE INCOME
THRESHOLD FOR THE FIRST TIME IN
NEARLY A DECADE AND ESTABLISHED
A PROCESS FOR UPDATING THE
THRESHOLD EVERY YEAR.
AND SECOND WE CHANGE PROGRAM
RULES FOR THE PROGRAM SO THAT
PARENTS CAN RECEIVE A TWELVE
MONTH ELIGIBILITY FOR CARE WHICH
REALLY HELPS STABILIZE BOTH THE
FAMILIES THE CHILDREN.
AS WELL AS THE PROVIDERS.
PRIOR TO THESE CHANGES NEW CASES
AN ATTRITION OFFSET ONE ANOTHER
SINCE THE CHANGE AS ATTRITION
HAS BEEN.
REDUCED SIGNIFICANTLY ONE NEW
CASES CONTINUED TO BE ADDED AS
THEY HAPPEN HISTORICALLY.
PRIMARILY AS A RESULT OF THESE
CHANGES WE ARE PROJECTING THAT
AVERAGE MONTHLY CASELOADS AND
BOTH STAGE TWO AND THREE
COMBINED WILL BE ABOUT 29%
HIGHER IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
COMPARED TO TWENTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTEEN THE LAST YEAR BEFORE
THAT CHANGE DIVING IN A BIT
DEEPER FOR BOTH STAGE TWO AND
STAGE.
THREE CASELOAD INCREASE DEEPLY
EACH MONTH AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN STAGE TWO HAS SLOWED
DOWN SOMEWHAT IN THE CURRENT
YEAR WAS STAGE THREE CONTINUES
TO GROW AT A FAST PACE.
AS A RESULT OF UPDATED DATA WELL
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS ESTIMATING.
THE CURRENT CASELOAD PROJECTION
VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT IS INCLUDED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE ARE
PROJECTING A CONTINUED INCREASE
IN CASE I'D FOR BOTH PROGRAMS
AND THE BUDGET YEAR.
NOTABLY IN STAGE.
THREE STAGE THREE RECENT DATA
SINCE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS
XIN CONTINUOUS AND SIGNIFICANT
GROWTH SIR BUDGET YOUR
PROJECTIONS ESTIMATE A SLIGHT
SLOW DOWN BUT STILL SIZEABLE
INCREASING CASELOAD.
WITH AN AVERAGE OF APPROXIMATELY
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
ADDITIONAL CASES PER MONTH.
THIS TRANSLATES TO A SHORTFALL
OF ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MILLION AND
STATES THREE COMPARED TO THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND NATIONAL
AMOUNTS. FOR STAGE TWO WE ARE
STILL ALLEN ANALYZING THE DATA
AS IT COMES IN TO SEE IF WE
WOULD NEED ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
WE'LL HAVE AN UPDATE LATER IN
MAY THAT WE CAN SHARE WITH YOU
ON STAGE.
TO THE KINGS CANYON STEEP GROWTH
IN STAGE THREE REALLY IS THE
RESULT MAINLY OF FAMILIES AS
THEY MOVE FROM STAGE TO INTO
STAGE.
THREE AND AND SO THAT CONCLUDES
MY PORTION OF THAT SECTION.
THERE WAS A RECENT REGIONAL
MARKET RATE SURVEY.
IS THE OF ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERED.
UPDATING THE RATES ACCORDINGLY.
SIR FOR QUITE.
WE HAVE BE WE HAVE THE RESULTS
OF THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A
REGIONAL MARKET RATE SURVEY AND
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT IT AND WE
WE WILL TAKE.
ANY CONSIDERATIONS ABOUT OF WHAT
THE MARKET RATE WILL MEAN FOR
THE FIELD BACK WITH THE HAS
THERE BEEN ANY SORT OF
ASSESSMENT AS TO WHAT THE IMPACT
WOULD BE IF WE IF WE UPDATED.
WITH THE SURVEY WE DON'T HAVE
THE INFORMATION CURRENTLY WITH
US RIGHT NOW.
THE STAFF NOTES ALSO.
REFLECT THAT THERE'S SOME
CONTINUED INEQUITIES AT LEAST
WITH RESPECT TO SOME PROVIDERS
WHICH LIMIT THE POOL -- WILLING
TO PROVIDE FLEXIBLE CARE DID YOU
NOTE THAT -- COMMENT ON PAGE
SEVEN OF THE AGENDA UNDER THE
STAFF COMMENTS.
IT'S IN THE SECOND PARAGRAPH OF
THE STIFF COMMENTS
.
DO YOU.
DO ANY OF YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS
ON THAT POINT.
ANYBODY WANT TO JUMP IN.
DOES IT IN FACT DOES THE
INEQUITY IN FACT THE THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IN FACT MEAN
THAT THESE.
KATE THESE LICENSE EXEMPT
PROVIDERS OR UNWILLING OR UNABLE.
TO OFFER PART DAY ARE FLEXIBLE
HOURS EVEN IN THE FACE OF DEMAND.
I THINK WE SEE BROADER ISSUES
AND AND THEN ACCESSING CARE
BECAUSE THEIR SCHEDULES TEAMS SO
FREQUENTLY.
AND THAT'S NOT JUST AT FOR
LICENSE EXAM TO CARE THAT
AFFECTS THEIR ACCESS TO CARE
OVERALL.
AND IS THERE OF A MOVE AFOOT TO
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES
OR HAVE DID YOU MENTION THAT
NIGHT.
I DIDN'T CONNECT THE DOTS WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN TALKING ABOUT THEM
IT WOULD BE A PRETTY BAG POLICY
CHANGE.
SO IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
NEED A LITTLE BIT OF TIME TO
DIVE ITO YOU AND WORK WITH
ACROSS BOTH PARTNERS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ADDRESS.
BUT THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS AS
YOU LOOK AT NEW FAMILIES TODAY
AND A LOT OF OUR FAMILIES THAT
ARE LOWER INCOME AT TEN TO WORK
SHIFT SCHEDULE SO THEY MAY BE.
IN RESTAURANTS OR HOTELS OR AND
INDUSTRIES THAT REQUIRE SHIFT
WORK AND SAID BECAUSE AT THAT
THEIR SCHEDULES ARE VARIABLE.
I ASSUME IS A BUDGET IMPLICATION
OF TO THAT AS WELL.
HANDING ON HOW WE WOULD DECIDE
TO ADDRESS THAT THERE WOULD BE.
WELL I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION [inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS.
NO GOOD THANK YOU.
LA -- DID THEY GIVE YOU A CHANCE
TO FOLLOW UP DO YOU HAVE ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS -- I WILL JUST
NOTE ON YOUR ON YOUR LICENSE
EXAM QUESTION ON YOUR MIDDLE
THAT AND THE YES SO WE THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT -- THAT WAS
LOOKED AT AS PART OF FLASHERS
BUDGET -- AND AND THERE IF THERE
WILL BE A BUDGET IMPACT ON ON
INCREASING THE RATES FOR LICENSE
EXAM PROVIDERS HAPPY TO WORK
WITH YOUR STUFF IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN LINE AGAIN.
SIR DURING THE OFFER
[inaudible]
GOOD.
OKAY ANYTHING ELSE.
THANK YOU GOOD DISCUSSION.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE PRE SCHOOL
EXPANSION ISSUE NUMBER TWO PAGE.
EIGHT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR STATE PRESCHOOL --
FELONY OF TO SHIFT.
PRISONERS OKAY.
THANK YOU OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
OF RENDITION ALL TEN THOUSAND
FULL DAY STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL IS TO
ADD THIRTY THOUSAND STATE
PRESCHOOL SLOTS ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND SLOTS.
EVERY YEAR -- IN ABOUT EQUAL
AMOUNTS OF FUNDING TO COVER
THIRTY THOUSAND ADDITIONAL SLOTS
TO PROVIDE THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM TO ALL INCOME ELIGIBLE
FOUR YEAR OLD AS A FIRST STEP
TOWARDS UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
[inaudible]
ELIO -- SO I'LL START ON PAGE
SIX OF THE HANDOUT BUT I WAS
SPEAKING FROM EARLIER -- AND
JUST TO GIVE SOME BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ON THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
CURRENTLY SERVES THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS -- FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES CHILDREN CAN
PARTICIPATE IN EITHER THE PART
AND PART DAY PRESCHOOL OR THE
FULL DAY PROGRAM.
THE PARTY PROGRAM IS AT LEAST
THREE HOURS THE FULL DAY PROGRAM
IS BETWEEN SIX AND A HALF TO TEN
HOURS -- TEN AND HALF HOURS THE
THE HOURS A CHILD IS ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE BEYOND THE THREE HOURS
OF THE PARTY PROGRAM ALIGNS WITH
THE PARENTS WORK OR SCHOOL
SCHEDULE.
THE FULL DAY PROGRAM
SPECIFICALLY HAS TO KEY
OBJECTIVES THE FIRST IS TO
PROMOTE -- KINDERGARTEN
READINESS AND THE SECOND IS TO
HELP LOW INCOME WORKING FAMILIES
WITH THEIR CHILD CARE NEEDS.
STATE PRESCHOOLS OFFERED BY
SEVERAL TYPES OF PROVIDERS
THERE'S LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
ELEAZAR WHICH ARE SCOOL
DISTRICTS AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND THEN THERE'S NON
ELEAZAR WHICH ARE TYPICALLY
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS -- BECAUSE
SOMETIMES CITY GOVERNMENTS --
THE FIGURE SHOWS THE FIGURE HERE
SHOWS THAT A GREATER SHARE OF
NON ELLIE A SLOTS ARE FULL DAY
SLOT THE RELATIVE TO ON THE
ELLIE A SPOT.
ELEAZAR FOR ELLIE IS THE BOOK OF
THE SLOTS THAT THEY SERVE OUR
PART GAME.
ANON ELLIE GAYS WHO SERVE ABOUT
A THIRD OF ALL STATE BE SCHOOL
SLOTS.
OF THE SLOTS THAT NOT ONLY A SIR
ABOUT HALF OF THEM ARE FULL DAY
AND HALF OF THEM ARE PART DAY.
SO MOVING ON TO PAGE SEVEN THIS
FIGURE SHOWS THAT -- THE STATE
IS A VISUAL REPRESENTATION OF
HOW THE STATE HAS INCREASED FULL
DAY STATE PRESCHOOL SLOT
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE PAST FIVE
YEARS.
I'M SO THE STATE OUT IN MORE
THAN TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
FLIGHTS AND IT THIS IS AN
INCREASE OF 70% OVER THE TIME
PERIOD.
SO ON PAGE EIGHT DESCRIBES THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS WITH REGARD
TO STATE PRESCHOOL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- ALREADY DESCRIBED ON
THE FOR THE FIRST BILL THAT I
HAVE HERE BUT I WILL I'M DISCUSS
THE SECOND BUILDING THE THIRD
BOLD HERE IS -- SO THE SECOND
PIECE OF THE STATE PRESCHOOL IN
ADDITION TO ADDING SLOTS IS
EXPANDING THE ELIGIBILITY FOR
THE FULL DAY SLOTS -- SO
ELIMINATES THE REQUIREMENT THAT
FAMILIES HAVE TO WORK OR GO TO
SCHOOL IN ORDER TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THAT SIX AND A HALF TO TEN
HOUR DAY PORTION.
AND THE THIRD THING THAT THE
PROPOSAL DOES IS IT SHIFTS UP
THE CHIPS ALL FUNDING FOR NON SO
STATE PRESCHOOL IS FUNDED WITH
ON TO FUND SOURCES NIGHT
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT AND ON
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT AND IT'S SHIFTING
SOME PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
OUTSIDE OF THEN -- OUTSIDE OF
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING AND ELLIE A
SLIGHT ENTIRELY WITH NON NINETY
EIGHT DOLLARS.
I'M SO MOVING ON TO PAGE NINE IT
DESCRIBES OUR ASSESSMENT.
I'M SO WE THINK EXPANDING SE
PRESCHOOL FOR NON ELOISE IS
LIKELY TO ADDRESS THE ADDRESS
WORKING FAMILIES NEEDS TO WIN
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH PROVIDERS --
ALTHOUGH THAT WE SO THE STATE
DOESN'T COLLECT DATA
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS BUT OUR
CONVERSATION WITH PROVIDERS WAS
NON ELLIE ACE TEND TO OFFER
OPERATE LONGER PROGRAMS TEN OUR
PROGRAMS TWELVE HOUR PROGRAMS
PER DAY.
COMPARED TO SADDAM'S COMPARED TO
ELLIE A PROGRAMS WICH WERE
TYPICALLY SIX AND A HALF HOUR
DAY SOMETHING MORE LINE IN
ALIGNMENT WITH THE SCHOOL DAY.
ON THE SECOND THING IS THAT
STATE PROVIDES THE STATE AND
PROVIDERS NOT MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO EXPAND AS QUICKLY AS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES AND THIS IS
RECOGNIZING SOME ADMINISTRATION
AND LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES BOTH
AT THE STATE LEVEL WITH
ADMINISTERING THE SLOTS.
AND ALSO AT THE AT THE PROVIDER
LEVEL WITH PROVIDERS BEING
INTERESTED AND BEING ABLE TO
PICK UP THE SLOT -- SO.
IN SLOTS ON THE LAST TIME SLOTS
REMARKS FOR THEM IN -- TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THEY THEY USE
ALTHOUGH SLOTS BUT THEY RECEIVED
A MUCH SMALLER AMOUNT IT WAS
ONLY ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
COMPARED TO THE TEN THOUSAND
SLOTS AT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING.
I'M IN THIS BUDGET.
THE THIRD POINT HERE IS A
FACILITIES ARE A KEY COMPONENT --
FOR EXPANDING THAT WE'VE HEARD
ON THAT THIS THAT THIS COULD BE
QUITE CHALLENGING FOR PROVIDERS
IN ORDER -- TO IN ORDER TO SERVE
ADDITIONAL CHILDREN.
THERE SOME LOCAL BARRIERS SUCH
AS THE OWNING REQUIREMENTS THAT
EXIST AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
ALSO SOME STATE -- FROM STATE --
ADMINISTRATIVE THINGS THAT THEY
WOULD NEED TO DO PRIOR TO
SERVING MORE CHILDREN SUCH AS
I'M GETTING LICENSE MY COMMUNITY
CARE LICENSING.
ON PAGE.
TEN A WE NOTE THAT WE THINK THE
WORK REQUIREMENT IS REASONABLE
TO PRIORITIZE SCHOOL DAYS AND
THIS IS TO MAKE THIS IS THIS
ENSURE THAT HELP ENSURE THAT A
FULL DAY SLOT IS AVAILABLE FOR
THE FOR FAMILIES THAT NEED A
FULL DAY FUND.
IN UGANDA TIONAL CARE COMPONENT.
AND THE LAST THING HERE IS
REMOVING THE WORK REQUIREMENT
COULD SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASE THE
COST OF THE PROGRAM.
I'M IT'S XPANDING -- THE POOL
OF ELIGIBLE OF ELIGIBLE CHILDREN
FOR THE FULL DAY COMPONENT AND
UP AND A FULL DAY SLOT COSTS
ABOUT DOUBLE THE COST OF A PART
A SLOT. TO THE EXTENT THAT SOME
OF THE WOOD SOME OF THE PARTY
SLOTS WOULD CONVERT TO FULL DAY
SLOTS -- AND IF IT HALF OF THE
PAST A PATH OF THE PARTY THOUGHT
CONVERTED TO FULL THEY THOUGHT
IT WOULD COST AN ADDITIONAL
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY MILLION
ABOVE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. TO
SERVE THE SAME NUMBER OF
CHILDREN AND ABSENT ADDITIONAL
FUNDS IT COULD HAVE THE
UNINTENDED EFFECT OF SERVING
FEWER CHILDREN IN THE PROGRAM.
ON PAGE ELEVEN WE DESCRIBE A
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THE LEGISLATIVE LEGISLATURE'S
INTERESTED IN ADOPTING THE
GOVERNOR'S A LONG TERM GOAL OF
SERVING ALL LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR
OLDS A WORST WE'RE RECOMMENDING
FUNDING FEWER SLOTS IN THE FIRST
YEAR OF IMPLEMENTING THE SCHOOL.
I'M JUST GIVEN THE LOGISTICAL
CHALLENGES THAT I'VE MENTIONED
WERE RECOMMENDING A MORE MODEST
NUMBER OF TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINETEEN AND
THEN THE LEGISLATURE COULD
REVIEW HOW MANY SLOTS WERE
TAKING UP IN THAT FIRST YEAR AND
DECIDE ON A ON A AN APPROPRIATE
NUMBER FOR THE FUTURE. FOR THE
FUTURE YEARS OF IMPLEMENTING
THIS FALL.
A WE'RE ALSO RECOMMENDING
STARTING THE SLOTS MID YEAR THIS
WOULD GIVE TIME FOR CD E. -- TO
TO REVIEW AND APPROVE
APPLICATIONS FOR PROVIDERS -- TO
TO DO SOME OF THE LOGISTICAL
THINGS TO GET THEIR FACILITIES
GET THEIR FACILITIES LICENSE
HIGHER STOCK AND IN LITTLE
CHILDREN.
WE'RE RECOMMENDING WE'RE ALSO
RECOMMENDING PROVIDING ONGOING
FUNDING TO SIT TO ASSIST WITH
FACILITY ISSUES WERE
RECOMMENDING PROVIDING FOR
MILLION -- ON GOING TO LOCAL
PLANNING COUNCILS TO ASSIST
PROVIDERS WITH FACILITY ISSUES --
AND WE'RE A WITH FUNDS LOCAL
PLANNING COUNCILS WOULD HIRE
FACILITY SPECIALISTS TO HELP
PROVIDERS IDENTIFIED ADDITIONAL
FACILITIES.
WE'RE RECOMMENDING RETAINING THE
WORK REQUIREMENT FOR FULL DAY
PROGRAMS AND GIVING NEW SLOTS TO
PROVIDERS OPERATING AT LEAST
ATTEND -- GIVING YOU SOUGHT TO
PROVIDERS OPERATING AT LEAST A
TEN HOUR DAY AND THESE TWO RULES
TOGETHER WOULD HELP ENSURE THAT
THE PRESCHOOL SLOTS WERE
AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF FAMILIES.
AND WE DO AND WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF NON ELEAZAR OF A FUNDING NINE
ELLIE A SPOT FROM ONE FUND
SOURCE WE THINK THIS GIVES
ADMINISTRATIVE FLEXIBILITY --
THE LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO GO
FURTHER BY FINDING IT ALL OF
STATE PRESCHOOL WITH ONE ONE
FUND SOURCE BECAUSE IT STILL IS --
PARTIALLY MIX WITH PROPOSITION
NINETY AND NOT NINETY FUNDING.
THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS BUT
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
WELL I'D BE INTERESTED IN SOME
COMMENT ABOUT THE SHIFT AWAY
FROM THE WORK THAT WERE MADE IN
THE IMPACT BUT I SUPPOSE.
I SHOULD LOOK.
FINISH THE PANELS FINISH THE
PRESENTATION SO CITY.
THE THIRD SARAH.
JUST TO CONFUSE YOU ARE.
SO I HAVE YOUR DO YOU DOES IT
WORLD HERITAGE YEAH.
DOING A GREATJOB BECAUSE YOU
JUST START TALKING AND I DON'T
NEED TO FIGURE OUT WHO TO CALL.
IT WORKS VERY WELL.
AND MY ADVANCED AGE YES MA'AM.
SO AT FURTHER EXPANDING THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM IS A VERY STRONG FIRST
STEP TO EXPANDING ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES THAT REACH
RESEARCH SHOWS ASKING CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
BUT WE WOULD ALSO SAY THAT WE
THINK IT'S ABOUT OPPORTUNITIES
TO EXPAND EARLY ACCESS TO
EDUCATION.
WE KNOW THAT THEY'RE STILL GREAT
NEED FOR INCREASED ACCESS TO
INFANT AND TODDLER CARE AND MANY
OF OUR COUNTY STATEWIDE.
OVERALL THE NUMBER OF SUBSIDIZED
THOUGHTS FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS DECLINED BY 26% BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED STOCKS.
WE APPRECIATE THE SUBSTANTIAL
RATE INCREASE IN THE RATES FOR
INFANTS AND TODDLERS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED LAST YEAR.
WHICH WOMEN NOW MAKE IT EASIER
FOR PROVIDERS TO OFFER
SUBSIDIZED HIM INTO OTHER SPACES.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
CURRENT FUNDING FOR SUBSIDIZED
EARLY LEARNING CARE ONLY
SUPPORTS ABOUT 16% OF INFANTS
AND TODDLERS FROM ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES.
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF FINALIZING A REVIEW OF
APPLICATIONS FOR GENERAL CHILD
CARE TITLE FIVE INFANT TODDLER
PROGRAMS.
AND WHILE WE ONLY HAVE EIGHT
MILLION IN FUNDING TO PROVIDE.
THE APPLICATIONS REQUESTED A
HUNDRED NINE MILLION.
AT THE LEGISLATURE'S INTERESTED
IN DRESSING THIS ISSUE WE ARE
HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH YOU TO
IDENTIFY THE BEST WAYS TO INVEST
IN THIS MUCH NEEDED AREA IN THE
FUTURE.
AB MORE DEEPLY INTO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO PRESCHOOL.
WE KNOW THAT THIS INVESTMENT IS
MUCH NEEDED AS MANY THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES STILL LACK ACCESS TO
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING AND CARE.
TO GIVE YOU A QUICK BREAK DOWN.
BASED ON CENSUS DATA WE KNOW
THERE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND FOUR YEAR OLDS
IN CALIFORNIA.
OF THESE FOUR YEAR OLDS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND
ARE FROM FAMILIES WITH INCOMES
BELOW 85% OF THE STATE MEDIAN
INCOME WHICH MEANS THEIR INCOME
ELIGIBLE FOR OUR PROGRAMS.
AT THESE LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR
OLD ABOUT A HUNDRED NINETY ONE
THOUSAND ARE FROM LOW INCOME
WORKING FAMILIES WHICH MEANS
THEY WOULD CURRENTLY MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
EVER OUR PROGRAMS SERVE ONLY
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THOUSAND FOUR YEAR OLDS FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
OR ABOUT 37% OF ALL OF THE LOW
INCOME CHILDREN.
IN ADDITION TO CALIFORNIA STATE
PIECE C<c.cyan> PROGRAM WHERE WE</c>
KNOW THE QUALITY IS HIGH AND THE
STANDARDS ARE INTENTIONALLY
ALIGNED WITH WHAT PERMITS
CHILDRE'S DEVELOPMENT.
WE ALSO SERVE ABOUT TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND FOUR YEAR OLDS AND
OTHER CD PROGRAMS.
AND ANOTHER HUNDRED THOUSAND IN
THE TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
THAT YOU HEARD ABOUT EARLIER.
WE APPRECIATE THE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR HAVE MADE IN
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS TO EXPAND
STATE PRESCHOOL.
ADDING ANOTHER TWENTY THOUSAND
NEW FULL DAY OR THIRTY THOUSAND
A NEW TWENTY THOUSAND IN THE
PAST COUPLE YARS THEY WERE VERY
THANKFUL FOR THAT.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THESE NEW
THOUGHTS ARE FULL DAY FULL YEAR.
SAID THAT THE GOVERNMENT WHAT
THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING TO
ALLOW ALL LOW INCOME CHILDREN TO
ACCESS THAT FULL DAY FULL YEAR
QUALITY PROGRAM.
REGARDLESS OF THE PARENTS
PARTICIPATION AND WORK FORCE
ATTENDANCE AT SCHOOL.
THIS CHANGE WITH A LINE AS WITH
THE FEDERAL HEAD START
REQUIREMENTS AND WOULD PROMOTE
CHILDREN'S DEVELOPMENT AS WELL
AS SUPPORTING WORKING PARENTS
NEEDS FOR EXPANDED HOURS.
FINALLY THE FIND JEFF TO FIND
ALL OF STATE PRESCHOOL AT NON
ALLEY A L. E. EIGHTH AND I'M
GONNA REFER TO THEM AS COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS SO THEY
DON'T FEEL LIKE THE OTHER.
WITH NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND WILL GIVE OUR
CBO PROVIDERS MORE FLEXIBILITY
WITH THEIR FRIENDS SENSIBLE
UNITE ALL NON ALLEY A FIND UNDER
A SINGLE SOURCE.
HOWEVER WE ARE STONE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
GOVERNOR ABOUT SOME ASPECTS OF
THAT PROPOSAL.
WHAT HAVE WE LEARNED FROM OUR
RECENT EXPANSIONS WE LEARNED A
LOT THROUGH THE RECENT
AUGMENTATIONS ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES AND BARRIERS TO
EXPANDING STATE?
PROGRAMS IN EACH YEAR OF
EXPANSION INTEREST AMONG THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
FOR SLOTS OUTPACED AVAILABLE
FUNDS FOR THOSE THOUGHTS.
OVERALL IN YEARS FOR EXPANSION
FUNDING WAS AVAILABLE TO BOTH
ELEAZAR.
AND THE NON CBO SIDE CBO THE
PIPE FOR MORE THAN THREE TIMES
THE AMOUNT OF FULL DAY FULL YEAR
SOUGHT.
THAN ELEAZAR PRIDE.
FOR SO FOR EXAMPLE IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE MADE AVAILABLE JUST
OVER FIFTY EIGHT HUNDRED FULL
DAY FOR YOUR THOUGHTS TO ELEAZAR.
AND TWELVE HUNDRED FULL DAY FULL
YEAR TO THE CBO'S.
OF THOSE THOUGHTS FOR THE
ELEAZAR WE ONLY RECEIVED A
REQUEST FOR ABOUT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED FULL DAY FOR YEARS.
HOWEVER AT THE SAME PER THE
CBO'S WE RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR
SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN AS A REMINDER IF THERE
IS ONLY MONEY.
FOR ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
THEY DEFINITELY OUTPACED.
WHAT WE WERE AVAILABLE?
YOU ALSO CAN SENIOR AGENDA THE
ASKING AWARD FOR THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN YEAR WE ARE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF AWARDING
THE THOUGHT.
THAT WERE AVAILABLE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUT WE ALREADY
KNOW THAT THERE'S A MUCH HIGHER
REQUEST ON THE FULL DAY SPOT.
FOR CBO'S THEN WE CAN FIND TO
ILLUSTRATE THE ACUTENESS OF THE
GAPS CBO'S REQUESTED.
OVER TWO THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
FULL DAY FULL YEAR SPOTS WHICH
WOULD NEED TO BE SUPPORTED WITH
ABOUT THIRTY THREE MILLION AND
NON PROPOSITION. NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND IN ADDITION TO
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT FIND.
HOWEVER ONLY ONE POINT TWO
MILLION AND NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND IS
AVAILABLE THROUGH A CONTRACTOR.
SO WE WILL HAVE TO TELL MANY OF
OUR CONTRACTOR SEEN THAT THEY
WERE NOT APPROVED FOR EXPANSION.
BECAUSE THERE WASN'T THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE.
THE WHY HAVEN'T ELEAZAR CRIED
FOR THESE FUNDS THAT THE
QUESTION WE COMMONLY CAM.
WE HEARD FROM OUR CONTRACTORS
THAT IS DIFFICULT FOR AT LEAST A
OFFER FULL DAY FULL YEAR
PROGRAMS FOR SEVERAL REASONS
INCLUDING.
THE LOW REIMBURSEMENT RATES
ESPECIALLY SINCE MANY STAFF LA
PROGRAMS ARE COLLECTIVELY
BARGAINED AND THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE FOR OTHER PROGRAMS
IS MUCH HIGHER THAN THIS. FOR
MOST OF THE STATE.
THERE IS ALSO AN INCENTIVE FOR
PROGRAMS TO OFFER TO PARTY
PROGRAMS DURING THE DAY INSTEAD
OF ONE FULL DAY PROGRAM BECAUSE
OF THE WAY THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES.
FOR ADDITIONALLY ELEAZAR CAN
EARN MORE FROM SERVING FOUR YEAR
OLDS IN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN THEN THEY CAN EARN
FROM SERVING CHILDREN IN THE
STATE SCHOOL PROGRAM.
TKO ALSO HAS BUREAUCRAT MEANT
AROUND SOME OF THE STANDARDS FOR
RATIO THE GROUP SIZE THINGS THAT
DRIVE UP THE COST A LITTLE BIT.
THERE'S ALSO A LACK OF
FACILITIES.
THIS COME UP AS A BARRIER ALL
THE TIME FROM ALL OF OUR
PROVIDERS AND AGENCIES ACROSS
THE STATE THE DRESSING IN THE
BUDGET MOVING FORWARD IS KEY.
SHEET INCLUSION OF THIS AS PART
OF THE GOVERNOR'S KEY
INFRASTRUCTURE KEYS.
WE ALSO HEAR FROM SOME ELEAZAR
THAT FULL DAY FULL YEAR
OPERATIONS ARE DIFFICULT SINCE
OUR SCHOOL FACILITIES ARE CLOSED
DURING THE SUMMER.
HOWEVER WE WOULD WANT TO BALANCE
IS CONCERNED WITH BUT WORKING
FAMILIES NEED MOVING FORWARD.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR EXPANDING STATE
PRESCHOOL ALLOCATE SLOTS TO
COMMUNITY BASED PROVIDERS.
THAT HAVE DEMONSTRATED OVER THE
YEARS THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND SERVICES
AND ARE INTERESTED IN EXPANDING.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE FULL DAY
IN THESE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS OFTEN MEANS TEN
HOURS OR MORE WHICH REALLY
ALIGNS WITH WHAT ARE WORKING
FAMILIES NEED [inaudible]
AND SO AS WE LOOK AT ALL OF THIS
WE KNOW THAT MET THAT DEMAND IS
THAT PAY STATE WE THINK THAT
PAIRING THIS THOUGHT INCREASE
WITH THE FACILITIES WILL HELP A
LOT.
AND THE OTHER ISSUE THAT WE HEAR
A LOT IS THE WORK FORCE WILL BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT WHEN WITH
ALL OF YOU IN A LITTLE BIT.
SO I THINK IT WILL CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS UNLESS YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS WELL MAYBE YOU YOU
PROBABLY COVER THIS COULD YOU
JUST GO BACK OVER FOR ME THE
MAYBE RESPOND TO THE LA IS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WORK
REQUIREMENT ISSUE. FOR COULD
SOMEONE [inaudible]
SURE.
SO THE ADMINISTRATION'S ONE OF
THE MEASURES BIG GOALS FOR THIS
ENTIRE PACKAGE IS INCREASING
ACCESS TO THE SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS FOR OUR MOST.
VULNERABLE YOUNGEST LEARNERS SO
REMOVING THE WORK REQUIREMENTS.
IS ACTUALLY SOMETHING THAT WOULD
REALLY HELP FAMILIES WHO NEED
SUPPORT FROM THESE PROGRAMS AND
ARE FACING MORE OF THOSE
INTERMITTENT OF WORK SCHEDULES.
AND REALLY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THE PROGRAMS THEY WOULD
BE ABLE TO HAVE EXPANDED ACCESS
SPEAK BY REMOVING THE WORK
REQUIREMENT SO THAT IS THE MAIN
MOTIVATION BEHIND.
THIS PARTICULAR CHANGE HOW HOW
DOES THAT IMPACT HOW DOES THAT
INTERFACE WITH THE AVAILABILITY
OF SLOTS I MEAN ARE YOU I THINK
ALEJO'S CONCERN WAS.
IF YOU ELIMINATE THE WORK
REQUIREMENT.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE FOLKS
COMPETING FOR THE SAME NUMBER OF
FLOOD STOOD I UNDERSTAND IT
CORRECTLY.
AND THAT COULD.
HAVE AN ADVERSE IMPACT ON OUR ON
OUR OUR GOAL.
IN MY UNDERSTANDING A GROUP
MEMBER.
YES WE BELIEVE THAT BY TAKING
AWAY THE WORK REQUIREMENTS GOING
TO RESULT IN MUCH BETTER RESULTS
FOR OUR FAMILIES THAT WOULD
OFFSET SOME OF THESE ADVERSE.
OBSERVATIONS ARE BEING MADE BY
THE LA.
WELL WHAT ABOUT THE THE
INJECTION OF AN INCREASED NUMBER
OF THE THIRTY THOUSAND WELL IN
MY NUMBER. THIRTY THOUSAND ****
OVER THREE YEARS TO SERVE THE
LOW INCOME FORTY FOUR YEAR OLD.
OVER THE THREE YEAR PERIOD THE
CONCERNED AS I UNDERSTAND IT IS
TOO MUCH IN TWO SHORT OF TIME.
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT THE NUMBER
OF SLOTS SO WE ARE PROPOSING IT
IS IN A SLOW AND METHODICAL WAY
IT IS TEN THOUSAND SLOTS.
EACH YEAR AND I WOULD I WOULD
ALSO ADD THAT IT IS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH SOME OF OUR
OTHER PROPOSALS TO HELP
STRENGTHEN THE NTIRE SYSTEM AS
IS EXPANSION CONTINUES SO WITH
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT DOLLARS IN
THE EXPANSION.
EXPANSION OF THE PRESCHOOLS LOTS
WE BELIEVE THAT AS WE ALL WORK
TOGETHER IT WILL HELP CREATE
THAT FOUNDATION THAT WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT A SUSTAINABLE
EXPANSION OF SLOTS.
AND WE WHICH IS SAD BECAUSE WE
HAVE SEEN THAT DEMAND FROM THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
PROVIDE MORE PRESCHOOL AND TO
PROVIDE THE FULL DAY.
THERE'S A LOT TO CONSIDER AROUND
HOW TO SUPPORT THAT AND HOW TO
ADDRESS EQUITY ISSUES ACROSS THE
STATE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A HIGH QUALITY
PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS.
EVERYWHERE SO FAMILIES CAN
ACCESS THEM THE THINGS DE
CONSIDER AROUND ELECTRONIC
MONITOR TEEN ELECTRONIC OR PHASE
THINGS THAT WOULD REALLY MAKE IT
EASIER ON THE CONTRACTORS AND
EASIER ON THE DEPARTMENT ASWE
HAVE TO ADDRESS A LOT OF
APPLICATIONS.
WE'VE ALSO OBSERVE THAT FOR
EXISTING CONTRACTORS THAT CAN
TAKE THEM A LITTLE BIT OF TIME.
TO BE AWARDED THERE'S SOMETHING
AROUND HIRING STAFF REALLY
MAKING SURE THEY GET THAT
PROGRAM LICENSED IN UP AND GOING.
FOR BRAND NEW CONTRACTORS WHO'VE
NEVER WORKED WITH CD I CAN TAKE
A LITTLE BIT LONGER TO ACTUALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW TO DO BUSINESS
WITH THE STATE.
WE FEEL THAT ALL PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY THIS NEW ONES WOULD
BENEFIT FROM MARCUS TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
AND TRAINING AND SUPPORT ON HOW
TO IMPLEMENT A STATE CONTRACT
HOW TO ENSURE GOOD STEWARDSHIP
OF THE PUBLIC FUNDS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY HOW TO BEST SUPPORT
THE CHILDREN FAMILIES IN THIS
PROGRAM.
THEY'RE REALLY GETTING
ADDITIONAL TRAINING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BOTH AHEAD OF TIME TO
HELP ADDRESSES QUESTIONS
CONCERNS BEFORE AN RV WOULD BE
RELEASED.
AND THEN SUPPORTING PROGRAMS AS
THEY WOULD BE A REALLY GOOD WAY
A STRONG WAY TO CONSIDERING
COMPANY KNOWS THOUGHT INCREASES
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THAT. TO A CD HAS A PLAN.
TO IMPLEMENT THE TEN THOUSAND
PER YEAR UP TO THIRTY THOUSAND
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY.
WE FEEL THAT GETTING OUT IN
FRONT OF IT WITH ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WOULD BE
GOOD.
WE DO FEEL THAT IF WE REALLY
ESPECIALLY AS WE KEEP INCREASING
WHEN WE WOULD NEED TO INCREASE
THAT OTHER PIECES OF OUR SUPPORT.
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY FULLY TO
AT SO IS THAT PEACE IN INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET SOMEWHERE.
I'M JUST TRYING TO MAKE SURE IN
THE FACE OF THE AS WE MOVE
THROUGH THIS IS AN OPEN ITEM SO
WE'LL HAVE ANOTHER CONVERSATION
ABOUT IT.
AS WE MOVE THROUGH THE
CONCLUSION OF THIS PHASE OF OUR
BUDGET KABUKI DANCE.
THAT THAT ALL THE PIECES OF THE
BUDGET OR ARE WORKING TOGETHER
TO IN FACT IMPLEMENT THIS PLAN
TO ADD THIRTY THOUSAND PLUS OVER
THREE YEARS SO. TO SAY THAT
THAT'S A GOAL AND WE PUT IT IN
THE BUDGET WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THE CD HAS A FUNDING NECESSARY.
TO TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS WORKS
AND THAT WAS.
THAT WAS MY THE GENESIS OF MY
QUESTION.
YES -- IT IT JUST.
THAT WAS I GUESS THAT WAS A
QUESTION BUT I GUESS IT COULD BE
A STATEMENT IF YOU WANT TO WAIT
NANCE RELATED.
I I CAN COMMENT ON SO -- WE WE
DEFINITELY AGREE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE WE
DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
LOTS ARE SUCCESSFUL IN THAT CD
HAS THE CAPACITY. TO BE ABLE TO
DO WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE ON THEIR RULED
OUT EFFECTIVELY AND THERE IS.
THERE ARE.
THERE IS A PROPOSITION IN THE
BUDGET TO INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
POSITIONS THAT WE'RE GIVING TO
SPECIFICALLY TO THE EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE DIVISION FOR
FOR THEIR CURRENT WORKLOAD --
AND AS WELL AS THE FORTHCOMING
WORKLOAD WITH ALL THESE VARIOUS
BUDGET PROPOSALS.
THAT ENTERED THANK YOU SIR LEVEL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IS THERE.
A CONCERN THAT IF WE ELIMINATE
THE WORK REQUIREMENT AS PROPOSED
THAT WE MIGHT BE ADVANTAGE IN
THE WRONG FAMILIES THAT WE MIGHT
BE ADVANTAGE IN FAMILIES WHERE
THERE'S ONLY ONE WORKING PARENT.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE THE PARENTS WHO HAVE ARE
BOTH WORKING.
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT PARK
WERE PRIORITIZING SO IS THERE
ANY CONCERN THAT BY ELIMINATING.
THE WORK REQUIREMENT THAT WOULD
BE A PROBLEM.
THAT THAT IS A CONCERN FOR THE
WAY THAT THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PRIORITIZATION IS IS CURRENTLY
IN LAW IS IT'S AN AD CODE OF HOW
FAMILIES WILL BE PRIORITIZE
FIRST -- TO WITH FAMILIES
REFERRED BY CPS ON SECOND TO
FOUR YEAR OLDS BY LOWEST INCOME
TO HIGHEST INCOME AND THEN THREE
YEAR OLDS -- BY INCOME I'M SO IN
WITHOUT CURRENT PRIORITIZATION
SCHEDULE ON THE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN AMEND THAT
PRIORITIZATION THAT CURRENT
PRIVATIZATION I THINK YOUR
CONCERN IS VALID.
SO SO I WOULD JUST LIKE US TO
LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE HELPING THE
FAMILIES THAT NEED HELP MOST.
OF AND THEN SECONDLY.
I HAD A QUESTION ABOUT -- I
THINK THAT FINANCE I THINK THAT
THAT IS A GOOD IDEA TO ONLY
INCREASE THE RESCHOOL SLOTS BY
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED BECAUSE WE
DON'T USE ALL THE SLOTS THAT
WERE GIVEN EVERY YEAR CORRECT.
DON'T MANY OF THEM GO UNUSED
BECAUSE MY CONCERN WAS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WINE TO ADD.
TEN THOUSAND WE WOULDN'T WE ARE
USING EVERYTHING WE HAVE NOW
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
ARE ARE WE USING ALL THE SLOTS
WE HAVE AVAILABLE.
BUT YOU'RE CORRECT THERE IS SOME --
THERE ARE SOME SAVING THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM NOW.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE PUTTING THE SLOTS WERE WE
MOST NEED THEM [inaudible]
THAT'S ALL.
THE MAJORITY OF THE THOUGHTS
THAT HAVE STUCK ON AND USE THAT
WOULD BE PUTTING OUT AGAIN OUR
FOR SPECIFIC FOR ALLIE ACE ONLY.
AND SO THE PART THAT'S AVAILABLE
FOR FULL DAY FULL YEAR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THOSE ALWAYS
HAVE A MORE DEMAND THAN WE HAVE
FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR THEM.
SO COULD WE MOVE. ONE TO THE
OTHER.
I MEAN  KNOW ONCE CONSIDERABLY
MORE EXPENSIVE BUT I I JUST
THINK WE NEED TO FIND A WAY. TO
GET TO WHERE FAMILIES NEED US
AND NOT LEAVE MONEY ON THE TABLE
SO TO SPEAK WITH SLOTS BEING
UNFILLED.
CERTAINLY PLEASE TEN THOUSAND
SLOTS ON THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED
IN THE NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
ART SPECIFICALLY FOR A NON.
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THEIR
FUNDED BY NON PROPOSITION NINETY
DOLLARS SO WE BELIEVE THAT THERE
IS ENOUGH EVIDENCE -- THAT MISS
NOBLE MORGAN POINTED OUT. TO TO
SHOW THAT THERE'S A LOT OF PENT
UP DEMAND FOR SLOTS AT NON LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES FOOD IS
TARGETED IN THAT WAY.
OKAY THANK YOU ONE ONE THING I
WILL NOTE ON YOUR ON YOUR
COMMENT - ADDRESSING STATE
PRESCHOOL THROUGH ONE FUNDING
SOURCE WOULD ADDRESS YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT HAVING SAVINGS
THAT ARE ONLY EXPLICITLY
EARMARKED FOR ELEAZAR ONE
FUNDING SOURCE WOULDN'T YOUR
MARK THE FUNDS FOR SPECIFIC
AGENCY OR FOR SPECIFIC ENTITIES
TO USE THE STATE PRESCHOOL SLOT
SO THAT WE COULD BE ADDRESSED
THAT WAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYTHING FURTHER PANELS IN THIS.
ONE ANYTHING FURTHER IN A QUOTE
FOR THE QUESTION SEVERAL I JUST
WANTED TO I WANT TO GET YOUR
TAKE ON ELIGIBILITY MMA MAYBE I
MEAN THAT'S ANOTHER WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT RIGHT YOU KNOW --
WE KNOW THERE'S A LOT WE MAY BE
LEAVING THINGS ON THE TABLE BUT
THE FLIP SIDE IS ON WINDOWS AND
INCREDIBLE DEMAND OUT THERE.
AND I WONDER -- YOU KNOW IT.
IN THIS CAN OPEN UP OF A CAN OF
WORMS IN TERMS OF COST BUT AND
BUT IS THERE.
AT A TIME TO LOOK.
TAKE A GIVEN THE EVER INCREASING
COST OF LIVING FOR EVERYBODY
HOUSING EVERYTHING ELSE. TO
EXPAND ELIGIBILITY POLL FURTHER
AND IF SO WHERE IS THAT
CONVERSATION GOING WHERE WOULD
WE TWEAK IT WORK YOU KNOW HOW
HOW WOULD WE AND IT IS IT.
IS THAT CONVERSATION HAPPENING
ALL AND AND AND LIVING YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT.
JUST TO CLARIFY ARE YOU ARE YOU
SPECIFICALLY REFERRING TO INCOME
ELIGIBILITY YEAH YEAH EXACTLY.
WE DID INCREASE IN THIS PAST
BUDGET YEAR THAT WILL TAKE PLACE
AND STARTING JULY FIRST THAT
WENT FROM 70% OF STATE MEDIAN
INCOME TO COMMAND.
ALL THE WAY UP 285% THAT'S A
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT INCREASE.
NHà IS THERE OKAY.
A. N. -- THE DROUGHT.
I GUESS DOES THAT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT COST OF LIVING FROM
REGION TO REGION.
SO IT'S BASED ON STATE MEDIUM
INCOME SO IT TAKES SO WHEN SO IT
IS ACTION AT THE FEDERAL
REQUIREMENT TO BASE IT ON THE
STATE MEDIAN INCOME SO -- OF
LOOKING AT A FEDERAL LEVEL IT
TAKES AN ACCOUNT THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS A HIGHER COST OF LIVING IN
ANOTHER PLACE BUT IT DOESN'T DO
IT GEOGRAPHICALLY -- AMONG THE
HIGHER COST COUNTIES RELATIVE TO
LOWER COST AND THE REASON I ASK
THAT IS BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU GOT
FOLKS LIVING IN OUR CITIES WHO.
ARE READY ARE SPENDING.
YOU KNOW A HALF OF THEIR INCOMES
ON HOUSING [inaudible]
AND CHEN ACOSTA LIVING IS SOAKED
THROUGH THE ROOF AND THEN HAVING
TO KID YOU KNOW ADDS ALL SORTS
OF ADDITIONAL.
PRESSURES -- AND THE COST.
FOR YOU.
MARKET RATE CHILD CARE IS SO
EXPENSIVE.
SO I IT JUST KINDA MAKES ME
WONDER WHETHER THERE OUGHT TO BE
A LITTLE BIT EXTRA FLEXIBILITY
GIVEN TO THOSE PEOPLE LIVING IN.
BUT IF WE HIGH COST AREAS OF THE
STATE.
I WHICH COULD WE DO THROUGH
EXPECT EXPANDING -- ARE HAVE
MORE A. P. VOUCHERS.
WOULD THAT HELP IS CONCERNED.
IF I COULD EITHER I WROTE THE LA
I THINK SO I THINK WE DO HAVE --
WANT TO CARVE A DIFFERENT IN
TERMS OF COST OF LIVING SO WE'D
IN TERMS OF INCOME ELIGIBILITY
LOOKING AT A FAMILIES INCOME WE
DO NOT HAVE A REGIONALLY
ADJUSTED -- CHRIS SECRETARY AS
WE HAVE. 185% STATE ME IN INCOME
WE DO IT JUST FOR A FAMILY A
FAMILY SIZE TO DECIDE WHETHER TO
MONTH ALL DOUBLE THAT IS NOT
JUST ACROSS THE STATE.
AND SO THAT DOES MEAN THAT IF
YOU'RE NOT A HIGHER COST OF
LIVING AREA MAYBE THAT.
THERE THERE'VE BEEN SOME GOOD
NEWS AND SOME OF THOSE AREAS
MAYBE SOME FAMILIES.
SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE THAT ARE NOT
WHERE WE DO I JUST FOR COST OF
LIVING IS ON THE OR WE JUST FOR
REGIONAL COST IS ON THE THE COST
OF THE PROGRAM ITSELF THE
VOUCHERS -- ARE ARE PROVIDED
BASED ON REGIONAL MARKET RATE SO
IF YOUR IF YOU'RE AT A FAMILY
THAT'S GOING -- TO GET OUT GET A
CENTER SLOT IN THE BAY AREA
VERSES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
THAT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T HAVE ANY
EFFECT ON YOU BECAUSE WE'RE
PAYING WHATEVER THE COST IS --
BASED ON THAT REGIONAL MARKETS
RIGHT SO THERE ARE THOSE THOSE
DIFFERENCES THERE I THINK THE
THE ISSUE THAT.
THE ISSUE OF TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW HOW -- TO SERVICE CENTER
IS IT IS A DIFFICULT ONE WE HAVE.
RECENTLY CHANGE THE INCOME
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA AND ALSO
THE STATE MEDIAN INCOME IS NOW
IN STATUTE WILL BE AUTOMATICALLY
ADJUSTED AS WE GET NEW -- DATA
FROM NEW NEW INCOME EVERY YEAR
SO THERE IS A BUILT IN MECHANISM
WHERE IT WON'T BE AS IT WAS IN
THE PAST WHERE.
WE HAVE FOR A LONG TIME WE WERE
USING THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE
MEDIAN INCOME -- TO TO TO
DETERMINE ELIGIBILITY THAT
PROBLEM HAS BEEN FIXED IN COURT
AS WE ARE GOING TO BE UPDATING
IT BUT THE THE THE PLACE WHERE
WE HAVEN'T.
OUT THERE ISN'T ANY SPECIFIC --
ISSUE-- CHANGES RELATED TO THE
REGIONAL DIFFERENCES IN THE IN
THE INCOME OF THE FAMILIES.
YEAH I JUST THINK THAT'S A
PROBLEM I I UNDERSTAND THAT MAY
ADD A WHOLE THEIR LAYER OF
COMPLICATION IN YOUR MAYBE IT'S
NOT WORTH OPEN A CAN OF WORMS
BUT YOU KNOW A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ON THIS BUILDING IN OTHER
COMMITTEES ABOUT -- THE THE
RELENTLESS COST OF LIVING
PRESSURES ON PEOPLE IT'S
INJECTED INTO OUR WHOLE
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOUSING AND
WE'RE ACTUALLY CONTEMPLATED
PRETTY RADICAL STUFF -- IN THAT
SPACE AND IT IT JUST MAKES ME
YOU KNOW.
IN A BATTLE BABY MYSELF AND I'M
I'M I'M NOW FACING ALL NEW
ECONOMIC REALITIES FOR SO -- AND
NOT THAT I MEAN TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR IN THESE PROGRAMS BUT BUT
BUT YOU KNOW -- BUT IT BUT IT
CERTAINLY DOES AND YOU KNOW I
I'VE I'M JUST GETTING OF A REAL
CRASH COURSE AND AND ALL THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED AS I AS I TRY
TO PLAN OUT FOR THE FUTURE AND
AND I I REALLY DO WORRY ABOUT --
WHAT IT'S LIKE FOR FAMILIES THAT
ARE LIVING IN IN IN PARTS OF LOS
ANGELES FOR EXAMPLE SAN
FRANCISCO ETCETERA THAT -- THAT
ARE JUST BARELY STRUGGLING TO
MAKE IT.
I IN IN AN EXPENSIVE PART OF THE
WORLD.
I AND AND NOW THEY HAVE A KID
AND AND WHEN WE'RE NOT PROVIDING
KIND OF A LITTLE BIT EXTRA HELP
FOR THEM.
I GET I GET THAT THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE IS A LITTLE
BIT BETTER FOR THE PROVIDER
THAT'S FANTASTIC BUT I I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF REALLY GOOD
FOLKS BEING LEFT ON THE TABLE
HERE SO WE TALK ABOUT SLOTS NOT
BEING FILLED.
MAKES ME WONDER WHAT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY THERE TO HELP.
PEOPLE IN HIGH COST AREAS THAT
MIGHT BE REALLY STRUGGLING.
THAT WAS EXACTLY WHY WE ADDRESS
THAT STATE MEANING COME LAST
YEAR SO BEFORE THEY WOULD COME
IN AT 70%.
AND THEN THEY WOULD EXIT EIGHTY
FIVE BUT INSTEAD WE SIDE -- IT
WAS CHANGED SO THEY COULD COME
IN AT EIGHTY FIVE AND THEN ACTS
THAT.
SAID THAT WAS -- SPECIFICALLY
FOR THE HIGHER COST LEVINE AREAS
THAT'S GREAT.
LET ME ASK ONE FINAL QUESTION
AND I'VE MET CITY I'M SURE YOU --
YOU SAID THIS AND I MISSED IT.
WITH THE THIRTY THOUSAND SLOTS
OVER THREE YEARS TO THE NON
ELLIE A IS WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
DEMAND I MEAN WHAT'S THE UNMET
DEMAND.
IS THAT A FAIR QUESTION.
DO WE KNOW NUMBER OF CHILDREN
WHO WOULD STILL BE ELIGIBLE WHO
HAVEN'T WHO ARE ELIGIBLE BUT
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO SECURE OF
THE FREE SCHOOL OF FULL TIME FOR
ME TO SUGGEST WE HAVE THAT DATA.
I I GUESS I'M JUST TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW FAR WE'RE GOING
TO GET WITH THE THIRTY THOUSAND
THERE FOR JUST THE KERN AT THE
FOUR YEAR OLDS.
WE HAVE A A HUNDRED NINETY ONE
THOUSAND WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FRIEND
LOW INCOME AND WORKING FAMILIES.
WHEREAS WE WOULD HAVE THREE
HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND WHO
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE IF WE JUST
LOOKED AT INCOME WE CURRENTLY
SERVE A HUNDRED AND TWELVE
THOUSAND IF YOU LOOK AT THREE
HUNDRED AND SIX VERSUS A HUNDRED
AND TWELVE THOUSAND THEY'RE
STILL IT DEFINITELY AT LARGE
SHARE OF FAMILIES WHO.
ARE ELIGIBLE. ONE OF HIS PIECES
I SIDE WITH WE REALLY WANT TO
WORK ON WHERE PROGRAMS ARE
ACROSS THE STATE AND MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S MORE ACCESS AND
COMMUNITIES THAT TYPICALLY
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE.
TO OFFER THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
SO EVEN WITH THE EVEN WITH THE
THE HUNDRED NINETY ONE THOUSAND
THIRTY THOUSAND NOT GOING TO
FILL THE NEED.
CORRECT -- THAT RAIN.
COULD COULD I COULD I THINK MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE THIRTY
DOLLARS IN.
A NUMBER THAT THAT IS A PROPOSED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION WAS AN
ESTIMATE FROM THEM ON THE NOT
THE AMOUNT OF ADDITIONAL SLOTS
THAT WOULD BE NEEDED. TO SERVE.
TO TAP ENOUGH LOTS OF THAT YOU
WOULD SERVE ALL LOW INCOME FOUR
YEAR OLDS IN THE STATE NOW THE
NUMBERS ARE NOT.
QUITE A THE THING I THINK THAT
SEAT NUMBERS AT THE THE AFTER TO
HIRE.
THE COUPLE REASONS WHY THAT
THOSE NUMBERS ARE DIFFERENT ONE
IS THAT THE THAT THERE ARE GOING
TO BE.
THERE ARE SOME CHILDREN WHO FOR
EXAMPLE ARE ENROLLED IN HEAD
START PROGRAMS THAT ARE
FEDERALLY RUN THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO HAVE A GOOD WE DON'T DO A
GOOD JOB OF COMBINING DATA
SOURCES SO THAT WE CAN.
UNDERSTAND HOW MANY OF THOSE
HEAD START STUDENTS -- ARE ARE
BEING SERVED THERE IN ARE NOT
ALSO.
SERVED AS THE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
AND THEN THERE IS WITH ALMOST
ANY BOB PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AT ANY
OF THE OF THESE KINDS OF EARLY.
EDUCATION PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY -- YOU DON'T HAVE ALL A
100% OF ELIGIBLE FAMILIES WHO
WANT THIS THE THE THE SLIGHT
EVEN IF EVEN IF IT'S AVAILABLE
SO THERE IS SOME KIND OF SET A
REASONABLE EXPECTATION THAT YOU
MIGHT.
HAVE THAT THAT NOT ALL STUDENTS
WHO ARE WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TEND
FOR EXAMPLE NOT EVERY.
NOT NOT EVEN EVERY L. G. NOT
EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA TEND
THE PUBLIC KINDERGARTEN FOR
EXAMPLE -- SO YOU HAVE SOME
SIMILAR EXPECTATIONS IN THE
PRESCHOOL SIDE SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE THIRTY
THOUSAND WAS AN ATTEMPT. TO TO
COME UP WITH WHAT INCREASED IS
NECESSARY FOR STATE PRESCHOOL SO
THAT WE WOULD BE AT THE STATE
SERVING ALL LOW INCOME CHILDREN
WHO ARE ELIGIBLE AND WHOSE
FAMILIES ARE INTERESTED IN
RECEIVING A SLOT GOT IT IN ME
THAT.
THAT HELPED.
IF I MAY ASK ON THE DAILY -- BUT
THAT HE'S EXACTLY RIGHT SO THE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL IS
TO SERVE ALL LOW INCOME FOUR
YEAR OLDS SO THE THIRTY THOUSAND
WAS JUST AN ESTIMATE OF THOSE
NOT BEING SERVED AT THE TO TRY
TO GET THERE YES.
SO AS I'M CERTAIN WE'RE TRYING
TO IMPROVE OUR OUR DATA
COLLECTION AS WE ARE AS I'VE
LEARNED ACROSS THE ENTIRE
EDUCATION SPECTRUM.
PERFECT I WAS GONNA SAY THAT WAS%
THE ACTUALLY HAD ON A PERFECTLY
WE HAVE A LOT OF DATA CHALLENGES
AROUND AND DUPLICATE ACCOUNTS OF
CHILDREN.
THE UNDERSTANDING WHERE CHILDREN
ARE NOT THEY'RE BEING SERVED BY
HEAD START FOR SAYS AS STATE
PROGRAM ISN'T SOMETHING THAT
WERE ABLE TO GET TO VERY EASILY
FELT THE LA AHEAD I'M NOT
CORRECTLY.
AND EARLY WE HAVE DATA
CHALLENGES PRES THROUGH CAREERS
SO I KNOW WE'RE TRYING TO FIX
THAT THE HORIZONTAL AND VERTICAL
AND IT JUST TO GO BACK OVER ONE
OF MY DATA POINTS.
WE DO SERVE ABOUT TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND FOUR YEAR OLDS IN OTHER
CD PROGRAMS THAT THEY MAY BE AND
CAL WORKS OR USING A VOUCHER.
TAXES THAT AND THEN ANOTHER
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOUR YEAR OLDS
ARE IN TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
INFORMATION AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE PRESENTATION.
WILL MOVE ON TO THE NEXT --
ISSUE ISSUE NUMBER THREE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION ONE TIME
INVESTMENT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
INCLUDES FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND.
A ONE TIME FOR A VARIETY OF
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT PROGRAMS TEN
MILLION DOLLARS IS DEDICATED TO
A STRATEGIC MASTER PLAN THAT IS
GOING. TO BE USED TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE THESE GAPS SO
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT TODAY -- BUT
ALSO TO BUILD UPON ALL THE GREAT
WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE BY MY
PREVIOUS STUDIES AND TO PROVIDE
A STRATEGIC PLAN FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND TO AID IN
THEIR DECISION MAKING -- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS PATH OF
EXPANDING CHILDCARE AND AND
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL.
OF THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION ONE
TIME ALSO INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND TWO HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE MILLION -- FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT -- MONEY WILL BE
USED TO HELP MOVE -- CARE
PROFESSIONALS ALONG THEIR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
CONTINUING.
AND THE TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
MILLION FOR INFRASTRUCTURE WE
USE FOR US SUBSIDIZE CHILDCARE.
BUILDINGS OUT NON LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THANK YOU
[inaudible]
HELLO.
LET'S ALL BE STARTING ON PAGE
TWELVE THE LA -- HAND OUT I'M SO
THIS PROVIDES A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ABOUT THE IN THE
TOPIC AREAS WHERE THE GOVERNOR
HAS PROPOSED -- SOMEONE TIME
IMPROVEMENT INITIATIVES SO WITH
REGARDS TO WORK OUT TO IT.
WITH REGARD TO THE CHILD CARE
PRESCHOOL WORK FORCE -- CHILD
CARE AND PRESCHOOL WORKERS MUST
MEET CERTAIN EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AND HE'S VERY FIVE
FIVE PROVIDER TYPE AND THE
POSITION THAT THE EMPLOYER HAS
WITHOUT PROVIDER.
WITH -- WITH REGARDS TO
FACILITIES WE DON'T HAVE A LOT
OF INFORMATION ABOUT A FACILITY
ARRANGEMENTS OF PROVIDERS BUT
FROM OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
PROVIDERS THEY TEND TO HAVE
THREE COMMON FACILITY
ARRANGEMENTS.
AND THE FIRST WOULD BE PROVIDERS
ON TECH COULDN'T LEASE AT
SUBSIDIZED RATE SO THIS WOULD BE
A PROVIDER HAVING A PARTNERSHIP
WITH A PUBLIC ENTITY ONE EXAMPLE
THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM PROVIDERS
IS THAT THEY'RE PAYING ONE
DOLLAR A YEAR TO WRITE
FACILITIES FROM A CITY
GOVERNMENT.
ON THE OTHER -- ARRANGEMENT
COULD BE LEASING AT MARKET RENT
THEIR THEIR LEASING OF A SPACE
AND PAYING MARKET.
A MARKET RATE RENT FOR THAT
SPACE AND THEN THE OTHER
ARRANGEMENT WOULD BE OWNING
EITHER EITHER PAYING A MORTGAGE
OR THEY PAID OFF THE MORTGAGE
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN THERE FOR
MANY YEARS -- PAGE -- THIRTEEN
DESCRIBES SOME OF THE SPECIAL
STATEWIDE PLANNING EFFORTS THAT
HAVE BEEN UNDERTAKEN IN THE PAST
FEW YEARS AND THESE INCLUDE THE
ASSEMBLY IS BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION -- ON EARLY EDUCATION
THAT BEGAN MEETING -- TWO YEARS
AGO AND RECENTLY RELEASED A
DRAFT SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
HOW TO IMPROVE THE SYSTEM.
ANOTHER WORK GROUP -- PUBLISHED
A SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND
THE RATE SYSTEM -- CD E. WAS --
THAT SAID THE CD IS SERVICE IS
CURRENTLY WORKING ON A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AND A STRATEGIC PLAN
THROUGH THE PRESCHOOL DEVELOPING
GRANT THAT THE STATE WAS
RECENTLY AWARDED -- AND THEN
THERE IS A AND OTHERS A RESEARCH
AND HE WORKING ON A WORK FOR
CITY -- THAT WILL PROVIDE SOME
REGIONAL INFORMATION AND
STATEWIDE INFORMATION ON THE ON
WHAT THE WORK FORCE THAT EARLY
THE THE CHILD CARE PRESCHOOL
WORKFORCE LOOKS LIKE -- IN
CALIFORNIA BOTH REGIONALLY AND
STATEWIDE AND LATE -- TWENTY
TWENTY ON PAGE.
FOURTEEN DE IS THE GOVERNOR'S A
SUMMARY OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DISCUSSES CONTENT ON
THIS PAGE SO I MOVE ON TO PAGE.
FIFTEEN I'M SORRY THIS IS START
THEIR DISCUSSION FIFTEEN STARTS
OUR DISCUSSION ON THE ASSESSMENT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S ONE TIME
INITIATIVES.
A WE THINK THE WORK FORCE AND
FACILITY ISSUES ARE KEY THESE
ARE THINGS THAT COMMONLY COME UP
AS BIG AREAS OF CONCERN FOR
CHILDCARE PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS --
OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE STATE
LACKS SOME DATA TO MAKE INFORMED
DECISIONS ON HOW THE STATE WOULD
PRIORITIZE AND TARGET THE FUNDS
AND USE THEM EFFECTIVELY.
A WITH REGARD TO THE WORK FORCE
PROPOSAL THE STATE DOES IT KNOW
WHAT GEOGRAPHIC AREAS NEED
ADDITIONAL CHILDCARE PERSONAL
WORKERS WE DON'T HUNT AND WE
DON'T HAVE INFORMATION ON THE
EDUCATION ATTAINMENT LEVELS OF
THESE EMPLOYEES -- SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION WILL COME -- AS THAT
AS THAT RESEARCH GROUP WILL
RELEASE THEIR STUDY BUT THAT'S
COMING IN LATE.
TWENTY TWENTY WITH REGARD TO THE
FACILITY PROPOSAL THE STATE
DOESN'T COLLECT INFORMATION.
ON THAT WOULD ALLOW IT TO
DETERMINE THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
FACILITY CHALLENGES FACING
PROVIDERS OR THE GEOGRAPHIC
AREAS EXPERIENCING THE GREATEST
CHALLENGE AS AND THEN WE ALSO
THINK ANOTHER PLAN IS
DUPLICATIVE OF MANY OF THE
RECENT EFFORTS -- AROUND AROUND
PLANNING AND STRATEGIC PLANS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE THE CHILD CARE AND PRE
SCHOOL SYSTEM THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED RECOMMENDATIONS MIGHT
OVERLAP SIGNIFICANTLY WITH WHAT
WHAT IS ALREADY AVAILABLE ARE
UNDER WAY.
ON PAGE SIXTEEN IS OUR
RECOMMENDATION OF FOR THE ONE
TIME IMPROVEMENT INITIATIVE
WE'RE RECOMMENDING GETTING
BETTER INFORMATION BEFORE
FUNDING AN INITIATIVE SO HOLD
OFF ON SPENDING THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IMMEDIATELY --
CONSIDER SETTING ASIDE SOME
AMOUNT OF MONEY EITHER MORE OR
LESS -- INTO ACCOUNT
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNATED FOR
CHILDCARE FUTURE CHILD CARE
EXPANSION AND IMPROVEMENT
EFFORTS.
WE IDENTIFY TO AREAS THAT THE
STATE MIGHT WANT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION TO STRATEGICALLY
PRIORITIZE FUNDS AND WE
CONSIDERED SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT IT WILL BE
COMING AVAILABLE -- THE FIRST
AREA IS AROUND FACILITY
ARRANGEMENTS AND BETTER
UNDERSTANDING WHAT ARE THE
FACILITY ARRANGEMENTS THAT
CURRENT HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS
HAVE AND WHAT ARE THEIR
MAINTENANCE ISSUES WHAT ARE SOME
FACILITY LIABILITIES IN THIS
RECOMMENDATION IS FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING FACILITY ISSUES OF
CURRENT PROVIDERS SO THAT WE ARE.
NOT THE STATE IS KNOWLEDGEABLE
WHEN DEVELOPING A PROGRAM FOR OF
X. OF HIS OF FOR FUTURE FACILITY
EXPANSION.
ON THE OTHER WAS STUDY THAT
WE'RE RECOMMENDING IS SERVING L. --
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES AND BETTER
UNDERSTANDING THE NEEDS OF THESE
FAMILIES I'M IN THE STUDY IS
THERE'S A STRATEGICALLY DEFINE A
DESIGN AND INCREASED CHILDCARE
PRESCHOOL EXT.
THINK ABOUT HOW CARING SPREE
PRESCHOOL EXPANSION IN A
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE NEEDS OF
FAMILIES.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT.
HAPPENING ADDITIONAL STUDIES IN
GETTING THE INFORMATION TO
INCLUDED IN A IN A STATE PROGRAM
WOULD TAKE TIME I'M SO THAT THE
DECISIONS OF THE STUDIES --
COULD IN COULD INFORM THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
BUDGET -- THIS CONCLUDES MY
REMARKS BUT HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS WELL BEFORE WE GO TO
THE CD JUST TO THROW A COUPLE
THINGS THAT MAYBE YOU COULD
COVER IN YOUR PRESENTATION.
I WOULD BE INTERESTED IN IN AND
MAYBE YOU'VE COVERED IT AND I
JUST.
MY OLD BRAIN IS SLOW I'M TRYING
TO GET A HANDLE ON WHAT
INFORMATION WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW CHILD CARE AND PRE
SCHOOL FACILITIES AND WORK FORCE.
NUMBER.
ONE A NUMBER TO HAVE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE THE NEW.
STUDY.
COURSE TO TO STUDIES I GUESS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PROPOSED.
WILL.
INTERFACE WITH STUDIES THAT
APPARENTLY IN COMMISSION REPORTS
OF CURRENTLY FORTY BEEN
CONDUCTED IN RELEASED OR IN THE
PROCESS WHETHER IT'S THE
ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
OR THIS OTHER WORKGROUP ON RATE
STRUCTURES OR THE WORKFORCE
STUDY THAT APPARENTLY IS.
GOING TO BE RELEASED IN LATE.
TWENTY TWENTY WE WERE CUSTOM
DOING A LOT OF STUDIES UP HERE
AND SEEING A LOT OF STUDY
PROPOSALS AND THIS IS YET
ANOTHER ONE BUT HOW DO HOW DO WE
GET OUR ARMS AROUND THIS AND
FIGURE OUT.
WHAT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION WE
NEED WHAT WE'VE SEENTHREE OTHER
TIMES IN DIFFERENT VERSIONS AND
OR WE SIMPLY FOR FUNDING?
ANOTHER STUDY THAT'S NOT REALLY
A QUESTION FOR WHICH I APOLOGIZE
BUT I WANTED TO THROW THAT OUT.
CITY BEFORE YOU PRESENTED AND
MAYBE YOU COULD HELP COVER THAT.
I AN SPEAK TO THE GOVERNOR'S ON
STRATEGIC MASTER PLAN AND AND
WHAT THE INTENTION IS AND HOW
IT'S GOING.
TO A PROVIDE NEW INFORMATION AND
AND COVERED.
SOME OF THE DATA COLLECTION THAT
THAT WE'RE SHORT REALLY
STRUGGLING TO GET SO -- THIS
MASTER PLAN IS IS INTENDED TO
BUILD OFF ALL OF THESE OTHER
GREAT PLANS WE KNOW THAT CD HAS
THEIR PRESCHOOL -- DEVELOPMENT
GRANT -- A NEEDS ASSESSMENT THAT
THEY'RE DOING AS WELL AS THE
ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
THE THE WORK GROUP ON ON RACE
THERE BEEN.
SO MANY GREAT PLANS HAVE BEEN
OUT THERE AND THIS PARTICULAR
MASTER PLAN IS VERY IS.
PLANNING ON BUILDING ON TOP OF
ALL OF THOSE -- THOSE PLANS
PROVIDE A LOT OF GREAT POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS THIS MASTER PLAN
ONCE THE LINK THOSE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS TO STRATEGIES
AND ONE OF THE REALLY.
BIG EMPHASES THAT ODD THIS PLAN
IS GOING TO ADDRESS IS ALSO
LOOKING OUT FUNDING SOURCES SO
IDENTIFYING -- THE FUNDING
SOURCES THAT WOULD REALLY MAKE
THIS ENTIRE SYSTEM MUCH MORE
SUSTAINABLE LOOKING AT
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING SOURCES
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
REALLY GETTING INTO THE WEEDS
ABOUT WHAT EXACTLY IT WOULD TAKE
FINANCIALLY. TO TO CREATE THE
PROGRAMS AND AND THE THE ACCESS.
THAT FAMILIES NEED -- WITHIN
THESE THESE LARGER CHILD CARE
SYSTEM I I GET IT.
I UNDERSTAND.
GOOD POINTS YES MA'AM.
YES MARY.
ALWAYS OKAYFEMINIST I REWORKED
FOR US AS WE DIVE INTO THE WORK
FORCE ISSUE WE KNOW FROM THE
RESEARCH -- ACTUALLY MINUTE BACK
UP AND JUST AT THE HOW MUCH WE
APPRECIATE THAT IN ADDITION TO
THE STARK ACT -- INVESTMENT IN
ACCESS THAT THESE ARE BEING
PAIRED WITH MUCH NEEDED
INVESTMENTS IN EARLY LEARNING
CARE SYSTEM OVER ALSO WORK FOR
SOME FACILITIES OR THINGS WE
HEAR ABOUT DALY.
pTHE STATE THAT THEY REALLY NEED
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS AND SO
STARTING WITH THE WORK FORCE WE
KNOW THAT RESEARCH REALLY SHOWS
THE QUALITY AND RESPONSIVENESS
OF CHILD ADULT INTERACTIONS.
IN THE EARLY LEARNING CARE
ENVIRONMENTS -- MAJOR PREDICTOR
OF CHILD OUTCOMES FOCUSING ON
THOSE ADULTS THOSE ARE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING THE CARE IS THE MOST
CRITICAL PART OF ANY EXPANSION.
WITH THAT WE WILL ALWAYS THERE
BEFORE WE DIVE INTO THEIR ACTUAL
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING THE HIGHER
EDUCATION PORTFOLIO THAT THEY
MAY NEED WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON
COMPENSATION.
AND ENSURING THAT THE WORK
FORCES ADEQUATELY COMPENSATED
RESEARCH TELLS US THAT 58% OF
CHILD CARE WORKER FAMILIES
PARTICIPATE IN ONE OR MORE
PUBLIC INCOME SUPPORT PROGRAMS.
CITIES TEACHERS THEMSELVES MAKE
A FRACTION OF WHAT KINDERGARTEN
TEACHERS MAKE AND DON'T HAVE THE
DIGITAL RESOURCES TO PAY FOR THE
COURSE WORKER TRAINING.
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS RECOGNIZED THE IMPORTANCE OF
IMPROVING QUALITY BY INCREASING
THE KNOWLEDGE AND COMPETENCIES
OF THE WORK FORCE.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THAT IT IS
PARA AND RECOGNIZE THAT THEY
WILL NEED FINANCIAL SUPPORT IN
ORDER TO ACCESS THE COURSE WORK
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
AS WE DIVE AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
LESSNS LEARNED OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS FROM QUALITY
PROJECTS THAT HAVE BEEN FUNDED.
THROUGH BOTH RC CDF OUR
CHILDCARE AND DEVELOPMENT FUND
QUALITY PROJECTS WE HAVE
SOMETHING CALLED AB TWO TWELVE
THERE'S ALSO BEEN SENDING THAT
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA FUNDED IN
THE PAST CALLED FIRST FIVE CARES.
THROUGH THOSE WORKFORCE EFFORTS
AS WELL AS OUR CURRENT QUALITY
COUNTS CALIFORNIA QUALITY
READING IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM WE
HAVE A LOT OF LESSONS LEARNED
THAT WE THINK WE ON THE TO KEEP
IN MIND AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
SO I WAS STRESSED OVER AND OVER
THE IMPORTANCE OF BEING
INTENTIONAL ENSURING THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE WORK FORCE YOU
REALLY NEED TO WRAP AROUND.
THE EDUCATIONAL PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING GOALS THAT THEY SAT TO
ENSURE THAT THEY CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL IN ACHIEVING THEM.
ONE KEY THING WE FOUND WAS THE
IMPORTANCE OF ADVISORS A FORMER
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
WAS UNIQUE IN THAT REQUIRED
PARTICIPANTS TO MEET WITH AN
ADVISOR TWICE A YEAR.
WHO COULD HELP MAP OUT THEIR
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING JOURNEY
ADVISE THEM WHAT TRAININGS AND
COURSE WORKS THAT THEY COULD
TAKE TO HELP THEM ACHIEVE THAT?
FROM THE RESEARCH ON EVALUATION
OF THAT PROGRAM THE NUMBER ONE
THING THAT THE PARTICIPANTS THAT
MADE A DIFFERENCE WAS EIGHT THEY
FELT VALIDATED AND THEIR
PROFESSION.
MEETING WITH THAT ADVISER MADE
THEM FEEL HEARD AND IMPORTANT IN
THEIR WORK.
SECOND WITH COURSE WORK THAT
DEVELOPS KNOWLEDGE AND
COMPETENCIES SO MUCH OF PROGRAM
QUALITY ACTUALLY DEALS WITH
PERFECTING THAT CHILD ADULT
INTERACTION.
THE WINNING COURSE WORK THAT
INCLUDES STRONG PRACTICE BASED
COMPONENTS THAT'S BEST FOUND TO
PROMOTE CHANGES AND PRACTICE.
AND PERMITS KNOWLEDGE AND
COMPETENCIES VERSUS JUST THEORY
OF CHILD DEVELOPMENT.
AT ENSURING THAT WE HAVE LINKS
COURSES ONE OF THE TOP BARRIERS
FOR EARLY EDUCATORS AND GETTING
THEIR CHILD DEVELOPMENT PERMIT.
MOVING ON TO GET AN AIRING OR A
BA IS ACTUALLY OBTAINING THE
GENERAL ED REQUIREMENTS THOSE
MATH AND ENGLISH COURSES.
THEY REALLY SEEM TO BE A
STICKING POINT FOR THEM IF YOU
CAN LINK OF COURSE BETWEEN MATH
AND ENGLISH WITH SOMETHING WITH
CHILD DEVELOPMENT WE FOUND THAT
IS A STRATEGY THAT HELP THEM.
BE MORE SUCCESSFUL IN GETTING
THROUGH THOSE G. COURSES WE ALSO
FOUND A POWER OF COHORTS.
OR APPRENTICESHIP MODELS THAT
WHEN YOU BAD IN BED A COHORT
TOGETHER THAT GOES THROUGH THE
DEGREE AS A TEAM THEY HAVE THE
SUPPORTS THEY GET TRAINING.
A CAT AM TUTORING THAT THAT
REALLY HELP THEM BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL AND RIGHT NOW ACROSS
THE STATE THERE SOME
APPRENTICESHIP MODELS FOR
THEY'VE ACTUALLY EMBEDDED THAT
INTO.
THE PROGRAM ITSELF AS A WAY TO
GROW YOUR OWN STAFF AND ENSURE
THAT THEY HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE AND
JOB TRAINING.
FELT REALLY.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD WITH ALL OF
THIS WE THINK THERE ARE SOME
OTHER KEEP THINGS AS WE LOOK AT
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN.
IT IS ESSENTIAL TO HOLD COURSES
IN LANGUAGES OTHER THAN ENGLISH.
DURING NONTRADITIONAL TIMES AND
TO BE HELD AND COMMUNITY
LOCATIONS SUCH AS RESOURCES AND
REFERRALS VERSUS ON THE COLLEGE
CAMPUS ALL THE TIME.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT OUR
TEACHERS REALLY UNDERSTAND
INCLUSIVE PRACTICE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF OUR
PROGRAMS AS WE GROW CAN SUPPORT
CHILDREN ACROSS ALL OF THE AND
ABILITY LEVELS.
INCLUDING THOSE CHILDREN THAT
HAVE AN I. F. S. P. R. AND I. E.
P..
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
REALLY SUPPORT DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND SUPPORT HOME
LANGUAGE AS WELL AS ENGLISH.
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ANTI BY A
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE ISSUES.
THAT COME UP IN IN OUR PROGRAMS
AND REALLY LOOK AT WHO
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN ARE AND
SUPPORT THAT WHOLE CHILD.
AS WE LOOK TOWARDS EXPANSION WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO EDUCATE OUR
WORKFORCE NOW IN ALL OF THESE
AREAS. TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
SUPPORT THOSE ADDITIONAL THIRTY
THOUSAND THOUGHTS WE ALSO KNOW
THAT FUNDING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IS A SMART
INVESTMENT AND WILL REALLY HELP
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM QUALITY.
AS WE LOOK AT BUILDING SOME OF
THAT OUT WE DO KNOW WE NEED SOME
OF THE DATA SYSTEMS TO CAPTURE
THAT THERE IS A WORK FOR STUDY
THAT HIDEOUS HELP FINE ALONG
WITH FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA.
THAT WILL PROVIDE SOME OF THE
DATA ON IT THEY REALLY ENSURING
THAT WE CAN CAPTURE ONGOING
INFORMATION IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
AS WELL AS PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO PROGRAMS
SUPPORTING PROVIDERS AND WORKING
WITH INSTITUTES OF HIGHER ADD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR COURSE WORK
IS ACTUALLY APPLICABLE TO WHAT
WE NEED ON THE GROUND AS
PROVIDERS IN THE FIELD.
THE MOVING ON FROM NOT FISCAL
EXPANSION WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S WISE INVESTMENT
ENSURING THAT THEY'RE SUFFICIENT
FACILITIES AVAILABLE.
SINCE FACILITIES AND
AVAILABILITY OF CARE ARE
INTERTWINED ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF THE
CAPACITY ISSUE WE HAVE IS THE
STATE THIS DEALS MORE WTH A
LICENSE CARE BUT IT REALLY IS
THE LICENSE FACILITIES THAT ARE
PART OF THE ISSUE.
CALIFORNIA HAS ABOUT SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION CHILDREN AGE BIRTH
THROUGH AGE TWELVE AND NOT AS
SORT OF OUR SCOPE OF ARE
SUBSIDIZED EARLY LEARNING CARE
FIELD.
OF THESE CHILDREN WE ESTIMATE
ABOUT FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
68% LIVE IN FAMILIES WHERE THEIR
PARENTS NEED CARE.
OF THE CHILDREN NEEDING CARE
ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR MILLION ARE
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE SUBSIDIZED
CARE.
BUT AS YOU LOOK AT LICENSED
CAPACITY WE ONLY HAVE LICENSE
CAPACITY TO CARE FOR UNDER A
MILLION CHILDREN AT ANY ONE TIME.
SO TWO POINT FOUR MILLION
CHILDREN ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIZED CARE FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION CHILDREN NEED CARE AND
WE ONLY ACTUALLY HAVE LICENSE
THOUGHTS. FOR UNDER AND MILLION
FROM.
THE JUST THINKING OF THAT AND
KNOWING THAT IT'S NOT JUST
FACILITIES BUT FACILITIES IS
DEFINITELY ONE AT THAT.
AND THEY WERE REALLY HAPPY I AM
ANGRY FOR THAT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD WILL BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
AND PULL TOGETHER MORE AT THIS
ISSUE.
THERE'S ALSO THINGS AROUND CHILD
CARE DESERT'S AND WE THINK
PAIRING THE WORK FORCE AS WELL
AS THE FACILITIES TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CHILD CARE DESERT
AREAS.
WILL BE N IMPORTANT PART OF
THAT.
WE ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THAT THERE ARE SOME.
SOME CONCERNS IN DIFFERENT AREAS
AROUND FACILITIES THAT WE WILL
NEED TO NAVIGATE A LITTLE BIT
MORE DEEPLY.
AROUND ENSURING THAT THEY AREN'T
A GIFT ABOUT THE PUBLIC FUNDS
AND THAT WE ENSURE THAT THOSE
PROGRAMS AND IS FACILITIES
CONTINUE TO BENEFIT SUBSIDIZE
CHILDREN. FOR AT LEAST TEN YEARS
AFTER AN AWARD IS GIVEN.
THE REALLY EXPLORING IDEAS
AROUND WORKING WITH AN
INTERMEDIARY ORGANIZATION WHO
CAN PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
THROUGH AS YOU WORK ACROSS THE
STATE MAKING SURE THAT ALL OF
OUR PROVIDERS AND PROGRAMS CAN
ACCESS THAT VERSUS JUST THE
RELEASE THAT THE ONES WHO HAVE
MORE EXPERTISE AND FACILITIES.
SO AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO BUILD
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD OUR
SYSTEM AN INCREASE ACCESS FOR
CHILDREN FAMILIES.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS -- WITH
RESPECT TO WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
YOU KNOW AND IN A DIFFERENT
SETTING IN THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE.
DIFFERENT TIME HAVE EXPRESSED
SOME CONCERNS ON CTP --
COORDINATION IN THE STATE.
COORDINATING THE FINE WORK THAT
OUR EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS DO
WITH.
WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE -- A
DISCONNECT ON THE DEMAND SIDE
HERE WE'RE TALKING IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
A DEMAND SIDE ISSUE.
OF FINDING IN TRAINING --
WORKERS TO WORK IN THE CHILD
CARE SETTING IN THESE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS AND EDUCATION SETTING.
EARLY EDUCATION SETTING.
HOW DO HOW TO OUR EFFORTS HERE
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
COORDINATOR INTERFACE WITH WHAT
WE'RE DOING ON THE C. T.?
IN THE C. T. E. AREA WITH OUR
REGIONAL CONSORTIA -- ARE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM IN THE ON LINE COLLEGE IS
BEING DEVELOPED AND AND WHAT THE
THE FINE WORK THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY IN
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA ARE
DOING.
IN A SIMILAR FASHION.
THAT A FAIR QUESTION.
A TRENTON ACOSTA.
A LIFE OF RECOVERY CALLS IS AS
WELL -- SO -- I THINK THAT THAT
THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT IS A
PRETTY DECENTRALIZED -- SYSTEM
AND SO IT BEING DONE VERY
SIGNIFICANTLY FOR US FROM ACROSS
THE STATE -- UNFORTUNATELY THE
CENTRAL.
AND ALSO EVEN EVEN IN THE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES WE HAVE THE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM WHICH
DOES REQUIRE COLLEGES. TO SERVE
GET GET TOGETHER IN CONSORTIA
AND AND DEVELOP THEM PLANS
AROUND SOME OF THESE -- IMPORT
INDUSTRIES.
THAT I THINK THE HOW MUCH ANY
SPECIFIC REGION IS GOING TO
PRIORITIZE EARLY EDUCATION WRIST
VERSUS OTHERS.
IT IS IS GONNA VERY ACROSS THE
STATE I WOULD SAY IT IN A MOVE
BY THE WAY THEY SHOULD
PRIORITIZE IT BASED ON THE
DEMAND IN THE REGION.
WHICH IS THE DEMAND SIDE OF THE
EQUATION WHICH IS WHAT CONCERNED
YEAH AND I WOULD SAY THAT I
THINK THE THE STRONG WORK FORCE
FROM OUR WE HAVE HAD ACT A FEW
YEARS AGO WE HAD SOME
CONVERSATION WITH COMMITTEE
CALLED STE -- FOLKS ABOUT THE
CHILD DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS OF
INTO THE COLLEGES ARE
PRIORITIZING PROGRAMS THAT DO
ONE OF TWO THINGS ONE IS THERE'S
DEMAND FOR THIS INCREASED NUMBER
OF JOBS.
IN TO THAT WE CAN EXPECT THAT
THOSE -- INDIVIDUALS WHO.
WHO'D CONDUCT THE TRAINING TO
GET THOSE JOBS ARE WELL PAID.
I THINK SOME COMEY COLLEGES ON
THE DEMAND SIDE OF ITS FOR
EXPANDING PRESCHOOL THEN THERE
MIGHT BE -- THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL JOBS BUT COMPARED TO
OTHER POTENTIAL CD TYPE PROGRAMS --
BEING IN THE EARLY EDUCATION
WORKFORCE RIGHT NOW IS NOT
VIEWED AS A VERY HIGH PAYING JOB
AND SO SOME COLLEGES.
ARE PRIORITIZING SOME UP SOME OF
THE OTHER INDUSTRIES -- BECAUSE
OF THAT.
WHICH RESULTS IN A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PRIORITY. ONE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIES IN
OUR PRIORITY HERE IN THE IN THE
LEGISLATURE IF IT IS A PRIORITY.
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THAT AND
WHAT'S GOING TO GOING ON DOWN IN
THE REGION'S WITH RESPECT TO
EDUCATING AND PREPARING THE
WORKFORCE TO MEET.
A REQUIREMENTS WHICH PROBABLY
PROBABLY NEED TO WORK ON THAT.
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS.
SEVERAL OF THANK YOU.
FIRST A COMMENT -- I COULDN'T
AGREE MORE AT THAT THESE I I
WILL SAY WOMEN BECAUSE I HAVEN'T
MADE ANY MEN CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS.
THESE WOMEN ARE I'M SURE THERE'S
SOME SURE THEY'RE WONDERFUL BUT
IT'S PRIMARILY WOMEN.
AND THESE WOMEN ARE SO PROUD
SPECIALLY THE IN HOME DAY CARE
CENTERS A LICENSED ONCE SO PROUD
OF THE JOB THAT THEY DO AND THEY
REALLY DO DO A REMARKABLE JOB
I'M IMPRESSED EVERY TIME I VISIT
ONE OF THE SITES.
AND I THINK THE MORE WE CAN DO
FOR THEM OFFERING ADDITIONAL
CLASSES AND COURSES.
THEY JUST WANT TO DO THEIR BEST
FOR THESE KIDS THEY YOU KNOW
THEY STILL LOVE THEM AND TO YOUR
POINT RICHARD.
AND TO YOUR POINT WE ARE
OFFERING IT BECAUSE THE THE
CLASSES BECAUSE IT JUST DOESN'T
PAY WELL YOU DON'T BECOME A
CHILD CARE PROVIDER BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO MAKE MONEY OR BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO BE RICH YOU DO
BECAUSE YOU LOVE CHILDREN AND
YOU BELIEVE IN -- ADVANCING OUR
FUTURE SO THERE IS A DISCONNECT
THERE I DON'T KNOW HOW WE DO
THAT AT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BUT I JUST WANT TO COMMENT ON
ONE IN MASON JOB THESE WOMEN DO
AND AND HOW PROUD THEY ARE OF
WITH THE SERVICE THEY ARE
PROVIDING FOR WORKING FAMILIES
IN.
THESE CHILDREN AND THEN I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT THE CHILD CARE
DESERTS DO YOU WHERE ARE THOSE I
HAD NOT HEARD THAT BEFORE.
I'M SURE IT'S QUITE TRUE BUT I
JUST HADN'T HEARD THAT.
WE ARE ACTUALLY ANALYZING OUR
DATA RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE HAVE A
NUMBER I THINK ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED AND STATE CODES THAT
DON'T HAVE ANY LICENSED KAREN
NONE.
AND YET THE FAMILIES ARE SEEKING
STEPS TODAY HAVE SUBSIDIES ARE
ACCESS TO ROGERS THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR CARE.
THERE'S QUITE A NUMBER WE TEND
TO SEE IT MORE IN RURAL ISOLATED
COMMUNITIES.
AM SO IF YOU LOOK IN LINDA NOT
NORTH ATTENDS TO HAPPEN A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
BUT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
WANT TO DIVE INTO MORE AND MORE
HAPPY TO SHARE AS WE SERVE
EXPLORE THE DATA.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU.
ZERO YEAH -- I TO THIS WORKFORCE
THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT
PARTICULARLY YOU KNOW HERE WE
ARE.
EXPANDING SLOTS WITH BIG PLANS
TO MOVE AHEAD IN THE FUTURE.
AND THAT'S GONNA TAKE.
FILL IN THOSE POSITIONS ARE YOU
KNOW WHO I THIS TEACHERS.
AND SO I GUESS THERE'S A
QUESTION ABOUT -- ABOUT YOU KNOW
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WERE YOU
KNOW WE'RE WE'RE YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE WITH THEM IN A LOT OF
COMMITTEE COLLEGES THAT ARE OUT
THERE ACTUALLY HAVE EXCELLENT
PROGRAMS -- YOU KNOW KIND OF
MAKES YOU WONDER YOU WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE CHALLENGES OF
OF B. A.'S I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
LIKE A SENSE THAT HAVING A BA
PROVIDES FOR HIGHER QUALITY.
TRAINING -- AND AND TEACHING
THOUGH AS YOU SAY IF SOME OF THE
CURRICULUM SO FAR AWAY FROM THE
CORE.
SKILLS THAT THEY NEED FOR THE
ACTUAL WORK.
IT MAKES YOU WHERE WONDER ABOUT
THE RELEVANCE RIGHT I MEAN IT
YOU KNOW IS IS.
IS IT THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
EXTRA SPECIAL ABOUT THIS TWO X.
TWO YEARS IN COLLEGE THAT THEY
CAN'T PICK UP INTO EXTRA YEARS
ON THE JOB -- AS  AS A AS A
EARLY CHILDHOOD AND INSTRUCTOR
YOU KNOW I I KNOW WE'RE ALL
GOING TO VERY WRAPPED UP IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE BUT I WONDER ON
PARTICULAR GIPSON HAS YOU SAY
THE GENERAL EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS ARE KIND OF LITTLE
OFF.
FROM THE FROM THE FROM THAT THE
NEEDS OF THE TEACHERS.
I WONDER HOW WHETHER WE'RE WE'RE
LETTING -- FORM TROUBLED TRUMP
FUNCTION.
SO I WOULD SAY ACTUALLY WAS
SPEAKING SPEAKING ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM FELLOW AS WE HAVE
PROVIDERS COMMAND EVEN FAMILY
FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR PROVIDERS
HAVE BANNED IN SOME OF OUR
TRAINING AND SUPPORT PROGRAMS IN
THE PAST BECAUSE IF.
YOU SHARED THAT THEY WANT TO DO
THAT BASS THEY WANT TO BE THE
BEST THAT THEY CAN BE TO SUPPORT
THESE CHILDREN TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
PHIL WE'VE SEEN THAT -- NOT JUST
AT THE BE A LEVEL BUT THE A
LEVEL TWO YOU BUMP INTO THOSE
REQUIREMENTS AROUND GENERAL AD
AND THE PROVIDERS TEND TO
STRUGGLE A LITTLE BIT MORE WITH.
THE ENGLISH AND ESPECIALLY THE
MATH COURSES THROUGH ITS ACROSS
ALL OF THEM AND SOME OF THE
ACCESS POINTS IF YOU'RE WORKING
ALL DAY AND SOME OF OUR
PROVIDERS WORK.
INTO THE EVENING IT CAN BE
REALLY HARD TO ACCESSING SO EVEN
IF YOU WANT TO IMPROVE YOUR
KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS THAT.
IT'S TRYING TO MAKE THOSE A
LITTLE BIT MORE AVAILABLE
WHETHER THEY BE WEB BASED
WHETHER THEY HAVE THEM IN THE
WEEKENDS ARE RATHER THEY HAVE
EVENING ACCESS TO SOMETHING.
BUT THEN HOW DO YOU PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR THEM SO THEY DON'T
FEEL SORT OF OFF ON THEIR OWN IN
FRONT OF A COMPUTER THAT THEY
MAY NOT BE SKILLED AT AND SO IT
REALLY IS PAIRING THEM TOGETHER
WITH AN ADVISER.
THOSE CORE HURTS WORKED
FABULOUSLY WE DID HAVE FAMILY
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND CO
HURTS IN THE YEARS PAST WHO DID
WANT TO GO AND GET THEIR
BACHELORS.
AND I MEAN I WOULD NEVER WANT TO
SAY TO A WOMAN A WOMAN OF COLOR
THAT THEY CAN'T ACHIEVE THAT
BACHELOR'S IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
WANT.
THE WE SAW SUCCESS ACROSS ALL OF
IT THE KID CAN CAN AGREE WITH
THAT MORE BUT BUT I BUT I GUESS
WHAT I WHAT I'M THINKING -- WITH
THE THE AMBITIOUS A PRO PRO
REALLY AMBITIOUS PLANS TO EXPAND
THE PROGRAM -- WE'RE GONNA NEED --
TO THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF OF
HIRING NEEDS I AND THERE'S A LOT
OF OPPORTUNISTIC WE'VE GOT GREAT
INFRASTRUCTURE THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES -- TO TRAIN THEM IS
REALLY GREAT PROGRAMS OUT THERE
UP AND DOWN THE STATE IT JUST
MAKES YOU WONDER WHETHER WE
OUGHT.
TO KIND OF BUILD ON THAT
EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO EARLY CHILDHOOD
CERTIFICATES DAY AIDS.
OBVIOUSLY WITH THAT WITH THE
OPTION OF OF FOLKS TO GO ON AND
GET HIGHER DEGREES IF IF THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO.
I THAT WILL SURELY HELP IS A
QUESTION ABOUT IT BUT ON BIG BIG
GIVEN THAT.
THE THE THE CALIBER THE PROGRAMS
THAT CURRENTLY EXIST IN THE NEED
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE PLACING
ON THE SYSTEM VERY VERY SOON AND
QUITE FRANKLY THE REALLY
EXCITING JOB OPPORTUNITIES ARE
OUT THERE FOR YOUNG PERSON.
WHO WANTS TO GO INTO THIS KIND
OF WORK?
ON YOUR MAKES ME THINK ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING RIGHT NOW TO
COORDINATE AND EXPAND THE
EXISTING COMMUNICATIVE FOR
STRUCTURE. TO REALLY HAVE
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW. TO TO TO BE ABLE TO TO
TO TO DEAL WITH IN A IN A IN A
VERY POSITIVE PROACTIVE.
MEETING FOR WAY THE DEMAND IT
WILL BE OUT THERE AND AND I JUST
THINK ABOUT YOU KNOW
CERTIFICATES A IS WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT CAN WE DO. TO TO TO JUST
GET -- GET MORE STUDENTS A GOOD
QUALITY TRAINING THAT THEY NEED
NOW. TO BE ABLE TO MEET THE
DEMAND OF THE STATE WILL BE
PUSHING OUT THERE.
AND I I LOVE THE I DON'T KNOW IS
THERE IS THERE BEEN A
CONVERSATION WITH THE TO ME
COLLEGES ABOUT HOW TO DO THIS
AND HOW TO GET FUNDING TO THEM
FOR THIS AND HOW TO REALLY.
BE ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW SOMETIMES I WORRY
I'M I'M WORKING RIGHT NOW ON A
COORDINATING A COUPLE COURTING
BILLS RIGHT YOU KNOW.
SO AS WE WE DO GREAT STUFF IN
ONE PORTION OF OUR EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM AND THAT AND THAT CREATES
A WHOLE NEW SET OF OPPORTUNITIES
AND RESPONSIBILITIES ON OTHER
PARTY EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM OUT WE
MAKE SURE THAT THE LEFT IN STOCK
IN THE RIGHT HAND.
I THINK IT JUST FROM PAST
EXPERIENCE WITH OUR PROGRAMS
THEY TYPICALLY HAVE PARTNERED
VERY CLOSELY WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IT'S CREAM THAT ACCESS
POINT SAID THAT.
THE PROVIDERS DON'T ALWAYS HAVE
TO GO ON TO THE COLLEGE CAMPUS
TO ACCESS THE COURSES AND THAT'S
WHY SOME OF THE PRODUCES
PROGRAMS HAVE BROUGHT THEM ON TO
THE CHILD DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM
CENTER SITE.
AND THEY BROUGHT IN FAMILY
TUCKER PROVIDERS FROM THE
COMMUNITY DO COULD BE PAIRED
WITH CENTER STAFF AS THEY GO
THROUGH ARTICULATED COURSE WORK
THAT'S BEING TAUGHT THROUGH A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR ANOTHER
COLLEGE SYSTEM.
THROUGH ITS JUST INSURING AS YOU
LOOK AT LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT
YOU THOUGHT THROUGH WHO IS THE
WORK FORCE HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT
ACCESS AND SUPPORTS ARE THERE.
SO THEY CAN BE EFFECTIVE AS THEY
GO THROUGH THE COURSES AND I DO
THINK CONTINUING TO UPDATE WHAT
THOSE COURSES REFLECT AND
ENSURING THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
OUR CHILDREN WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
SO THAT WE REALLY HAVE A WORK
FORCE WHO KNOWS HOW TO SUPPORT
BILINGUALISM AND THEY'RE LOOKING
AT A CHILD SOME LANGUAGE IN
ANOTHER.
AND AND THOSE ARE SOME OF THE
CLASSES THAT I THINK THAT WE'VE
SEEN IN PAST WORK FOR STUDIES
WARRANT IS AVAILABLE AND SO
MAKING MORE AND MORE IF THAT.
CONTENT KNOWLEDGE AVAILABLE
GERMAN FOREIGN CARE IN THAT
PIECE.
EMBEDDING DOT AS SOMETHING THAT
ALL OF OUR PROVIDERS SCOTT AS
THEY MOVE FORWARD.
WOULD REALLY SUPPORT OUR
CHILDREN.
WELL.
I'LL MAKE THIS OBSERVATION --
AND I'VE.
WE DID A SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING ON SOME OF THIS DOWN IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND I'VE
TALKED TO SOME FOLKS IN AND A
GENERALIZATION WE GENERALLY
LEAVE IT TO THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY.
K. THROUGH TWELVE AND ABOVE.
TO BOTH DESIGN PROVIDE THE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS BUT ALSO TO
IDENTIFY [inaudible]
THE NEED.
ANECDOTALLY IT WORKS IN
DIFFERENT WAYS SOMETIMES THAT'S
NOT THE CASE BUT GENERALLY WE
RELY ON THE EDUCATIONAL
COMMUNITY. TO IDENTIFY THE NEED
AND THEN BY THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT AND I AM NOT SURE
THAT'S THE BEST AND MOST
ORGANIZED EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE
WAY TO DO IT.
SO I'M GIVING KUDOS THE
EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITY FOR
STEPPING OUTSIDE THE SANDBOX AND
DOING THINGS THAT I THINK OTHER.
ORGANIZATIONS SHOULD BE
ORGANIZED TO DO WHICH IS
IDENTIFY WITH THE JOB NEED IS IN
THIS CASE CHILD CARE.
EDUCATION WORKERS AND THEN WORK
WITH THE EDUCATIONAL COMMUNITY
TO PROVIDE THE TRAINING -- AND
THE CERTIFICATES OF DEGREES
WHATEVER THEY ARE WHATEVER LEVEL.
TO TO MEET THE NEEDS THAT I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO DO
IT IN A MORE ORGANIZED.
AND EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE WAY
STARTING STATE DOWN NOT TO TAKE
AWAY LOCAL CONTROL FOR THE LOCAL.
REGIONAL CONSORTIA OR WHATEVER
THE ORGANIZATIONAL ENTITY IS
THAT IS TASKED WITH THIS
RESPONSIBILITY WOULD DETERMINE
THE NEED IN THE REGION IN SOME
REGIONS MIGHT HAVE A HIGH NEED.
FOR OF EDUCATION WORKERS.
OTHER REGIONS MAY NOT HAVE QUITE
AS MUCH IN THE BUT THIS IS NOT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO DO THIS AND
I'M JUST GIVING A LECTURE RIGHT
NOW BUT I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW
WHAT MY PERSPECTIVE IS AND THE
GOOD NEWS IS.
WE'RE PROBABLY GOING TO FUND A
STUDY.
YET ANOTHER. ONE TO BUILD ON THE
OTHER STUDIES THAT WE'VE HAD WE
HAVE AND I'M HOPING THAT THIS
STUDY ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THIS STUDY CAN DO IS AT LEAST
DETERMINE IN THIS.
AREA WHETHER THAT WE CAN HAVE A
MORE ORGANIZED APPROACH TO
IDENTIFYING THE JOB IN THE THE
DEMAND SIDE AND COUPLING THAT
WITH THE EDUCATION PIECE TO
PROVIDE THE WORK FORCE THAT WE
NEED IN THIS AREA TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES TO THE PEOPLE WHO BADLY
NEED.
SERVICE.
SO HAVING SAID THAT.
OUR SERVICE.
MISTER CHAIR THIS IS JUST A
COMMENT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THEM -- ATTAINING.
DEGREES AND WHATNOT AND HOW DO
WE DO THAT AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IT'S ALREADY BEEN NOTED
THAT THESE ARE HIGH AYING JOBS.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S WHERE
THE DISCONNECT IS IS THAT WE
LOOK AT CHILD CARE.
ABOUT PROVIDERS WHICH ARE
PRIMARILY WOMEN THERE IN LOW
WAGE MINIMUM WAGE JOBS MOST THE
TIME WITH NO PENSION SO YOU
MIGHT BE A CHILD CARE PROVIDER
FOR THIRTY YEARS.
AND WHEN YOU RETIRE.
WHAT IS THERE FOR YOU AND OUR
HOME CARE WORKERS ARE IN THE
SAME BOAT THESE ARE MOSTLY IN
THAT THAT'S -- THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE UP
AND DOWN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PROVIDING THAT SERVICE.
98% OF WHOM ARE WOMEN AND SO I
JUST WANT TO STOP THINK ABOUT.
TAKING CARE OF THESE KIDS BUT
WHAT WE ALSO DOING FOR THE WOMEN
THAT ARE TAKING CARE OF OUR OUR
FUTURE AND TO IN RAISING OUR
FUTURE.
AND IF WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THEM
EXPECT THEM TO WORK AT MINIMUM
WAGE AND HAVE NO PENSION.
WHAT WHAT DO WE DO AND WE'RE
GAVE WE DON'T HEAD ON THE FRONT
AND WE'RE GOING TO PAY IT ON THE
BACK AND SO I JUST SO THAT OUT
FOR US TO ALL CONSIDERING THINK
ABOUT?
WAS A TRACK MORE PEOPLE YEAH AND
THE TRIP ARE PEOPLE WHO.
CO EXITING FURTHER.
THANK YOU LOU PELOSI GREAT
PRESENTATION JOIN THE
CONVERSATION LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING ANOTHER.
ONE ISSUE NUMBER FOUR IS A
WOMEN'S CAUCUS PROPOSAL I'M
GOING TO ASK MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR LEYVA TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION.
GONNA FIGHTER OKAY I'M READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF I
FIRST WANT TO START BY SAYING
THAT AS THE CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS -- THERE BEEN MANY WOMEN
WHO HAVE COME BEFORE ME AND BEEN
THE CHAIR AND REALLY REALLY
GREAT WORK I JUST.
I'M THE LUCKY ONE WHO GETS TO BE
THE STEWARD OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS
AND TRY TO MOVE THE BALL FORWARD.
THIS YEAR -- WE ARE WORKING ON
AGAIN ON SLOTS IN CHILD CARE AS
WE DO EVERY YEAR AND FOR OVER A
DECADE THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS
PRIORITIZE INCREASING ACCESS. TO
SUBSIDIZE CHILD CARE FOR CARE
FOR OUR YOUNGEST UNDERSERVED
CHILDREN INCALIFORNIA.
IT HAS BEEN A DEATH A DECADE.
OF THE AS SEEN DRASTIC LONG
LASTING CUTS TO A SYSTEM THAT
HAS BEEN CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED
AND IN SERIOUS NEED OF SUPPORT.
THROUGH THE WORK OF OUR PREVIOUS%
WOMEN'S CAUCUS CHAIR'S WE'VE
ALSO SEEN INCREMENTAL POSITIVE
STEPS.
THIS YEAR IS NO DIFFERENT THE
CAUCUS REMAINS COMMITTED TO
MAKING THE NECESSARY INVESTMENTS
AND EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
YOUNGEST UNDERSERVED CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA.
WITH THE NEW ADMINISTRATION THAT
HAS BEEN VOCAL AND PUTTING THE
NEEDS OF OUR YOUNGEST AT THE TOP
OF THEIR AGENDA.
THE TIME IS NOW TO MAKE A REAL
INVESTMENT IN CHILD CARE.
AND I MUST SAY THAT FOR THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS WE ARE VERY
EXCITED TO HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO
CAME RIGHT OUT AND SAID THAT HE
IS WORRIED ABOUT THE YOUNGEST
AMONG US.
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO TRULY
MAKE LASTING CHANGE THE NEED FOR
INCREASED ACCESS TO THESE
SERVICES HAS ALWAYS BEEN
SUBSTANTIAL AS WE'VE HEARD TODAY.
HOWEVER NEWER DEBTOR SHIP DATA
SHOWS THAT INVESTMENT NOW IS
MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER A TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN JUST ONE IN
NINE CHILDREN ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE CALIFORNIA
ACTUALLY RECEIVE SERVICES.
IN ORDER TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
CHILD CARE THE CAUCUS ULTIMATELY
BELIEVES THAT WE MUST INVEST IN
THE WORK FORCE WHICH IN TURN
WILL GIVE PROVIDERS.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE MORE
CHILDREN AS WE JUST DISCUSSED.
SPECIFICALLY.
CALIFORNIA HAS A BIFURCATED
SYSTEM OF REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR EARLY LEARNING SERVICES
WHICH COMPLICATES EFFORTS TO
FUND AND DELIVER HIGH QUALITY
EAZY E. PROGRAMS.
THAT MEET THE DEVELOPMENTAL
NEEDS OF ALL CHILDREN.
THE GOAL HERE IS TO CREATE A
SINGLE REGIONALI STATE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE THAT DOES FOR
THINGS ONE COMPENSATES TEACHERS
AND PROGRAMS FOR THE COST OF
PROVIDING CARE. TO IS RESPONSIVE
TO THE ECONOMIC DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. THREE RECOGNIZES THE
COST OF MEETING VARYING QUALITY
STANDARDS FOR INCENTIVIZE IS
QUALITY AND PARTICIPATION IN
RESEARCH BASED EQUALITY IN BOOK
AND PROVE ME EFFORTS.%
WE SHOULD ALSO DEVELOP
GUIDELINES AND STANDARDS TO
FACILITATE EASY E. PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT IN ORDER TO
STRENGTHEN RECRUIT AND RETAIN
THE EASY WORKFORCE AGAIN WE JUST
SPOKE ABOUT THAT.
WE SHOULD HAVE CONSISTENCY IN
HOW THESE FUNDS ARE APPLIED WE
SHOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT FAMILIES
DO NOT EXPERIENCE A BREAK IN
CHILD CARE SERVICES.
DUE TO BE TRANSITION BETWEEN THE
THREE STAGES OF CHILD CARE BY
STREAMLINING CAL WORKS STAGEONE
CHILD CARE ELIGIBILITY RULES.
CONTINUITY OF CARE CREATES THE
STABLE CONDITIONS THAT CHILDREN
NEED FOR HEALTHY DEVELOPMENT.
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
BELIEVES THAT WHILE BOOSTING
FUNDING FOR CHILD CARE%
FACILITIES LIKE THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED IS IMPORTANT.
BUT IMPROVING THE WORK FORCE
WILL INEVITABLY INEVITABLY LEAD
TO MORE CHILDREN BEING SERVED.
WELL INCREMENTAL INVESTMENTS IN
SLOTS HAVE BEEN MADE IN RECENT
YEARS MOST HAVE BEEN TARGETED
TOWARDS THE CALIFORNIA ST
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
WELL IS IMPORTANT INVESTMENT
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE STATE WITH
THE FIRST CHILD CARE NEEDS WE
WAS PROVIDE THE SUPPORTS NEEDED
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE PULP
POPULATIONS.
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES
WHICH OFTEN WORK NONTRADITIONAL
HOURS ARE ALREADY STE AND ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO FOR THE
BASICS.
WELL ONE PROGRAM CAN HELP ONE
FAMILY IT MAY NOT BE SUITABLE
FOR THE NEXT FAMILY.
IMPROVING THE WORK FORCE
INCREASING SLOTS WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA BEGIN TO MEET ITS
GOAL.
OF PREPARING CHILDREN FOR SCHOOL
ALLOWING PARENTS TO WORK
INCLUDING THOSE WITH
NONTRADITIONAL SCHEDULES.
AND PROVIDE FAIR PAY FOR CHART
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS.
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
IS UNITED AND BRINGING ATTENTION
AND FIGHTING FOR OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS WE STAND READY TO WORK
WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR ON THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES. TO HELP
SUPPORT WOMEN CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES THANK YOU CENTERS THIS
ONE BEEN SCORED.
BY FINANCE NO -- IT WILL BE
EXPENSIVE -- WE WON'T FIND OUT
PROBABLY UNTIL THE MAY REVISE
BUT W'RE THINKING A HUNDRED
THOUSAND SLOTS OVER THREE YEARS
ABOUT ONE BILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME FUNDING. ONE TIME. ONE TIME
AND THE ONE BILLION WOULD BE
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS
[inaudible]
CEREMONY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
EASY [inaudible]
SUPER PRESENTATIONS.
ISSUE NUMBER SIX KINDERGARTEN
CHILD SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
PAGE TWENTY ON THE AGENDA
.
GOOD AFTERNOON IF YOU WOULD
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD
STORE IN MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT
SIR Q..
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DAVID O'BRIEN
A DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT A
COMMISSION THANK YOU AFTER RUN
GOOD. TO SEE YOU GEN MERRY ARE
WITH FINANCE.
THE KING WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
IF YOU.
AGREE TO BROUGHT THE LEGISLATIVE
OFF THE MR ROW THANK YOU.
OKAY WHO WANTS TO START.
ASSAULTING OFF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INCLUDES A PROPOSAL TO
PROVIDE FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. TO SUPPORT PILOT
PROJECTS AND PARTNERSHIPS WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AGENCIES AND
PHILANTHROPY IS TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO TRIAL SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
FOR INCOMING KINDERGARTNERS.
THIS PROPOSAL AIMS TO SUPPORT
AND ENCOURAGE FAMILIES TO BUILD
ASSETS FOR THE CHILDREN'S POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE CHILD SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS PROGRAM IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
EFFORTS PROMOTE EQUITY IN THE
STATE BY PROMOTING FINANCIAL
LITERACY.
CULTIVATING A COLLEGE GOING
IDENTITY AMONG BOTH STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND LEVERAGING
RESOURCES FROM MULTIPLE SOURCES
TO ASSIST IN MAKING POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION ATTAINABLE.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
HELLO.
THANK YOU FOR THINKING THAT THE
L. L.. TO FIND OVER VEAL AND
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS AS
CONTEXT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND FURTHER DISCUSSION.
THE SERGEANTS HAVE JUST
DISTRIBUTED A HANDOUT THAT'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM.
ON THE FIRST PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
WE INTRODUCE THE TYPE OF SAVINGS
ACCOUNT CALLED THE FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLAN.
THIS IS CREATED BY FEDERAL LAW
IN THE MID NINETIES AND IS THE
BASIS OF MANY TOP SAVINGS
ACCOUNT INITIAL.
IN SHORT A PARENT OR OTHER ADULT
CAN OPEN UP AT FIVE TWENTY NINE
PLAN ON BEHALF OF THE CHILD.
AND INVEST FUNDS NOT PLAN WHICH
WILL TYPICALLY GROW OVER TIME.
MAJOR ADVANTAGE OF A FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLAN OF FOR THE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS IS THAT THE EARNINGS ON
THOSE INVESTMENTS ARE NOT
TAXABLE AS LONG FOR SKIN USES
THE FUNDS AND QUALIFYING
EDUCATION EXPENSES.
IN THIS CASE IS EXPENSES
INCLUDING TUITION FEES BOOKS
SUPPLIES AND ALSO SET LIVING
EXPENSES.
NEARLY EVERY STATE ADMINISTERS A
FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN AND
CALIFORNIA ARE JUST CALLED
SCHOLAR SHARE.
ADMINISTERED BY AN OFFICE WITHIN
THE STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE AND
THERE ARE CURRENTLY OVER THREE
ENGINE TEN THOUSAND OPEN ACCOUNT.
FOR PERIODICALLY SCHOLARS ARE
OFFERS INCENTIVES FOR FAMILIES
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY THROUGH THE END OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN CALENDAR YEAR
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES CAN
RECEIVE MATCHING A SENTENCE OF
UP TO TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE DOLLARS THEY OPEN A NEW
ACCOUNT.
AND ESTABLISH AUTOMATIC ON THE
CONTRIBUTIONS.
PETER HAND OUT WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE ALSO SEVERAL LOCAL
EFFORTS TO EXPAND PARTICIPATION
IN COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
STARTED IN SAN FRANCISCO IN.
TWENTY ELEVEN CURRENTLY THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
AUTOMATICALLY OPENS A COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT ON BEHALF OF
EVERY KINDERGARTEN AND THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
MAKES INITIAL DEPOSIT NOT
ACCOUNT AND THEN OFFERS
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVES TO
ENCOURAGE FAMILIES TO CONTRIBUTE.
SINCE THE CREATION OF THAT
PROGRAM IN SAN FRANCISCO VARIOUS
OTHER LOCAL ENTITIES INCLUDING
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
ALSO.
WENT TO BE INCLUDING BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE LUNCH SIMILAR
INITIATIVES.
IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT THESE
INITIATIVES DO VERY IN TERMS OF
WHO IS ELIGIBLE FOR THEM.
WHAT THE ENROLLMENT PROCESS
LOOKS LIKE INCLUDING WHETHER IT
OFTEN OR OPT OUT?
AND WHAT MATCHING CENTERS ARE
AVAILABLE TO FAMILIES.
RECENTLY IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE STATE TO CREATE A
PROGRAM CALLED EVERY KID COUNTS
THAT'S INTENDED TO SUPPORT THESE
LOCAL INITIATIVES.
THIS PROGRAM IS MINISTERED BY
THE STATE NEED COMMISSION.
AND IN SHORT IT PROVIDES GRANTS
TO LOCAL ENTITIES THAT HAVE
PROGRAMS IN PLACE SOARING
DEVELOPMENT TO INCENTIVIZE LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES TO SAVE FOR
COLLEGE.
RECOGNIZING THAT THE STUDENT A
QUESTION WILL BE PROVIDING AN
UPDATE ON THIS PROGRAM ALL I'LL
KEEP OUR COMMENTS BRIEF AND JUST
NOTE THAT LAST MONTH THE
COMMISSION DID APPROVE NINE
GRANTEES FOR THIS PROGRAM
TOTALING TWO POINT NINE MILLION.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR OVERVIEW OF
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS BUT I'D
BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU.
COMMISSIONS NEXT.
I I HOPE YOU'LL COME AND YOU
RECEIVED NINE APPLICATIONS AND
APPROVED ONLINE I'M SORT OF
SURPRISE YOU ONLY RECEIVE NINE
SO MAYBE YOU COULD GO INTO THAT
FOR ME DURING YOUR PRESENTATION.
YES SIR CERTAINLY ARE DAVID A
BRAND OF THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION SO -- AS THE ONLY
A MENTION AS YOUR YOUR EXCELLENT
STAFF AGENDA SUMMARIZES THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT ESTABLISHED THE EVERY KID
COUNTS COLLEGE SAVINGS PROGRAM.
PROVIDED SOME ONE TIME FUNDING
AND WAS LATER AMENDED TO PUT
THIS PROGRAM UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE STUDENT A
COMMISSION -- BUT WE CAME UP
WITH A AN ELIGIBILITY FORMULA
BASED ON THE WORDING OF THE
STATUTE WHERE BY -- ENTITIES ITS
SUBMITTED APPLICATIONS WOULD
RECEIVE A PROPORTIONAL AMOUNT OF
THE TWO POINT NINE MILLION
AVAILABLE FUNDS BASED ON A
COMBINATION OF HOW MANY STUDENTS
THEY INTENDED TO SERVE.
AND SPECIFICALLY HOW MANY LOW
INCOME FAMILIES THEY INTENDED TO
SERVE BECAUSE THE INTENT OF THE
STATUE WAS TO ENCOURAGE SAVINGS --
AND TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES FOR
SAVINGS FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
WE DID RECEIVE APPLICATIONS FROM
A TOTAL OF NINE ENTITIES WE DID
SOME LIMITED OUT REACH WE DIDN'T
HAVE A DEDICATED BUNCH DO IN THE
EXTENDED OUT REACH.
BUT WE DID SOME LIMITED OUT
REACH THROUGH CONTACTS THAT WE
HAD MADE AND THROUGH
ORGANIZATIONS -- LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PAYS ORGANIZATIONS TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY WAS
AWARE THAT THIS FUNDING
OPPORTUNITY WAS AVAILABLE AND
SUBMITTED AN APPLICATION.
JUST SPECULATING HERE ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT -- WE MAY HAVE NOT
GOTTEN MORE THAN THE NINE IS
THAT THERE WAS A STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT THAT THE ENTITY
EITHER HAVE A PROGRAM IN
OPERATION OR IN DEVELOPMENT.
AS OF DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST LAST
YEAR SO THIS FUNDING IN THIS
PARTICULAR AND BUDGET ACTION
ITEM WAS NOT INTENDED TO BE A
SEED FUNDING OR START UP FUNDING.
FOR LOCAL ENTITIES ACCORDING TO
THE WORDING OF A STATUTE IT WAS
INTENDED TO SUPPLEMENT OR
PROVIDE MATCHING FUNDS.
OR OTHER -- PROGRAM EVALUATION
FUNDS FOR ENTITIES THAT WERE
ALREADY IN THE PROCESS OF
ESTABLISHING A PROGRAM SO THAT
COULD BE SORT OF SOME OF THE
REASONS WHY WE DIDN'T GET MORE
THAN THE NINE IT MAY BE
SOMETHING WORTH CONSIDERING THE
FUTURE FOR FUTURE PROGRAMS
WHETHER.
THAT RESTRICTION SHOULD STILL BE
IN THERE OR WHETHER OR NOT SOME
OF THE FUNDS FROM THE STATE
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR SORT OF
START UP FUNDS WHICH WAS NOT
ALLOWED.
UNDER THE EVERY KICK COUNTS AND
WHAT WILL I PRESUME YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE ANOTHER DEADLINE OF
FEBRUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY THIS WAS A ONE
TIME PROGRAM -- SO WE
DISTRIBUTED THE FUNDS ON A ONE
TIME BASIS -- WE RECEIVED NINE
APPLICATIONS SCORED THEM DID THE
PROPORTIONAL FUNDING AND THEN AT
OUR MARCH COMMISSION MEETING OUR
COMMISSIONERS -- APPROVED THE
STOCK RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
FUNDING BUT WE SELL NEW PROGRAM.
WAS THE FIFTY MILLION FR
CORRECTS -- I'VE DONE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THE PROGRAM
IS SAYS LATER TO BE ADMINISTERED
BY THE FIRST FIVE COMMISSION I
BELIEVE -- SO TO CLARIFY -- AS
MISTER O'BRIEN SAID THE THREE
MILLION THAT WAS MADE AVAILABLE
FOR EVERY GETS COUNTS ACT WAS
APPROPRIATED IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUDGET ACT WAS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR A ONE TIME PURPOSE.
THE CURRENT FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET A WORKING TEAM TO HAVE
ONGOING CONVERSATIONS AND WE
HOPE TO PROVIDE MORE DETAILS
FORTHCOMING ON HOW THE FUNDS
WILL BE EXPANDED AND IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH WHICH
ORGANIZATIONS OR AND WHAT
FRAMEWORK WILL BE USED AND WELL
I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE.
THAT I MEAN IF IF IT'S GOING TO
BE IF THIS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FOR EXAMPLE MUNICIPALITIES
HAVING PROGRAMS OR OR COUNTIES
YOUR PROBABLY MISS BELL IS WOULD
BE THE BEST -- GOVERNMENT ENTITY
I GUESS.
THEN I WOULD CERTAINLY HOPE THAT
USE.
THE SERVICES OF THE LEGAL
CALIFORNIA CITIES AND SOME OF
THESE OTHER -- ASSOCIATIONS TO
GET THE WORD OUT I'M.
I'M SORT OF DISAPPOINTED THAT --
I DON'T SEE ANY CENTRAL VALLEY --
INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA --
CITIES ON THE LIST -- OBVIOUSLY
DIDN'T HAVE PROGRAMS BY DECEMBER
THIRTY ONE OF WHATEVER THE YEAR
WAS BUT IN AREAS WHERE WE HAVE --
HISTORICALLY HAD LOW.
OF HIGH SCHOOL COMPLETION
GRADUATION RATES -- LOW COLLEGE
GOING RATE FOR A WHOLE VARIETY
OF REASONS. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
LISTENING DOWN IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND WHERE I COME FROM IN
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I HOPE
THEY STEP IT UP A NOTCH AND SEE
IF WE CAN PUT PROGRAMS TOGETHER --
TO QUALIFY FOR SOME OF THIS
MONEY.
AND I I THINK I WOULD JUST KNOW
THE ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT I
THINK AS WE DELIBERATE ON THE
PROPOSALS AND THE EXACT FORM
IT'S GONNA TAKE IS THIS ISSUE OF
STRIKING A BALANCE BETWEEN
PROVIDING FUNDS TO JUMPSTART
PROGRAMS MAYBE IN AREAS WHERE
THEY DON'T EXIST.
BUT BALANCING THAT AGAINST
WHETHER THAT'S SUSTAINABLE OR
NOT OR IF THERE IS GOING TO BE
SOME TYPE OF LOCAL MATCH.
I'M NOT AND I'M NOT SUGGESTING
THAT THIS BE USED TO JUMP START
PROGRAMS I'M SUGGESTING THAT.
PEOPLE IN AREAS WHERE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING DILIGENTLY FOR YEARS TO
DRIVE UP HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
RATES AND COLLEGE GOING RATES.
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO CREATE THEIR
OWN PROGRAM SO THAT THEY CAN
QUALIFY FOR THE PROGRAMS THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN A
GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO INCLUDE IN
THE BUDGET AND YOU'RE GONNA BE.
NICE ENOUGH TO ADMINISTER -- WE
NEED TO GET THE WORD OUT WRITE
VANCE OF YOU KNOW EARLIER THAN
THREE MONTHS BEFORE THE DEADLINE
HER HER AND SET THE SET THE
PROGRAM START DATE -- AT A AT A
POINT WHERE PEOPLE CAN.
GET RAMPED UP SO THEY CAN
QUALIFY FOR THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM.
IT QUESTIONS KELLY.
THE HOOD I CUT OUT APPEARED
EVERYBODY GET ENOUGH CONTINUES
SPEAK.
THEIR OWN ANYTHING.
EXCELLENT.
BUT FOR TO HAVE A CONTINUE
DISCUSSION THIS EXCELLENT
PROGRAM THANKS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR DOING THIS.
OKAY OUR FINAL AGENDA ITEM
BEFORE PUBLIC COMMENT IS ISSUE
NUMBER SEVEN SPECIAL EDUCATION
.
OKAY YOU KNOW THE DRILL FOR I
COULD ASK YOU TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELF FOR THE RECORD TO MY
LEFT YOU RIGHT MA'AM.
I AS HEATHER CARLSON -- WITH THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION DIVISION OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON BEHALF OF
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION TWENTY THURMAN.
THANK YOU WAS GROSSING SAID
ATTORNEY.
YES MA'AM LISA RESIDENTS HERE AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU YEAH.
MICHELLE ILLEGAL ALSO DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
BRIAN ANDERSON ALEJO.
MISTER ANDERSON GOOD TO SEE YOU
BACK.
OKAY WHO WANTS TO START.
A STATUS I THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT OF WHICH ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN MILLION AS
ONE TIME FOR EXPANDED SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND SCHOOL READINESS
SUPPORT FOR KNOWN AS A SPECIAL
EDUCATION CONCENTRATION GRANT.
THIS FUNDING IS TARGETED AT A
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES WITH
BOTH HIGH CONCENTRATIONS OF
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES AS
WELL AS HIGHWAYS SEVEN
DUPLICATED PEOPLE SO THESE ARE
STUDENTS WHO ARE -- ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS YOUTH IN
FOSTER CARE AND YOUTH FROM LOW
INCOME FAMILIES.
THE THESE FUNDS ARE INTENDED TO
SUPPLEMENT SERVICES FOR STUDENTS
ALREADY RECEIVING SUPPORTS
BEYOND WHAT IS AN IP AS WELL AS
TO FIND PREVENTIVE SERVICES SUCH
AS EARLY INTERVENTION IN
PRESCHOOL.
THESE FUNDS CAN ALSO BE USED TO
ADOPT STRATEGIES TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
IDENTIFIED TO THE STATE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT -- AS WELL AS TO
BUILD OR EXPAND UPON LOCAL MULTI
TIER SYSTEM OF SUPPORTS OUR MTS --
AND I'LL JUST CONCLUDE MY
COMMENTS BY A AT BY SAYING THAT
THIS IS A HISTORIC INVESTMENT
SPECIAL EDUCATION.
BUT IS ALSO A STRATEGIC ONE WITH
A FOCUS ON EQUITY -- THIS
ADMINISTRATION AND THIS GOVERNOR
IS REALLY INTERESTED IN LOOKING
AT THE COMPOUNDING EFFECTS OF
POVERTY RATE POVERTY IMPACTS
EVERY ASPECT OF A PERSON'S LIFE
OF THE CHILD.
FIVE AND THAT'S NO DIFFERENT FOR
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES --
AND SO THIS FUNDING IS REALLY TO
HAVE TARGETED INCREASE
INVESTMENTS TO MORE
REALISTICALLY SUPPORT STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES ESPECIALLY
STUDENTS IN HIGH NEED AREAS --
AND TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
THESE A STUDENTS AND BONTA BOOK
COMMUNITIES AND I'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE QUESTIONS [inaudible]
HELLO.
YEAH -- SO THE ADMINISTRATION
JUST LAID OUT THERE PROPOSAL AND
I WILL GET TO THAT AND OUR
COMMENTS ON IT BUT FIRST I WAS
ASKED TO OFFER SOME.
HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF CURRENT
ISSUES IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
FINANCE AND I'LL BE DOING SO.
IN THE HANDOUT THAT THE SERGEANT
JUST DISTRIBUTED.
THE FIRST PAGE OF THAT HAND OUT
AS JUST A BRIEF INTRODUCTION TO
THE CONCEPT TO SPECIAL EDUCATION
SO.
REAL QUICKLY SPECIAL EDUCATION
INSTRUCTION DESIGNED TO MEET THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF EACH CHILD WITH
A DISABILITY FEDERAL LAW
REQUIRES THAT ALL SCHOOL ALL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
IDENTIFIED ALL CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES THAT AFFECT THEIR
LEARNING AND ALONG WITH THEIR
PARENTS DEVELOP AN
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION PROGRAM
SPELLING OUT THE SPECIFIC
SERVICES EACH OF THOSE CHILDREN
WILL RECEIVE.
THE FIRST PAGE OF OUR HAND OUT
WE LAY OUT THE MOST COMMON
DISABILITIES BY GRAY THE OLD
NOTICE FIRST OF ALL.
ABOUT 60% OF ALL CHILDREN WHO
ARE IDENTIFIED FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
OF ONE OF TWO I USUALLY MILD.
DISABILITIES.
IN THE EARLIER GRADES THAT'S
LARGELY SPEECH IMPAIRMENTS
SEARCHES STUTTERING ARE
ARTICULATION DISORDERS.
AND THE LATER GRADES IT'S
COMMONLY LEARNING DISORDERS SUCH
AS DYSLEXIA.
THE SECOND PAGE OF THE HANDOUT
LAYS OUT SOME BASIC PRINCIPLES
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION FINANCE.
OF THE TWO BASIC IDEAS HERE
FIRST.
CHILDREN WHO ARE RECEIVING
SPECIAL EDUCATION OR GENERAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS FIRST THEY
RECEIVE.
INSTRUCTION THE SAME CURRICULUM.
OFTEN FROM THE SAME TEACHERS IN
THE SAME CLASSROOMS AS THEIR
PEERS WHO DO NOT HAVE
DISABILITIES AND THEY GENERATE
THE SAME FUNDING LARGELY THROUGH
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA. TO SUPPORT THOSE
ACTIVITIES SO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS WERE
JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
ADDITIONAL COSTS INCURRED ABOVE
AND BEYOND THOSE GENERAL
EDUCATION EXPENDITURES.
BECAUSE OF THOSE CHILDREN'S I
HE'S.
WELL THE FIGURE ON PAGE TWO
PLAYS OUT THE MOST RECENT DATA
WE HAVE WHICH IS FROM TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ON
THOSE BECAUSE YOU'LL NOTE THAT.
CURRENTLY IT COSTS ABOUT THREE
TIMES AS MUCH ON AVERAGE TO
EDUCATE A STUDENT WITH
DISABILITIES.
AS A STERN WHO DOES NOT HAVE
DISABILITIES OF COURSE THIS
VARIES A LOT BASED ON THE
INDIVIDUAL NEEDS OF EACH STUDENT.
PAGE THREE TRACKS HOW THESE
COSTS HAVE BEEN CHANGING OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS.
RATE THAT IT PRINTED IN A WAY
THAT IT'S IT'S HARD TO SEE
EXACTLY WHERE THIS LINE AND
SPREAD.
IN INFLATION ADJUSTED TERMS
TOTAL SPECIAL EDUCATION
EXPENDITURES HAVE INCREASED BY A
COUPLE BILLION DOLLARS OVER THIS
PERIOD.
THAT INCREASES BEEN BORN LARGELY
BY THE LOCAL GENERAL PURPOSE
SHARES SO.
THE THAT WOULD BE THE SHARE OF
THESE ACCESS SPECIAL EDUCATION
COSTS THAT ARE NOT COVERED BY
STATE AND FEDERAL CATEGORICAL
FUNDS.
AND NOW THIS SHARE THE LOCAL
SHARE OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
CLASSES INCREASE FROM.
WILL LESSEN 50% IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN EIGHT TWO WILL MORE THAN
60% IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
THERE ARE NUMBER OF REASONS WHY
COSTS HAVE BEEN INCREASING BUT
AMONG THE LARGER OURS SPILLOVER
EFFECTS FROM GENERAL EDUCATION
COSTS.
AS TEACHERS RECEIVE NEGOTIATED
SALARY AND OTHER COMPENSATION
INCREASES THESE APPLY TO SPECIAL
EDUCATORS WHILE.
ALSO AS PENSION CONTRIBUTION
RATES HAVE INCREASED OF THOSE
HAVE FACTORED SPECIAL EDUCATION
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT ACCOUNTS
FOR ABOUT A QUARTER OF THE
INCREASE IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
EXPENDITURES OVER THE LAST
DECADE.
OF THE REST WE BELIEVE IS
LARGELY DRIVEN BY AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
IDENTIFIED FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
IN PARTICULAR AT THAT INCREASES
BEING DRIVEN BY TWO POPULATIONS.
OF FIRST THE POPULATION OF
STUDENTS IDENTIFIED WITH AUTISM
HAS BEEN INCREASING RATHER
NOTABLY OVER THIS PERIOD.
AND SECOND THE POPULATION OF
CHILDREN IDENTIFIED WITH
DISABILITIES AGES THREE AND FOUR
HAS IDENTIFIED SIGNIFICANTLY
OVER THIS PERIOD.
AND THE FOURTH PAGE OF THIS
HANDOUT SPEAKS SPECIFICALLY TO
THAT POPULATION.
SO FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES SCHOOLS
TO BEGIN IDENTIFYING AND SERVING
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES AT
AGE.
THREE THESE CHILDREN CAN BE
SERVED AND ONE OF THREE GENERAL
SETTINGS EITHER -- THE
MAINSTREAM PRESCHOOL SETTING
SUCH AS YOU TALKED ABOUT EARLIER
STATE PRESCHOOL OR THE FEDERAL
HEAD START PROGRAM.
LATEST DATA SUGGEST THAT A
LITTLE LESS THAN HALF OF
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES ARE
SERVED IN SUCH PROGRAMS.
ABOUT A THIRD OF CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES ARE SERVED AND
SPECIAL PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS THAT
ONLY SERVE OTHERS SOON OUR OTHER
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITES.
AND OF THE REMAINDER.
ABOUT A QUARTER.
I'D AREN'T RECEIVING ANY
COMPREHENSIVE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM
BUT ARE JUST RECEIVING SOME.
CIVIC ADD ON SERVICES SUCH AS
SPEECH THERAPY.
L. AS NOTED EARLIER WE'VE SEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER OF PRE SCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN RECEIVING SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES CALIFORNIA'S
SCHOOLS SERVED ABOUT. FIFTY
THOUSAND OF THESE CHILDREN AND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WHICH IS AN
INCREASE OF ABOUT 25% FROM A
DECADE PRIOR.
AND ACCORDINGLY COSTS OF ALSO
GONE UP -- SO IN THE LATEST DATA
FROM TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
REPORTED SPENDING ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION.
ON THESE SERVICES AND THAT'S UP
FROM ABOUT THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION.
A DECADE PRIOR.
WELL THE LAST THING TO NOTE HERE
IS THAT THESE COSTS ARE COVERED.
UP.
ALMOST EXCLUSIVELY BY THE LOCAL
GENERAL PURPOSE SHARE.
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
EXPENDITURES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PROVIDE SOME
CATEGORICAL FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
FOR THIS POPULATION AND COVERS
ABOUT 20% OF THE ASSOCIATED
COSTS BUT THE STATE CURRENTLY
PROVIDES NO SPECIFIC FUNDING FOR
THIS THAT STATE CATEGORICAL
FUNDING. FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
IS.
SPECIFICALLY FOR K. TWELVE
EDUCATION.
THE FIFTH PAGE RAISES A COUPLE
OTHER ISSUES WITH SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING THAT WE
COMMONLY HEAR ABOUT. ONE IS THAT.
OUR PRIMARY ALLOCATION FORMULA
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
CATEGORICAL DOLLARS IS BASED ON
ACCOUNT OF TOTAL STUDENT
ATTENDANCE -- IN EACH STUDENT
WHO SHOWS UP REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THEY HAVE DISABILITIES
AND NOT GENERATES A FUNDING RATE.
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION BUT THOSE
RATES VARY QUITE NOTABLY ACROSS
THE STATE.
FROM LESS THAN FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN SOME REGIONS TO MORE
THAN NINE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
OTHER REGIONS.
THAT THERE'S NO.
REAL POLICY RATIONALE FOR THIS
INEQUITY THIS IS A RESULT OF
VARIOUS HISTORICAL FACTORS WHICH
HAVE BEEN GRANDFATHERED AND AND
IT'S SOMETHING BUT PARTICULARLY
THE REGION'S RECEIVING THE LOWER
RATES.
OFTEN A COME TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO ASK FOR CORRECTION.
THE OTHER ISSUE WE HEAR A LOT
ABOUT IS THAT.
THIS PRACTICE OF GIVING FUNDING
BASED ON OVERALL STUDENT
ATTENDANCE BY DESIGN DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR ANY.
REGIONAL VARIATIONS AND COSTS SO
WE DO HAVE THESE INEQUITIES THE
INEQUITIES AREN'T SAY LINK TO
THE INCIDENCE OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE THE SERVICES
THAT THOSE STUDENTS ARE BEING
PROVIDED.
WE DO KNOW THAT BOTH THE
INCIDENCE AND THE COST OF
SERVING STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES FAIRIES NOTABLY
AROUND THE STATE FROM -- SOME
REGIONS IDENTIFY FEWER THAN 10%
OF THEIR STUDENTS AS HAVING
DISABILITIES OTHERS NEARLY 20%.
THE ASSOCIATED COSTS RANGE FROM
LESS THAN A THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
STUDENT IN SOME REGIONS STONE
MORE THAN FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN OTHER REGIONS.
THE STATE'S CRRENT FUNDING
FORMULA DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR
SUCH VARIATIONS NOW THE PREVIOUS
US STAND FUNDING FORMULAS DID
AND THEY WERE SCRAPS AND IN PART
BECAUSE OF CONCERNS ABOUT.
A GROWING ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPLEXITY IN SOME CASES THERE
IS CONCERNS THAT THEY WERE.
CREATING AN APPROPRIATE FISCAL
INCENTIVES BUT THIS IS AN
ONGOING ISSUE AT THAT TIME I'M
SURE YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT.
THAT THE FINAL PAGE OF THE
HANDOUT COVERS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL. FOR SEED MINISTRATION
JUST DESCRIBED WERE.
OF WE ARE RECOMMENDING THE
LEGISLATURE REJECT THIS PROPOSAL
AND WE HAVE A COUPLE SPECIFIC
CONCERNS FIRST.
OF WE JUST DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THE PROPOSAL'S LIKELY TO ACHIEVE
THE ADMINISTRATION'S STATED
GOALS OF WHILE THEY INDICATE
THAT.
THE FUNDS ARE INTENDED TO BE
SPENT ON ADDITIONAL SERVICES
THAT STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE NOT CURRENTLY RECEIVING OR
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAMS THAT
MIGHT DAY FOR STUDENTS FROM
REQUIRING SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THE ASSOCIATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE IS NOT CONTROLLING UGH
IN FACT THE FUNDS COULD BE USED
FOR ANY PURPOSE WE BELIEVE BASED
ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
ADMINISTRATORS ACROSS THE STATE
THAT.
MANY OF THEM ARE CALLING OUT FOR
ADDITIONAL CATEGORICAL FUNDING
JUST TO COVER THEIR EXISTING
SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS AND WILL
LIKELY INTERPRET -- THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION CONCENTRATION GRANTS
IT'S JUST THAT AND PUT THAT
TOWARDS.
COVERING THEIR EXISTING PROGRAMS --
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE HAS
BETTER OPTIONS FOR AUGMENTING
STATE CATEGORICAL FUNDING IF
INDEED THAT'S WHAT WHAT IT'S
GOING TO BE USED.
FOR ROSS OF CONCERN SPECIFICALLY
AIMED AT THE ADMINISTRATION
[inaudible]
HAS INDICATED.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO INVEST IN
EARLY INTERVENTION PROGRAMS THAT.
REDUCE THE IDENTIFICATION RATE
FOR SINCE -- IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION -- BUT WE THINK THAT
THE FISCAL INCENTIVES CREATED BY
THEIR PROPOSAL ACTUALLY WORK
COUNTER THAT.
IN FACT -- FOR EVERY STUDENT
THAT ARE A DISTRICT THAT WAS
RECEIVING A SPECIAL EDUCATION
CONCENTRATION GRANT.
THAT NO LONGER IDENTIFIED FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION THAT DISTRICT
WOULD BE OUT ABOUT EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN ON GOING
FUNDING.
WE THINK THAT SENDS A STRONG
FISCAL INCENTIVES THAT ACTUALLY
PUSHES IN THE OTHER DIRECTION
THAT YOU SHOULD IDENTIFY MORE
CHILDREN NOT.
FEWER.
AS MENTIONED BEFORE WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE HAS OTHER OPTIONS
FOR AUGMENTING FUNDING AND WE DO
OUTLINED A COUPLE.
ON THE AS OF LAST BULLET.
HI THERE THE LEGISLATURE COULD
EQUALIZE PERCENT FUNDING RATES
OR COULD DEDICATE SOME STATE
CATEGORICAL FUNDING SPECIFICALLY
FOR FOR PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
WITH DISABILITIES -- EITHER
THESE PROPOSALS COULD BE
STRUCTURED IN A NUMBER OF WAYS
AND HOW YOU STRUCTURE IT.
WOULD ULTIMATELY -- DETERMINE
HOW MUCH IT COSTS BUT WE THINK
EITHER APPROACH COULD BE ADOPTED
WITHIN THE AMOUNT THAT SET ASIDE
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
THAT'S IT FOR MY REMARKS SO WITH
RESPECT TO EQUALIZATION ON PAGE
FIVE YOUR YOUR FIRST BULLET --
WITH THE WITH THE RATES VARYING
FROM FOREIGN EIGHTY EIGHT
DOLLARS TO NINE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SIX DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
EQUALIZATION WITH EQUAL EQUALIZE
THOSE PER STUDENT RATES.
THE U. S. SO THERE'S A NUMBER OF
WAYS THE A. B. E. YOU COULD DO
IT AT THE OF BUTTON THE GENERAL
CONCEPT IS THAT YOU SAID SOME
TARGET -- SAY THE NINETIETH
PERCENTILE.
BAD 90% OF OF FOLKS CURRENTLY
ARE RECEIVING EITHER THAT RATE
OR A LOWER RATE AND THEN YOU
LIFT EVERYONE WHO'S AT A LOWER
RATE UP TO THAT AMOUNT.
WE ESTIMATE THAT COST ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IT WOULD STILL
LEAVE SOME INEQUITIES RIGHT
BECAUSE YOU'D HAVE THAT TOP TEN
PERCENTILE WOULD STILL BE
RECEIVING -- THEIR HISTORICAL
FUNDING LEVELS BUT IF YOU WERE
TO FULLY EQUALIZE WOULD COST
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE.
AND THE COST OF THE PROVIDING
DEDICATED STATE FUNDING FOR
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
A IT WOULD DEPEND AGAIN ON HOW
YOU STRUCTURE THAT I KNOW THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER PROPOSALS OUT
THERE BUT YOU COULD -- EASILY
STRUCTURE IN A WAY THAT COST
SOMEWHERE AROUND THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS SAYS SIMILAR TO
THE GOVERNOR'S ON GOING PROPOSAL.
WELL OR POORLY OF SOME SCHOOLS
IN SOMERS STATER IDENTIFYING
FEWER THAN 10% OF THEIR STUDENTS
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THOSE SCHOOLS MUST BE RECEIVED
BUT THE BUT THE BUT THE FUNDING
IS DISTRIBUTED ON A PER STUDENT
BASIS THOSE SCHOOLS.
MUST BE RECEIVING A SUFFICIENT
AMOUNT OF MONEY TO EDUCATE THE
SPECIAL NEEDS.
COMMUNITY THAT THEY'RE WORKING
WITH.
YEAH WE FIND THE A IF YOU WERE
TO LOOK AT THIS DIVISION INTO
THE THREE POTS OF FUNDING RIGHT
THE LOCAL THE LOCAL SHARE THE
FEDERAL SHARE THIS STATE SURE
THAT WE CALLED OUT.
IF YOU WERE TO LOOK AT THAT --
ACROSS ALL THE VARIOUS REGIONS
IN THE STATE AT THE EXTREME
LEVEL YOU DO FIND THAT SOME HAVE --
NEARLY 90% OF THEIR COSTS
COVERED BY STATE CATEGORICAL
FUNDING THAT'S CLEARLY NOT THE
STORY FOR MOST OF THE STATE BUT
IN SOME PLACES THAT IS THE CASE.
AND IF WE CHANGE THE SYSTEM TO
PROVIDING FUNDING BASED ON
STUDENTS WHO HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS.
POST TO MY UNDERSTANDING IS
ACROSS THE BOARD -- WITH THAT
DRIVE UP THE IDENTIFICATION RATE
FOR SPECIAL NEEDS.
ED.
IT'S A SOMEWHAT CONTROVERSIAL
POINT AND THAT IT'S AN IMPORTANT
QUESTION BECAUSE IT'S THAT
POLICY IDEA THAT HAS BEEN
CONSIDERED FOR MANY YEARS.
AND I KNOW IF YOU'D ASKED THIS
QUESTION OF SOME ADMINISTRATORS
THEY TELL YOU THE ANSWERS NOW
THAT.
THEY IDENTIFY BASED SOLELY ON
WHAT THE APPROPRIATE DIAGNOSIS
IS AND THEY HAVE NO CONTROL OVER
THAT BUT THE THE LITERATURE DOES
SUGGEST THAT THE ANSWER IS YES
AND STATES THAT DO PROVIDE.
FUNDING BASED ON AN ACCOUNT OF
STUDENTS IDENTIFIED FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
THOSE STATES HAVE HIGHER
IDENTIFICATION RATES THAN STATES
THAT HAVE FUNDING SINCE SYSTEM
SIMILAR TO CALIFORNIA AND I
WASN'T IN THE QUESTION
SUGGESTING THAT.
WITH THE CHANGE PEOPLE WOULD
GAME THE SYSTEM I'M JUST
WONDERING.
WITH THE FUNDING ACROSS THE
BOARD FUNDING.
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE TODAY I
WONDER IF THERE'S THERE'S NO
NEED.
TO PAY PARTICULAR ATTENTION TO
THE IDENTIFICATION.
IT'S ALSO A GOOD POINT THAT
YOU'LL HEAR -- IF YOU TALK TO
THE FIELD THERE IS SOME CONCERN
THAT -- THAT THERE'S DANGER IN
GOING TOO FAR IN THE OTHER
EXTREME THAT PERHAPS OUR CURRENT
FUNDING SYSTEM IS OFFERING A
FISCAL DISINCENTIVE TO IDENT TO
PROPERLY IDENTIFYING SUBSTANCE
THAT SHOULD BE IDENTIFIED WITH
AND JUST A COMMON IN A PERFECT
WORLD WE WOULD.
CLEARLY AND ACCURATELY IDENTIFY
THOSE STUDENTS WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS.
AND THEN WE WOULD CLEARLY AND
COMPLETELY PROVIDE ALL OF THE
MONEY TO THE DISTRICTS NECESSARY
TO PROVIDE THE EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES WITH THE STUDENTS HER.
BY I THANK YOUR DESCRIPTION OF A
PERFECT WORLD IS A IS ON POINT
BUT I'M INTO GOING ON SEVEN
YEARS I'VE LEARNED THAT
CERTAINLY IN THE BUDGET PROCESS
IS NOT A PERFECT WORLD YEAH.
ANYWAY I DIDN'T MEAN SURE CUT
ANYBODY ELSE MA'AM.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS.
SO THE SUPERINTENDENT SUPPORT
AND APPRECIATE ALL THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR ENSURING
OUR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE RECEIVING THEIR EDUCATION
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
EDUCATION ACTOR ID EA.
AND RECOGNIZING THAT OUR STATE'S
HIGHEST NEED YOU OFTEN REQUIRE
SIGNIFICANT SUPPORT SERVICES AND
PLACEMENTS.
INCREASED FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION CONTINUES TO BE AT THE
TOP OF MINES IN MANY OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
WITH DISTRICTS AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS.
AS WE WORK TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES
AND STRIVE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR COMPLEX LEARNERS.
WE RECOGNIZE OUR STRENGTHS AND
WE CAN THAT THERE'S OME STRINGS
AND ALL OF THE THREE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE OUT THERE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET -- THERE'S A
SENATE BILL AS TWO SEVENTEEN AS
WELL SINCE ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
TWENTY EIGHT ALL OF WHICH
ADDRESS SOME IMPORTANT AREA OF
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND RELATED
SERVICES.
WERE SPECIALLY SUPPORTIVE OF ALL
OF ANY AND ALL SUPPORTS FOR
ELEAZAR TO PROVIDE MORE ACCESS
FOR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
TO THE GENERAL EDUCATION
ENVIRONMENT AND THEIR PEERS
WITHOUT DISABILITIES.
AND WE SEE THIS AS INCLUDING
THINGS LIKE STATEWIDE TRAINING
FOR GENERAL EDUCATION TEACHERS
AND PARA EDUCATORS AND HOW TO
ENSURE UNIVERSAL DESIGN FOR
LEARNING OR YOUDE L..
PRINCIPLES -- ARE EMBEDDED IN
THEIR TEACHING PRACTICES SO MORE
STUDENTS CAN ACCESS THE GENERAL
EDUCATION CURRICULUM.
WE APPRECIATE THE SENATE ARMED
PROPOSAL ADDRESSES THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR EARLY
LEARNERS WITH DISABILITIE -- AS
YOU HEARD THIS IS A HAS BEEN A
LONG STANDING CONCERN IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION AS ELEAZAR REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE EARLY LEARNING -- EARLY
EDUCATION LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
AND SERVICES BUT VERY LITTLE
FUNDING IS PROVIDED TO DO SO.
THE SENATE PROPOSAL WOULD
ADDRESS THIS LONG STANDING
SHORTFALL IN WOULD PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF TO MANY ALLEY ETS.
WHO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
PRESCHOOL STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES HOWEVER IT WOULD
NOT BENEFIT ALL ONLY ACE IN THE
STATE -- AS WE CONTINUE TO MAP
TO EMPLOYMENT FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WE NEED MORE
EQUITABLE PRE EMPLOYMENT
TRAINING AND OPPORTUNITIES.
AND BETTER ARTICULATED AND
PERSON CENTER TRANSITION
PLANNING ACROSS THE STATE WHICH
COULD BE DONE THROUGH SCALING%
COORDINATED PROGRAMMING LIKE
HELL PROMISE AND WORKABILITY --
WE CURRENTLY CURRENTLY ALL
DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS DON'T HAVE THE
SAME ACCESS TO PROGRAMS AND
FUNDING -- THE SUPERINTENDENT IS
THRILLED TO HAVE SPECIAL
EDUCATION AN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
ON THE MINDS OF OUR POLICY
MAKERS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITHYOU ALL ON THE BEST
WAY TO PROVIDE.
IT IN THE MOST EQUITABLE AND
EFFECTIVE MANNER THAT WILL
PRODUCE THE BEST OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
AND AGAIN AND MOST IMPORTANTLY I
HOPE THAT YOU WILL ALSO CONTINUE
TO INVEST IN OUR TEACHERS BOTH
GENERAL AND SPECIAL EDUCATORS
WHO NEED THE SUPPORT MENTORSHIP
AND WORKING CONDITIONS TO SERVE
OUR STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
PARTICULARLY THROUGH MORE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING IN
UNIVERSAL DESIGN FOR LEARNING
AND MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS OF
SUPPORT.
AND I'M HAPPY TAKEN QUESTION
WILL YOU TOUCHED ON THE WORK
FORCE ISSUE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THIS OF FOR A
SIGNIFICANT SHORTFALL IN THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION [inaudible]
EDUCATOR.
WORK FOR SERENA IS MY
UNDERSTANDING CORRECT.
I DIDN'T.
MAYBE I MISSED IT I DIDN'T SEE
ANYTHING IN ANYBODY'S PROPOSAL
INCLUDING.
SOME OF THE LEGISLATIVE ONES
THAT I'VE SEEN THAT SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESS THAT.
I'M.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING IN THE
CURRENT YEAR HOW ARE IN THE
BUDGET THE PROPOSED BUDGET BUT
THERE WAS -- A PROPOSAL IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
FOR COMING UP WITH A AND A
FINANCE COULD PROBABLY SPEAK
BETTER THAN I COULD ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT PROPOSALS THAT WERE
LOOKING AT TRYING TO GET -- MORE
WORK FORCE IN I THINK IT WAS
STEM AND SPECIAL ED -- AND AND I
DON'TI CAN'T SPEAK TO HOW THOSE
PROGRAMS HAVE.
WILL TRY TO STICK TO THE LINE
ITEM THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
HERE BUT I DO THINK THAT'S AN
ISSUE THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE.
TO TO FOCUS ON GIVEN THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE IN THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
HOWEVER ADEQUATE ARE INADEQUATE.
TO CONTINUING TO MOVE TOWARDS
SOLVING THE ISSUE [inaudible]
ZERO YEAH I CLOSER FIRST OF ALL
IT JUST SEND IN AS A BIT OF A
COMMENT.
TO AYE.
YOUR WIFE QUESTION MISTER.
YOU KNOW I REALLY WOULD PUSH
BACK ON THE IDEA THAT -- THAT
THERE IS A SERIOUS DANGER OF
INCENTIVIZING OVER
IDENTIFICATION.
THE REASON WHY I SAY THAT IS
BECAUSE EVEN IF WE CREATE A
SYSTEM.
THAT MIGHT DOES A MUCH BETTER
JOB OF REFLECTING THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH SPECIAL ED.
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL.
IT WILL STILL BE A FRACTION.
OF THE THE REAL COST AND WE
THERE'S NO WAY WE'RE EVER GOING
TO FIND.
THESE PROGRAMS THAT HAD A
PERCENT SO EVEN IF WE DID A BET
EVEN IF WE MET THAT YOU KNOW A
LITTLE SAY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SO WE CAME UP WITH
THE 40% THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO
COME UP WITH OF THE COST SO SEE
WITH IDA.
I INSTEAD OF THE ELEVEN OR 12%
THAT THEY'RE COMING UP WITH.
I THERE WOULD STILL BE --
FINANCIAL DISINCENTIVE.
AND JUST TO TALK REALLY COLEY
ABOUT THIS BUT A FINANCIAL
DISINCENTIVE. FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
OUR ALLEY A TO TO YOU KNOW TO TO
TO HAVE A SPECIAL I CAN'T.
BECAUSE OF THE HIGH COSTS
ASSOCIATED SO IT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I'VE BEEN IN REALLY
TRYING AND WE'VE TALKED A BIT --
AT WITH FOLKS FROM OUT LA -- AND
AND THE THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE HAD A HEARING ON THIS
AYE AYE AYE PRO I WANTED TO BE
HERE TODAY.
WAS BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO HAVE THE
SYSTEM BETTER REFLECT THE COST
SO.
EVEN UNDERSTANDING THAT THEY'RE
NEVER GOING -- TO FULLY
REIMBURSED THE DISTRICTS.
AFTER THE COSTS ASSOCIATED IN
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE IS JUST
SO MUCH TENSION.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DEVELOPMENT
OF AN OF AYE EP'S -- THERE IS
YOU KNOW THE THE DISTRICTS NO --
THE COSTS ASSOCIATED IT CREATES
VERY INTENSE NEGOTIATIONS WITH
FAMILIES THAT CAN OFTENTIMES I'D
TURN INTO.
A VERY EXPENSIVE LITIGATION.
I EIGHT AND AND IT'S BECOME A
REAL TENSION POINT OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM I SAY THIS
HAVING SERVED ON THE SCHOOL
BOARD IN MY OWN HOMETOWN BUT
THEN ALSO SERVING ON THE LA
COUNTY SCHOOL TRUSTEES
ASSOCIATION.
GOT A CHANCE THE TO LEARN HEAR
STORIES FROM UP AND DOWN -- THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY REGION
[inaudible]
SO.
I'M YOU KNOW AT THE THE SAT I I
GUESS MY MY POINT IS I I JUST I
I YOU'RE GONNA TAKE IT COULD
TAKE ME A LONG TIME TO EVER
BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A ANY KIND
OF DANGER OF OVER IDENTIFICATION.
GIVEN THE MACRO COSTS AND
MICHAEL PRESSURES AT PLAY HERE.
AND I I JUST DONE HOPE THAT THIS
SUBCOMMITTEE ENDS -- SANIDAD AND
AND AND NUMBER OF US CAN YOU
WITH LA -- AND AND YEAH AT
DEPARTMENTS OCCASION AND AND DO
ASSN AND YET WE CAN WE CAN
REALLY WORK TOGETHER. TO COME UP
WITH A SYSTEM THAT JUST.
YOU BETTER ALIGNS INCENTIVES --
REDUCES THE TENSIONS.
AND OUT IN A PROPERLY REIMBURSES
UNDERSTAND WHENEVER FULLY
REIMBURSED BUT BUT BUT DOES A
BETTER JOB I SUPPOSE.
OF REFLECTING THE REAL COSTS ON
THE GROUND -- SO THAT WE CAN BE
SERVING OUR SYSTEM BETTER.
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M TRYING TO
SEEK -- AND THAT YOU KNOW IF YOU
IF ANYONE ON THE PANEL HAS ANY.
KIND OF COMMENTS OR THOUGHTS ON
THAT I KNOW THAT'S WHAT WE'VE
ALL BEEN -- GOOD.
ADDRESSING DOES THE COURSE
DISCUSSION BUT IF YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS ON ON THAT.
THAT DIFFICULT BOUNCES STRIKE I
CERTAINLY WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
HEARING.
OF ALL IDLE TO THAT AT THE FIRST
AID.
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING UP ALL
THAT IS AN IMPORTANT POINT AND
AND ONE THAT'S OFTEN RAISED BUT
I I NEGLECTED TO RAISE MY
EARLIER COMMENTS ABOUT -- HOW
COULD AN INCENTIVE EXIST WHEN
THE STATE'S ONLY GIVING THIRTY
CENTS ON THE DOLLAR FOR THE
ASSOCIATED COSTS?
I THINK THE ONE THING TO KEEP IN
MIND -- IN FISCAL INCENTIVES CAN
BE VERY TRICKY AND ONE THING
THAT MAKES SOME PARTICULARLY
TRICKY IN THIS AREA IS THE WIDE
VARIANCE AND COSTS.
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION ACROSS
REGIONS AND ALSO BETWEEN VARIOUS
CHILDREN IN SOME CASES --
CHILDREN -- A DENTAL FIGHT FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION HAVE VERY
INTENSIVE NEEDS AND REQUIRE
COSTS THAT.
ARE IN THE SIX DIGITS -- IN SOME
CASES CHILDREN IDENTIFIED.
HAVE RELATIVELY MILD MEANS AND
MAY ONLY MADE A HALF HOUR OF
SPEECH THERAPY A WEEK AND A AND
IF YOU'RE YOU'RE TALKING
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THAT
POPULATION OF CHILDREN THAT'S ON
THE BUBBLE WHERE.
THE MAY BE UNDER ONE FISCAL
REGIME THEY'D BE IDENTIFIED.
AS HAVING A DISABILITY BUT UNDER
ANOTHER IF THEY WOULD NOT THOSE
CHILDREN OFTEN WILL BE ON THE
LESS EXPENSIVE RAIN RUSH.
YEAH KNOW THAT THERE'S NO
QUESTION ABOUT THAT AND THAT'S
ACTUALLY ALSO PART OF THE STORY
YOU KNOW AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
THEY'RE OFTENTIMES QUITE.
DRAMATIC RICK YOU KNOW.
DIFFERENCES OBVIOUSLY BETWEEN
BETWEEN AND SEVERITY OF NEEDS
AND THEN THERE'S REALTORS COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THEM AND MUCH
LESS WITH OTHERS.
ON LET ME I I'D LIKE TO ASK ONE
QUESTION RELATED.
TO I EARLY CHILDHOOD YOU TALKED
ABOUT THAT ISSUE I MEAN IT IT IT
IS AN EXAMPLE OF WHERE.
IT YOU KNOW ALL THE RESEARCH
SUGGESTS THAT.
IF WE DO A BETTER JOB OF REALLY
IDENTIFICATION AND THEY'RE BEING
TREATMENT AND AND AND TARGETED.
EDUCATION FOR THOSE LITTLE
LITTLE ONES -- WHO?
ARE HAVE A SPECIAL NEED ARE
THERE ARE THERE ARE POTENTIAL
TREMENDOUS COST SAVINGS DOWN THE
LINE BECAUSE YOU CAN.
YOU CAN REALLY GET OUT -- IT
SOME OF THEM YOU KNOW THE THE
THE IN THE THE CONDITIONS
DISABILITIES THAT -- WILL WILL
END UP BOTH BEING A SERIES COST
PRESSURE BUT ALSO WROTE IT TO
THOSE KIDS QUALITY OF LIFE.
BOB AND YET IT'S THE ONE AREA
WHERE WE SEEM.
TO BE THE MOST UNDER FUNDED
[inaudible]
OUR SO [inaudible]
JUST WANTED.
IDENTIFY THAT I AND AND AND
HIGHLIGHT THAT I WILL SAY I KNOW
THERE'S THERE'S AN INTERESTING
ISSUE THAT'S OUT THERE ABOUT THE
HAND OFF THE TRANSITION
[inaudible]
FROM.
I FROM WHEN CHILDREN.
YOU KNOW -- REACHED.
RICH THREE YEARS OLD.
ARE.
YOU THERE REALLY DOES SEEM TO BE
A SMOOTH TRANSITION INTO SCHOOL
DISTRICT PROGRAMS FOR THREE YEAR
OLDS FROM THE REGIONAL CENTERS.
AND THAT'S AN AREA THAT I JUST
THINK IS NOT BEEN GIVEN ENOUGH
ATTENTION I'D LOVE.
TO CAN HEAR ANY THOUGHTS OR OR
OR DISCUSSION MAY BE HAPPENING
IN YOUR IN YOUR RESPECTIVE
DEPARTMENTS.
ABOUT THAT TRANSITION AND SOME
OF THE THE INFRASTRUCTURAL NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE AS A STATE IN THAT.
AREA -- GANO WE TOTALLY.
THINK THAT ALLEY -- DID A REALLY
GREAT REPORT BOUT THIS ISSUE
RIGHT THE THREE YEAR OLDS -- WHO
ARE BEING SERVED BY REGIONAL
CENTERS TO HAVE AN I. F. S. P.
THERE'S OFTEN -- A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN WHEN THEY'RE ACTUALLY
SENT OVER TO THE ALLEY AND I
PROVIDED ALL THE RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED -- WE ALSO RACES AS
CONCERN AND THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- FINANCES BEEN WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH LA L. IN WITH
YOUR STAFF ON HAD HOW DO WE
ADDRESS THIS AREA OF NEED HAD WE
MAKE SURE THAT.
AT LEAST THREE YEAR OLDS THESE
INFANTS ARE NOT FALL INTO THE
CRACKS AND ARE GETTING CONNECTED
TO THE CORRECT SERVICES -- WHERE
THEY DO MAKE THOSE YOU KNOW THEY
DO HAVE THIS GREAT OUTCOMES WHEN
THEY ARE CONNECTED TO SCHOOLS
AND MANY ARE GETTING THOSE EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES SO WE'RE
DEFINITELY LOOKING INTO IT?
WE HEAR YOUR CONCERNS -- AND
WERE MOVING TOWARD SOMETHING IN
THE MAIL THE VICE CRIED I'M
REALLY EXCITED TO HEAR THAT I I
JUST [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY IF THERE'S ANY
ASSISTANCE WE CAN GIVE AYE AYE
HAPPY TO DO IT BUT I BUT I'M I'M
FROM I'M I'M THIS IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT.
BUBBLES UP ALL THE TIME WHEN YOU
TALK TO FOLKS ON THE GROUND --
AT THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN HOW
HOW.
HOW TO EASE THE TRANSITION AND I
THINK WE CAN HELP WE DO A LOT OF
GOOD FOR THESE KIDS?
AND THEY'RE IN THEIR DISTRICT
THE FOOD REALLY ADDRESS IT MORE
FUNDAMENTALLY COMPREHENSIVELY.
MAYBE YOU MAYBE YOU ADDRESS THIS
YOU KNOW TRYING TO BALANCE --
ALTERNATIVES AND WE TALK ABOUT
EQUALIZING YOU KNOW FUNDING
RATES AND THEN YOU TALK ABOUT
THE DEDICATED FUNDING FOR
PRESCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
WHAT SPECIFICALLY ARE THE
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WE SHOULD
USE AND?
IN TO THE EXTENT WE GET TO MAKE
A DECISION IN MAKING THAT
DECISION.
AND IS THAT A FAIR QUESTION. FOR
FOR SOMEBODY THAT KNEW THIS
RODEO.
I YEAH I THINK IT IS A FAIR
QUESTION -- I THINK OUR OFFICES
VIEWPOINT IS SOMEWHAT PECULIAR
THAT WAS.
THAT WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE
PRIMARY ISSUE -- WHEN YOU'RE
YOU'RE THINKING THROUGH OPTIONS
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION FINANCES
IS NOT ACTUALLY FUNDING FOR OUR
SERVICES PROVIDED TO STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES BUT IS THE
FUNDING THAT'S?
AVAILABLE FOR THE REST OF YOUR
STUDENT POPULATION THAT'S ABOUT.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT THAT
LOCAL GENERAL PURPOSE?
OF A SHARE OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
HI WHICH IS TO SAY THOSE DOLLARS
WHICH ARE CURRENTLY BEING SPENT
ON SPECIAL EDUCATION BUT WHICH
ABSENT THE NEED FOR THOSE
DOLLARS BECAUSE THERE'S INCREASE
CATEGORICAL FUNDING.
COULD BE SPENT ON ANY OTHER
EDUCATIONAL PURPOSE HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT THAT BURDEN IS
SHARED AS EQUITABLY ACROSS THE
STATE AS POSSIBLE.
NOW WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
TWO OPTIONS THAT THE LA -- HAS
LAID OUT OF EQUALIZATION AND
PRESCHOOL FUNDING WHAT WE'RE
SAYING AREN'T THERE ARE AT LEAST
TWO POPULATIONS OF OF RULES WITH
CERTAIN CHARACTERISTICS THAT ARE
BEING DISADVANTAGED BY THE
STATE'S CURRENT.
US SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
FORMULA FIRST THOSE THAT. FOR
HISTORIC REASONS HAVE THESE.
OF LOWER PURSUANT FUNDING RATES
THEY THESE SCHOOLS WILL TEND TO
BE CONTRIBUTING MORE OUT OF
THEIR LCF TOWARD SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND THUS HAVE FEWER
pSIMILARLY SCHOOLS THAT ARE
SERVING LARGE POPULATIONS OF
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS WITH
DISABILITIES ARE SIMILARLY
DISADVANTAGE THERE.
DIVERTING WORE THEIR DOLLARS TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE BE AVAILABLE FOR
OTHER EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES OF OF
WHICH OF THOSE POPULATIONS YOU
WOULD LIKE.
TO PRIORITIZE GIVEN THE LIMITED
FUNDING AVAILABLE THIS YEAR.
I THINK THAT'S A TOUGH DECISION
THAT'S THAT SAID.
A ONE FOR LEGISLATORS BUT I
THINK THERE'S A REASONABLE CASE
TO BE MADE FOR EITHER.
OR UNLESS THERE IS A UNLESS THE
THE BETTER APPROACH WOULD BE TO
COMBINE THE METHODS AND REDESIGN.
THE TRIGGER POINT BASED ON THE
IMPACT TO THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
IN MY MAKING SENSE YES I DO WELL
IN THE SITUATION WHERE SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SOME ELLIE ETS
OF HAVE OUR OUR HAVE A HIGHER
IMPACT BECAUSE OF A HIGHER
POPULATION OF THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS WITH SPECIAL NEEDS.
AND THEN THERE ARE OTHERS THAT
DON'T HAVE THE THREE AND FOUR
YEAR OLDS BUT HAVE.
ANOTHER POPULAR SPECIAL NEEDS
POPULATION IT IMPACTS THE
GENERAL FUND BECAUSE IT EXCEEDS
THE THE MONEY WE OTHERWISE
PROVIDE FOR SPECIAL NEEDS
EDUCATION.
AND SO MAYBE THE TRIGGER POINT
NEEDS TO BE.
BASED ON THE IMPACT TO THE THE
GENERAL FUND.
AS OPPOSED TO THE POPULATION OF
SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS.
SAID -- I DON'T BRAINSTORMING
THAT YOU'RE ENGAGING IN I THINK
IS VALUABLE AND I I KNOW THAT
MADE THESE CONVERSATIONS HAVE
BEEN HAPPENING. FOR INSTANCE
WITH CENTER ALLEN'S OFFICE AND
WITH THE FOLKS AT THE TABLE.
I IN SOME SENSE I I THINK THE
EXTREME OF WHAT YOU'RE
SUGGESTING IS THAT THE IDEAL.
SYSTEM FOR FUNDING SPECIAL
EDUCATION WOULD BE SOME KIND OF
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM IN SOME
STATES LITERALLY TO FUND SPECIAL
EDUCATION.
ON A REIMBURSEMENT THEY AS
SCHOOLS SHOW US YOUR RECEIPTS
SAN WILL GIVE YOU A CERTAIN --
CHAIR OF THOSE COSTS THAT OF
COURSE INVITES A LOT OF
QUESTIONS WE DON'T HAVE TIME TO
FULLY.
GET INTO RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
MOSTLY INVOLVING ADMINISTRATIVE
COMPLEXITY AND THE POSSIBILITY
THAT -- YOU MIGHT GAME THE
SYSTEM SIMPLY ON PAPER BY.
ASKING.
OF WHAT DOES COUNT AS A SPECIAL
EDUCATION EXPENSES OPPOSED TO
GENERAL EDUCATION EXPENSE LET'S
BE VERY TRICKY ISSUES TO WORK
THROUGH BUT I I THINK IT IS A
WORTHWHILE THOUGHT EXERCISE.
OR BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO IN ORDER
TO EQUALIZE THE IMPACT TO THE
NINE SPECIAL.
ED FUNDED PIECE OF THE GENERAL
FUND YOU HAVE TO SORT OF
UNDERSTAND WHAT.
HELP PEOPLE ARE SPENDING THEIR
MONEY SO.
THIS DISTRICT CAN GET MORE IN
THIS DISTRICT CAN.
YEAH AND ONE OF THE THINGS IT
COMPLICATES ALL THIS IS THAT.
I YOU KNOW THERE IS A
PEDAGOGICAL AND LEGAL MOVEMENT
TOWARD MAINSTREAM RATED AND
HAVING EVERYBODY TOGETHER.
AND BY ALL ACCOUNTS IT'S THE
BEST THING TO DO FOR HIM IN MOST
CASES.
THAT REALLY DOES BLUR THE LINES
I AND AND AND AND AND ALSO IN
ADDITION I'VE YOU DON'T WANT YOU
KNOW IF.
THEN AGAIN THERE IS A WHOLE SLEW
STUDENTS WHO SHOULD BE
MAINSTREAM I I AT THAT ARE
TYPICALLY HIGHER COST -- BUT
THEN YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU HOW DO
YOU CREATE A SYSTEM THAT REFER
BACK TO THE REQUEST OF REFLECTS
THOSE COST WITHOUT INCENTIVIZING
NON MADE YEAH.
SEPARATING KIDS OUT INTO.
THIS IS HOW WE GET INTO -- HEAD
SPINNING CHALLENGES FASCINATING.
YEAH ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS.
I LOTS OF FOR THE QUESTIONS AT
THE END OF THE DAY OF ALL GET
WHAT WILL WANT ONE FINAL THING
I'M SO SORRY.
ON THE EARLY CHILDHOOD THINK OUT
WHAT DO WE DO IN ON ON ON VERY
EARLY SCREENING I MEAN WHAT IS
THAT IS THAT I KNOW.
IS THAT PART OF THE CALCULUS
THAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT WITH YOUR
PROPOSALS AND A AN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR FOR BETTER
EARLY SCREENING -- I THINK IN
TERMS OF VERY EARLY SCREENINGS I
THINK THERE IS SOMETHING IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AROUND
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENINGS AT A
YOUNGER AGE IS NOT NECESSARILY
IN THE SPECIAL EDUCATION BUDGET.
BELIEVE IT'S MORE ON THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES SIDE BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT THE SCREENINGS ARE
HAPPENING -- BUT YET THIS THIS
PROPOSAL SPECIFICALLY DOES NOT
HAVE.
IT DOESN'T DEAL WITH SCREENING
AT EXTRA IF IF I I MADE BECAUSE
I I KNOW IT'S NOT -- MY
EDUCATION COLLEAGUES PROPOSAL AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BUT
I'M.
ACTUALLY ON MY WAY TO TESTIFY ON
THIS ISSUE AT SUB THREE SHORTLY --
SIZE SO I CAN DESCRIBE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSING
AND THIS BUDGET TO OFFER A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT TO MEDI CAL
PROVIDERS FOR INSURING THAT THE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS THAT THEY
SEE DURING THEIR WELL CHILD
VISITS RECEIVE.
A DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENER --
RIGHT NOW THAT IS TECHNICALLY
REQUIRED OF MEDI CAL PROVIDERS
OF WHICH SPOILER ALERT IS ONE OF
THE REASONS.
WE'RE RECOMMENDING AGAINST THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROACH BUT THIS
WOULD PROVIDE IN ADDITION TO THE
REQUIREMENT.
AT A FISCAL INCENTIVES TO
PROVIDE THOSE SCREENINGS -- GOOD.
OKAY GOOD I LOVE TO GET SOME
INFORMATION AND IF YOU WOULD
MIND SHARING WITH US YEAH
ABSOLUTELY HELPING TOUCH.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS A
FASCINATING CONVERSATION I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING MORE OF IT AS
WE MOVE THROUGH THE BUDGET.
HAVE A GREAT DAY.
WELL THAT CONCLUDES THE NORMAL
AGENDA AND I THINK IT'S NOW TIME
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT.
I WOULD -- I KNEW THIS WOULD BE
POPULAR.
ALL OF THE SO LET'S FORM UP.
AND BEFORE WE START.
A WAY TO EVERYBODY GET SITUATED.
BEFORE WE START I WOULD ASK YOU
TO LOOK AROUND YOU.
AND CHECK OUT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY
SO I WOULD -- I I DON'T NORMALLY
SET TIME LIMITS BUT I WOULD ASK
YOU TO BE AS BRIEF AS YOU
POSSIBLY CAN -- END OF WELCOME
MA'AM YOUR NUMBER.
ONE THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WELL I'M A MOM FROM CADANGAN
THIS IS MY DAUGHTER WE'VE BEEN A
PART OF THE CUTTING FAMILY FOR
ABOUT FIVE YEARS.
HI THERE -- THE PROGRAM IS
AMAZING AND IT'S BEEN ABLE TO
ALLOW ME TO STAY IN FINALS THEY
ALLOW ME TO WORK -- IT'S GIVEN
ME A SAFE PLACE TO TAKE MY KIDS
WHERE.
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET A HEAD
START ON THEIR EDUCATION AND THE
TEACHERS ARE AMAZING.
BUT IT ALSO HAS PUSHED ME FROM
NOT BEING ABLE TO CCEPT ANOTHER
JOB THAT PAYS MORE AND BECAUSE I
WOULD LOSE.
THE DAYCARE ARE THE THE
PRESCHOOL BUT I HAVE.
ALL AROUND YEAH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING IS.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MEANT THE WORLD IS AND I CAN BE
HERE TO TO TELL YOU THAT PLEASE
AGREES THAT BUDGET FOR THAT
CHARLIE CARES -- AND THE REASON
IS BECAUSE I HAVE AYE AYE
SPATIAL AND CHAT IS BUT YOUR
CHILD.
THEN HE MY SON HAS AUTISM IN MY
EXPERIENCE IS THAT MY SON WAS IN
ROLE IN THREE WEEKS ONLY IN AND
THAT HAS START.
AND I HAVE A BAD EXPERIENCE
THERE THAT PROVIDED SAY THAT
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW CARE IS A
CHILD WITH A DISABILITY SO IF
YOU INCREASES THE BUDGET.
THEY CAN -- RECEIVE MODIFICATION
THROUGH IN ORDER TO AT TEN CHILD
WITH A DISABILITY.
SO IMAGINE IN THE INCLUDING
THREE THREE WEEKS I RECEIVED.
SEVERAL CALLS ON TELL ME I CAME
I CAN CHARACTERS -- BECAUSE HE
HAS A BAD BEHAVIOR SO THEY
PUSHING ME EVERY DAY TO TRY TO
MORE MY SON TO A SPECIAL THAT
LOCATION.
THESE THEM BUT HE STAYS TIME SO
IF I WANT TO BUY AND FIND A JOB
IF I'M TRYING TO LOOK TO THE
SCHOOL I COULDN'T GIVE THAT
CHILD PROVIDERS.
CAN DO.
THEIR JOB BECAUSE THEY DON'T
HAVE A LOCATION TO TOOK CARE
DISABILITY -- CHILDREN'S THANK
YOU THANK YOU MA'AM YES MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA AND I'M A
TEACHER A PRESCHOOL TEACHER OUT
COULD DANGLE.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON
THE COM COMPENSATION OF SCHOOL I
KNOW THAT IT HAS HELPED ME A LOT
I ACTUALLY.
WENT TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FIRST AND TOOK TWO YEARS OFF AND
I CONTINUE MY EDUCATION AND WITH
MAYBE A AND WILL BE GRADUATING
WITH MY BACHELORS IN THREE WEEKS.
SO THE PROGRAM HAS HELPED ME
FINANCIALLY BECAUSE I WASN'T
ABLE TO AFFORD GOING TO SCHOOL
PAYING THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS EVEN
WITH THE HELP OF FINANCIAL AID.
SO I KNOW COULD DANGLE HAS THEIR
EDUCATION PROGRAM AND THE HOUSE
HELPED ME A LOT BECAUSE I WAS
ABLE TO SO CONTINUE GOING TO
SCHOOL.
AND STILL.
WE WERE A GAME YOU KNOW WITH
COULD ANGLE AND EVERYTHING AND
NOW THAT I'LL BE GRADUATE MY
BACHELORS -- I'VE GOTTEN MORE
EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD EVEN
THOUGH I HAD GOTTEN IT YOU KNOW
A COUPLE YEARS AGO BACK WITH MY
A A SO I THINK IT WAS YOU KNOW
GREAT.
YOU KNOW OF WITH THE HELP OF
EVERYTHING -- AND I KNOW FOR YOU
KNOW WITH TEACHERS I WILL LIKE
TO GO TO SCHOOL AND ALL HELP
THEM AS WELL.
BECAUSE IS HELP TO ME.
AND YOU KNOW IT'S HELPED ME I'M
PRETTY SURE IT'S GOING TO HELP
EVERYONE ELSE WHO WOLDLIKE TO
BE.
IN THE FIELD AS WELL AND THEY'LL
CONTINUE TO GROW MORE AND LEARN
MORE TO HELP OUT THE CHILDREN
AND I HELP THEM GROW AS A
TEACHER.
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU DO THANK
YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S CRYSTAL ENGLAND
KEEFE -- I'M MARRIED MOTHERS
THREE AYE I WORK AND LIVE OUT IN
CINEMA COUNTY -- I ALSO WORK AT
THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE AND
REFERRAL -- OUT THERE AND WE
RECENTLY WITH THE INCREASE THE
CITY THE BJP -- WE WERE ABLE TO
GET A CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED NEW
SLOT.
BUT WITH THAT WE ARE ONLY ABLE
TO SERVE CPS AND AT RISK
RANKINGS WE DID MAKE IT UP TO
RANK TEN WHICH FOR A FAMILY OF
FOUR IS ONLY SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS A MONTH.
THAT MEANS NOT A SINGLE FAMILY
WHO EARNERS WAIT A MINIMUM WAGE
WORKING FULL TIME WAS ABLE TO
QUALIFY FOR THE PROGRAM AND GET
IN.
AND MY FAMILY -- ME MY HUSBAND
ARE BOTH COLLEGE EDUCATED WE
MAKE OUT TWENTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
SO SLIGHTLY -- UNDER THE DOUBLE
THE MINIMUM WAGE AND YET WE
STILL CAN'T AFFORD CHILD CARE
AND WE ARE ON THE WAIT LIST
WAITING FOR SERVICES -- SO WE
ASK THAT YOU INCREASE THE
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY THE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS BEST FOR BABIES --
FOR ZERO TO THREE MY HUSBAND
WORKS NIGHTS AND HE WATCHES OUR
CHILDREN DURING THE DAY THAT'S
CURRENTLY OUR OF MAKING IT WORK --
SO MY HUSBAND HAS TWO FULL TIME
JOBS RAISING OUR CHILDREN DURING
THE DAY AND THEN GOING TO WORK
AT NIGHT HE COMES HOME AT THREE
AM.
AND IS A HIGH SIX MAKING MEALS --
WATCHING OUR TWO YEAR OLD.
AND AS I SAY THAT THE TRUTH IS
HE ALSO HAS A NAP HE HAS TO
SLEEP -- SO HE TURNS ON THE
TELEVISION SOMETIMES IF YOU HAD
A CUP OF COFFEE COOLEY ON THE
FLOOR AND THAT OUR TWO YEAR OLD
JUMP ON HIM.
IF YOU HAD TWO CUPS OF COFFEE
SOMETIMES HE'LL ROLL OVER.
AND YOU KNOW MY SON THINKS HE'S
WRESTLING BUT MY SON WAS JUST
DIAGNOSED OR NOT SO MUCH
DIAGNOSED BUT APPROVEDFOR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES JUST
BECAUSE HE'S NOT GETTING THE
INTERACTION THAT HE NEEDS.
IS NOT GETTING THE VERBAL
INTERACTION THAT HE NEEDS AND SO
HE'S GOT A 33% SPEECH DELAY
THAT'S BECAUSE NOBODY TALKS TO
HIM.
MY HUSBAND IS THERE HE IS
PRESENT IS A GREAT DAD BUT HE'S
TIRED.
WHEN I GET HOME IT'S DINNER BATH
BED AND I'M TIRED AND THAT MONEY
COULD REALLY GO TO HELPING
WORKING FAMILIES AND NOT JUST
FAIR OTHER FAMILIES ARE
STRUGGLING AND AFTER WITH
[inaudible]
YEAH Q. [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS SANDRA LEVELS AND
I'M WITH -- CINEMA COUNTY AS
WELL AND I MEAN JUST HERE JUST
JUST TO REITERATE THE THE CRISIS
IN THE BILL AFFORDABILITY -- AND
ACCESS THAT WE HAVE TO TO CHILD
CARE SO ON ON BEHALF OF MY
FAMILY ANSWER HIM COUNTY
FAMILIES YOU KNOW I ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT.
AND HELP INVEST IN IN ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS AND HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM BECAUSE WITH THIS --
INVESTMENT WE WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE QUALITY -- BY CHILD
CARE AS WELL.
AS IT WILL OBVIOUSLY BENEFIT --
OUR CHILDREN OUR CHILDREN'S WELL
BEING ARE HEALTHY HEALTHY
DEVELOPMENT AND AND ALLOW US
PARENTS TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND AND
BUILD -- SECURITY ECONOMY
ECONOMIC.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS.
ORLANDO NUMBER A JACQUELYN
CINEMA THEY THERE'S NINO SO NOW
THEY SAY YOU SHOULD READ THAT IS.
A STELLAR SPENDING AT LEAST BY
THEY SPIT ON THE GROUND IN FRONT
DALY FOR MOTHER SONYA C. MENU
YAK AND PROCESS TO PUT UP WITH
IT THAN THEIR OWN WITHOUT IN
FRONT THE LOW THEY GET IS ONLY
THE FISCAL.
RESTRAINT THE BE THE ONLY UNDER
THE LETTUCE BUT ON FIXING WITH A
SINUS BUT SYSTEM BY THE CHECKOUT.
BUT ON A FAMILIAR COMMA YOU
[inaudible]
SINCE YOU.
ON THE WAY LESS THAN AND AND
YEAH SHE'S PART OF THE BILLION
DOLLAR ASK.
YEAH.
SERVICE CENTER COMMUNITY ABOVE
BUT MUCH RSS FOR BRING. THREE
BILLION BACKS OF BILLION BACK IN
THE PROGRAM OVER THE NEXT THREE
YEARS.
I'M A SINGLE PARENT AND THE ONLY
PROVIDER OR MY FOUR KIDS -- MY
OLDER DAUGHTER HAS WAS ON THE
WAIT LIST WHEN SHE WAS YOUNGER
SHE NEVER WAS CALLED -- HER
FATHER PASSED AWAY ALMOST FOUR
YEARS AGO THIS YEAR AND ASSIST
ME.
TAKING CARE OF MY KIDS IN THIS
LITTLE BIT WOULD HELP US GO A
LOT FURTHER THAN JUST HAVING
EVERYTHING ON MY SHOULDERS.
IT WOULD HELP US WITH -- GETTING
A HOME IN -- ADVANCING IN THEIR
SCHOOL IN -- IT WOULD HELP BY
STAND HAVE A BETTER FUTURE FOR
HIMSELF WHEN HE STARTS SCHOOL IN
HE'S.
TO THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI AND MY NAME IS MARY GLACIERS
IN THE STATE ORGANIZER PAM
VOICES I'M GOING TO PASS OUT A
STUDY OF FAMILIES WHO ARE ON THE
WAITING LIST I KNOW YOU'RE
COLLECTING STORIES FROM ALL OF
US.
I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
78% OF THEM HAD TURNED DOWN OR
CUT HOURS OR DROPPED OUT OF
SCHOOL.
SORRY IT'S HARD TO FOLLOW THE
PATH.
THESE THE 89% REPORTED HIGH
STRESS 72% SAID IT AFFECTED
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH -- THE WE
DID AN AMAZING THING IN IN THIS
BODY PLAY.
IN THE MOST PROGRESSIVE CHILD
CARE ELIGIBILITY POLICIES IN THE
NATION AND THAT'S HOW CALIFORNIA
SHOULD BE IT SHOULD BE ABOUT
PROGRESS -- BUT WE OFTENTIMES
PIT PROGRESS AGAINST FAMILIES
WHO WHO AREN'T RECEIVING
SERVICES AND AND WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO BOTH THE LA -- JUST
CAME OUT AND SAID THAT WE MAY
HAVE MORE REVENUES THAN --
INITIALLY ANTICIPATED SO WE JUST
WE NEED THIS BILLION FOR
FAMILIES WHO ARE ON THE WAITING
LIST THEY ARE IN CRISIS THEY DO
NOT HAVE TIME TO WAIT FOR PEOPLE
TO PLAN AROUND THEM.
SO PLEASE LET'S WALK AND CHEW
GUM AT THE SAME TIME.
ADDRESS THE CRISIS AND PLAN
AHEAD THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
HI AND MONA WITH CONTRA COSTA I
HAVE A COUPLE SUCCESS STORIES.
WITH FAMILIES THAT WERE ABLE TO
GET A VOUCHER AND WE ARE SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE VOUCHERS THAT
WE DID RECEIVE.
BUT THEY ARE CPS AT RISK
FAMILIES WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
ACCESS OUR WORKING FAMILIES.
A WEEK JUST ARE REQUESTING THAT
WHEN BILLION.
OVER THREE YEARS -- TO ADDRESS
OUR WAITLIST.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS MONIQUE RAMOS --
ON BEHALF OF THE EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION COALITION SO THE
COALITION THANKS YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY.
WE ARE ASKING FOR BILLION
DOLLARS AND SPACES OVER THE NEXT
THREE YEARS.
SINCE THE RECESSION WE HAVE ONLY
RESTORED TEN THOUSAND GENERAL
CHILD CARE AND OUT TO BASE THIS
SPACES TO THE SYSTEM.
SO ALL THE SPACES THAT WOULD BE
GOING TO INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
WE'VE ONLY RESTORED.
TEN THOUSAND THE NATION RELEASED
A REPORT EARLIER THIS WEEK
TALKING ABOUT THE FISCAL IMPACT
OF THE CHILD CARE CRISIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT COST THE AVERAGE FAMILY
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS IN
LOST WAGES ANNUALLY.
NOT HAVING ACCESS TO CARE IT
COSTS BUSINESSES AND ELEVEN ON
AN AVERAGE OF ELEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS ANNUALLY NOT HAVING
ACCESS THEIR EMPLOYEES NOT
HAVING ACCESS.
AND IT COST THE TAXPAYERS AN
AVERAGE OF THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY DOLLARS ANNUALLY NOT
HAVING ACCESS TO CARE.
IN ADDITION WE ARE ALSO
SUPPORTING THE RATE REFORM
PROPOSAL BY SENATOR LEYVA WE
THINK THAT BASICALLY BRINGING
THE TWO PROPOSALS BRINGING THE
TWO SEPARATED RIGHT SYSTEMS INTO.
ONE WILL CREATE BETTER QUALITY
FOR SYSTEM OVERALL AND TO PAY
THE PROVIDERS WHAT THEY DESERVE.
AND THEN FINALLY.
WE ARE SUPPORT AND THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE ADDITIONAL
MONEY FOR THE WORK FORCE AS WELL
AS FOR THE FACILITIES TRAINING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM.
HI DENNIE MICHELETTI CULVER
REPRESENTING KAPPA -- WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WERE A MEMBER OF THE
ECG COALITION AND ARE PROUD TO
SIGN ON WITH THEM AND WHAT AS
WELL AS WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
I'M I'D LIKE TO UNDERSCORE THE
NEED AND THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
THE ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
HAS -- AND AND THIS IS THE
SYSTEM THAT SUPPORTS FAMILIES
AND A TWENTY FOUR SEVEN SYSTEM
IN THE BUDGET ESSENTIALLY
THERE'S NO FUNDING.
YET THIS IS THE THIS IS THE
FLEXIBLE PART OF THE SYSTEM --
WHAT I'D LIKE TO RECOMMEND FOR
THE COMMITTEE TO THINK ABOUT?
WE HEARD EARLIER ABOUT --
ALLOCATING SPACES.
WHERE THERE'S NO FACILITIES TO
SERVE THE KIDS?
LET'S TALK ABOUT MAXIMIZING IF
IT'S THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
THAT THE SPACES IN THE FUNDING
FOR PRESCHOOL CAMPY USE.
THAN WOMEN WITHIN NINETY DAYS
PUT IT OUT TO THE A PIECE I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU NOT ONE DOLLAR
WILL GO BACK AND ANOTHER WORKING
FAMILY WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
CHILDCARE.
I ALSO WANT TO TALK TO SOMEONE
MENTIONED ABOUT VARIABLE WORK
SCHEDULES AND PROVIDERS AND
WORKFORCE WE WERE WE ROLL IT ALL
INTO.
ONE WE HAVE TO START WITH THE
WORKFORCE AT VALUING THE
WORKFORCE WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
A LAW THAT SAYS THAT.
A A FAMILY IN NEED WILL SECURE A
PROVIDER.
AND YET WE ONLY PAY THE PROVIDER.
EVEN THOUGH THE THE PROVIDERS
HOLDING THE SPACE FOR THE FAMILY.
WE WILL ONLY PAY THE PROVIDER
BASED ON THE ACTUAL USAGE OF THE
FAMILY.
WELL WE PAY. FOR JANUARY WILL BE
PAYING FOR DECEMBER HOURS.
IN DECEMBER IF THE FAILY GET
SICK OF A FAMILY SOME VERY WILL
WORK SCHEDULING WASN'T SURE OF
THEIR WORK SCHEDULE AND DIDN'T
SHOW UP.
THAT PROVIDERS NOT EVEN GONNA
KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT AGAIN
GOING TO GET FULL PAYMENT UNTIL
JANUARY.
THAT HURTS US KEEPING PROVIDERS
THAT THEY CAN'T COUNT ON HOW
MUCH THEY'RE GOING TO MAKE.
FINALLY -- I'D LIKE I HAVE AN I.
T. I HAVE BUDGET REQUESTS WE
RESPECTFULLY SUBMITTED IF I CAN.
THIS STREAMLINING PROPOSAL OF
RATES THE ADDITION OF SLOTS --
THERE'S A PROPOSAL TO UNIONIZE
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS ALL OF
THOSE -- THAT TAKES MONEY AND WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
IMPLEMENTING EVERYTHING.
BETTER SERVING OUR FAMILIES
DOESN'T COME AT THE EXPENSE OF
ACTUALLY THE CASE WORK WE DO
WITH FAMILY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS ON I AM
COMMUNITIES I'M WITH EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIA WHERE AN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PROMOTING EARLY
LEARNING UP POLITY EARLY
LEARNING EXPERIENCES FOR
CHILDREN OUR STATE -- WE APPLAUD
AND APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED INVESTMENTS AND BELIEVE
IT IS BUDGET SETS THE RIGHT
VISION FOR CALIFORNIA'S EARLY
CHILDHOOD SYSTEM.
HOWEVER WE STAND WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN THE EASY COMMUNITY
WHO BELIEVE THAT THE STATE CAN
AND SHOULD DO MORE FOR FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN WHO NEED SERVICES
NOW.
PARTICULARLY IN OUR INFANT AND
TODDLER SYSTEM WE BELIEVE THAT
THE STATE OUGHT TO REFORM AND
RIGHT SIZE A REIMBURSEMENT
SYSTEM IN WAYS THAT ARE MORE
REFLECTIVE OF REGIONAL COST.
AND ALLOWS FOR APPROPRIATE
COMPENSATION OF THE WORK FORCE.
FINALLY EARLY AGE BELIEVES THAT
THE STATE MAKES THE SIGNIFICANT
THAT AS THE STATE MAKES THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS WE
SHOULD ALWAYS HAVE OUR SIGHTS ON
QUALITY THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM.
THIS INCLUDES IMPROVING THE
STANDARDS IN SETTINGS IN WHICH
WE NURTURE OUR CHILDREN AS WELL
AS IMPROVING WORK FORCE QUALITY
BY PROMOTING RIGOROUS
QUALIFICATIONS SUPPORTED BY FAIR
COMPENSATION AND MEANINGFUL AND
ONGOING PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON BACK UPON WITH
FIRST FIVE LOS ANGELES FIRST
FIVE LA SUPPORT CC COALITIONS
ROBUST BUDGET PROPOSAL.
THAT ADDRESSES ACCESS
REIMBURSEMENT RATE REFORM
FACILITIES AND WORK FORCE.
AS YOU HEARD EARLIER THERE'S A
REALLY CRITICAL NEED AND CRISIS
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO THOSE
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN MOST IN
NEED.
ONLY SUPPORT THE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT OVER THREE YEARS TO
AND FAMILIES.
ADDITIONALLY WE SUPPORT CENTER
LEAVE US CHILD CARE RATE
STABILIZATION PROPOSAL TO BETTER
ALIGN OUR RATE STRUCTURE TO
TRULY COVER THE COST OF CARE.
AND FINALLY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU ALL AROUND THE
PROPOSED WORK FORCE AND
FACILITIES INVESTMENTS THANK YOU.
IT'S BEEN.
A GOOD AFTERNOON I NEED UP WITH
A WITH -- EVERY TALK CALIFORNIA --
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ALIGN MY
COMMENTS WITH THE ECT COALITION
BUDGET REQUEST -- ALSO VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF SENATOR LEYVA AS
IT RATE STABILIZATION --
PROPOSAL AS WERE PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED AND WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL RADICALLY
CHANGE THE WAY IN WHICH WE
REIMBURSE PROGRAMS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO NOT ONLY
WILL WE NOT BE ABLE -- TO NOT
PAY APPROPRIATE RAGES ANYMORE
BUT WE WILL BE ABLE TO PAY
APPROPRIATE WAGES WE WILL BE
ABLE TO PAY FOR THE COST OF CARE
AND WE WILL BE ABLE -- TO
SUBSIDIZE FOR QUALITY ADDITIONAL
QUALITY ACTIVITIES WHEREVER YOU
ARE ON THE EASY SPECTRUM SO VERY
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT I'M ALSO
WAS NOTICED -- WE AS NOTED
EARLIER WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
ON THE OF THE ONE BILLION DOLLAR
REQUEST -- FOR INCREASED ACCESS
TO BOTH ALTERNATE PAYMENT AND
GENERAL TALKER SPACES -- AS
NOTED EARLIER THERE IS AN
INCREDIBLE NEED ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE CURRENTLY ONLY
SERVE ONE IN EVERY NINE ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN WHICH IS REALLY --
REALLY TRAGIC COULD GIVING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW WE
REALLY DO NEED TO DO BETTER SO
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THE HEARING TODAY.
AND AT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES MA'AM.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER -- I WANNA
LINE MY COMMENTS WITH -- WITH
PARENT VOICES THIS MORNING AND
THE STRUGGLES THAT THE PARENTS
PRESENTED -- HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
RAISING A FAMILY WHEN YOU'RE LOW
INCOME AND I WANT TO SUPPORT THE
ONE BILLION DOLLARS OVER THREE
YEARS FOR MORE SLOTS BECAUSE
THESE FAMILIES NEED MORE SUPPORT?
THANK YOU.
A AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MIKE BARELY JUNIOR I AM SEIU
MEMBER.
AND I'M A TEACHING ASSISTANT
SPECIAL EDUCATION AT LUTHER
BURBANK HIGH SCHOOL.
AND I HAVE TWO POINTS I'D LIKE
TO GO OVER SO I WILL BE DOUBLY
QUICK AND NOT MISS MY WORDS --
FIRST OFF -- I REQUEST THAT A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF MONIES BE
ALLOCATED FOR A ONE TIME PURPOSE
OF TEACHING -- SPECIAL EDUCATION
AIDS IN DISTRICT ON HOW TO DEAL
WITH ISSUES SUCH AS BATHROOM
BEING -- HAD A BETTER WORK WITH
OUR STUDENTS.
IN CLOSE QUARTERS WITH THEM.
AND HOW TO DEAL WITH CERTAIN
SITUATIONS -- WHAT WHETHER IT BE --
THERE LIKE A MOTIONAL DISTRESS
PHYSICAL DISTRESS HOW TO HOW TO
MANAGE THAT.
BECAUSE THERE'S TIMES WHERE
THERE IS ONE AID ONE CERTIFIED
EIGHT IN A CLASSROOM.
AND THE TEACHER WILL TAKE OFF TO
GO USE THE RESTROOM AND THE
OTHER CLASSIFIED AID WILL TAKE
OFF TO GO TAKE A BREAK AND
THERE'S ONLY ONE OF US.
THAT'S IN THAT ROOM BY OURSELVES
WITH A CLASS FULL GENERAL IT'S
STUDENTS.
AND SOMETIMES ONE OF OUR KIDS
IT'S IMMOBILE IN A WHEELCHAIR.
UNABLE TO SPEAK WE HAVE.
TO FIELD THAT AT THE SAME TIME
IS DEALING WITH THE OTHER
STUDENTS IN THE CLASSROOM.
MY OTHER POINT I WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE IS THAT -- ME BEING A
PROFESSIONAL AID AND THE TERM IS
NOT EXACTLY YOU KNOW KOSHER AT
THIS POINT YOU KNOW SPECIAL
EDUCATION AID MORE LIKE IT -- WE
LOVE OUR JOBS WE PUT OUR HEART
AND SOUL INTO OUR JOBS.
IT IN THAT LIGHT IT'S NOT TOO
MUCH TO ASK THAT WE HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO HAVE THE THE
MONEY'S.
AS FAR AS THE OUR PAY TO BE ABLE
TO DO OUR JOB.
AS BEST AS WE CAN.
WITHOUT HAVING TO RESORT.
TO YOU KNOW LIVING HALF OUT OF
OUR VEHICLES -- HAVING YOU KNOW.
HEY DO BILL SHOW UP EVERY TIME
WE GO HOME.
THAT SORT OF THING.
IT.
I'M NOT ASKING FOR THE ENTIRE
BANK JUST A LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW
NOT JUST FOR ME BUT FOR ALL THE
OTHER IS AN ADJUSTER BECAUSE I
MEAN.
WE'RE SHOULDER TO SHOULDER WITH
THE KIDS WE WORK WITH EVERY DAY
SOMETIMES WE FALL AROUND THE
CAMPUS.
ALL DAY LONG.
AND YOU KNOW WHETHER YOUR
TEACHERAND AID A PRINCIPAL OR
VICE PRINCIPAL.
STORY IN YOU KNOW THE THE PLANT
MANAGER EVERYBODY IS HAS A HAND
IN EDUCATING OUR CHILDREN.
BECAUSE IN IF IT'S NOT FOR THE
KIDS THAN WHAT WE IN A FOR THANK
YOU.
THE GERMAN SENATORS TEMPERATURES
REPRESENTING CHILD THREE SIXTY
BASED IN LOS ANGELES.
WANT TO SPEAK TO THE FIRST FOUR
ITEMS.
VIRTUAL THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
ACTING ON HIS BELIEVE SYSTEM
EARLY EDUCATON IS CRITICAL.
SECOND WE WANT TO ENDORSE THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS.
AND THANK THEM FOR THEIR ONGOING
SUPPORT AS A PRIORITY IN THEIR
IN THEIR LIVES LED DELIBERATIONS
AND THIRDLY WE WANNA DORSEY C.
COALITION.
LAST COMMENT IS.
LA ALWAYS RECOMMENDED.
DELAYING.
THE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT OF TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION
BECAUSE WE NEED MORE WORK AND SO
ON WE'RE ONLY AS GOOD AS THE
PEOPLE WHO DO THIS WORK.
AND AFFECT THE CHILDREN.
WE ENDORSE.
THE COMMENTS OF THE DEPARTMENT.
THE THIRD ONE DON'T DELAY IT
[inaudible]
IN.
TWO FOCUS ON SOME FOLKS THAT CAN
HELP COUNCIL ADVISE AND NAVIGATE
THESE YOUNG PROFESSIONALS AS
THEY GET THEIR CERTIFICATES.
IS EITHER A IS AS YOU GET THERE
BE A AND THAT WILL MOVE YOU
ALONG THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET ME JUST -- REMIND YOU TO
LOOK AROUND.
I'VE GOT A THREE PM MARCHED UP
[inaudible]
SO.
IF THOSE AT THE BACK DON'T GET
QUITE AS MUCH TIME BLAME THE
ONES AT THE FRONT SO.
HAS STICK AROUND TO THE BLAME
SIR YOU'RE NEXT YES VERY VERY
CLEAR SENATOR OUT THANK YOU
CENTER ROSS CENTER ALLEN JEFF
BARKER REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS.
LIMITING MY REMARKS TO THE ISSUE
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION.
ARE YOU HAVE CORRESPONDENCE WITH
FROM US -- JOINED BY A NUMBER OF
OTHER COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WHICH OUTLINES OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL.
WE ARE.
APPRECIATE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
FOCUS ON SPECIAL EDUCATION WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE THAT THE
GOAL SHOULD BE TO FOCUS ON
BETTER OUTCOMES.
OUR CONCERNS ARE REALLY BASED IN
THE FACT THAT WITH THE POSSIBLE
EXCEPTION OF HOME TO SCHOOL
TRANSPORTATION.
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING IN CALIFORNIA
IS ONE OF THE MOST INEQUITABLE
THAT WE LIVE WITH.
AND SO WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT APPROACH
WILL JUST EXACERBATE THOSE
INEQUITIES.
AND TO JUST GIVE YOU ONE SALIENT
EXAMPLE SENATOR ROTH.
OF AN IMPACT ON A DISTRICT IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
ARE WE TALKED A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO ABOUT HOW FOR UNIFIED IN THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND FISCAL DISTRESS.
THEY HAVE BEEN -- DEALING WITH --
GENERAL INCREASING GENERAL FUND
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE COSTS OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION WHICH OVER THE
LAST SEVEN YEARS HAVE TOTALED
ALMOST A HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
SO IT DOES BECOME A REAL
PRESSURE ON THE DISTRICTS THAT
ARE IN THOSE SITUATIONS SO WE
WOULD ADVOCATE FOR EQUALIZATION
TO BE A PIECE.
OF ANY SOLUTION AND THEN LASTLY
WE ALSO THAT IS LONG GONE A
PRIORITY IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY THE
FOCUS ON EARLY INCLUSION
PROGRAMS.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THAT WOULD
BE A FRUITFUL INVESTMENT AS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
YES MA'AM GOOD AFTERNOON
MICHELLE MCANDREW IT ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION.
FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE THAT WE'RE
HAVING THIS CONVERSATION BUT
THERE ARE DOLLARS ON THE TABLE
FOR SPECIAL AT FUNDING WE HAVE
FOR YEARS ADVOCATED FOR MORE
SPECIALIZED RESOURCES AND SELL.
FOR VERY HOPEFUL THAT AT THE END
OF THIS CONVERSATION WE HAVE A
SPECIAL ED FUNDING SYSTEM THAT
IS MORE EQUITABLE BUT IT IS
TODAY.
I THINK THAT IT SHOULD BE OUR
KEY ARE WE ARE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF A PROPOSAL THAT IS
NOW TWO YEARS IN THE MAKING AB --
FOR TWENTY EIGHT WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE SENATE CONSIDER THE
STRUCTURE OF EQUALIZATION --
WE'RE SUGGESTING UP TO THE
NINETY FIFTH PERCENTILE -- YOU
HEARD FROM THE LA -- TODAY THAT
SOME DISTRICTS HAVE QUITE A BIT
OF THEIR OF THEIR RESOURCES
GOVERNOR THERE COSTS COVERED ON
AVERAGE THE STATE COVERS 25% OF
THE COST OF SPECIAL EDUCATION.
THAT MEANS A FULL 66% ON AVERAGE
IS COVERED BY THE GENERAL FUND
BY LCF DOLLARS SO WE KNOW THAT
EVERY DOLLAR THAT THAT GOES IN
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION.
WILL BENEFIT EVERY STUDENT BOTH
THE GENERAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
AND THOSE SPECIAL ED PROGRAMS WE
ALSO WOULD PROPOSE PRESCHOOL
FUNDING WE KNOW THAT IS SUCH A
SMART INVESTMENT.
HAVE PRESCHOOL FOR THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS DISTRICTS ARE
DOING IT NOW THAT'S AGAIN A
SIGNIFICANT COSTS FOR THEM EVEN
THOUGH THEY KNOW IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT NEED.
WE ALSO HEARD TODAY ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN ABOUT
THE HIGH COST DISABILITIES
ESPECIALLY AUTISM YOU HEARD
ABOUT THAT TODAY ON THE SENATE
FLOOR AS RECOGNIZING AUTISM
AWARENESS MONTH.
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS NEED THERE
TOO AND SO WE WOULD SUGGEST
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR THOSE
STUDENTS WITH THE MOST HIGH COST
DISABILITIES.
HOPEFULLY YOU RECEIVED A COUPLE
DOZEN MAYBE EVEN A HUNDRED
LETTERS SUPPORTING THIS APPROACH --
I AM JUST BRING ONE HERE FROM
THE SPECIAL EDUCATION TASK FORCE
ON THE STATE WIDE TASK FORCE
THAT WAS -- CONVENED A COUPLE
YEARS AGO -- THEY SUPPORT -- OUR
PROPOSAL -- AND I'M BRINGING YOU
THE LETTER FROM THEIR PUBLIC
SECOND DIRECTORS -- THAT WILL
HOPEFULLY AND FROM THIS
CONVERSATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM [inaudible]
NEXT. EIGHT MY NAME IS ROBIN
MUCH LATER AND I WORK HERE IN
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT I WORKED IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION AS AN INSTRUCTIONAL
AIDE FOR TWELVE YEARS -- AND I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF LOCAL SEIU
LOCAL -- TEN TO ONE I SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED SPECIAL
EDUCATION BUDGET AND I'M ASKING
FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
WORKER TRAINING IN ORDER TO KEEP
THIS WORK IN HOUSE.
GIVEN OUR CURRENT BUDGET CRISIS
IN SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT -- IT WOULD BE
BEST PRACTICE TO TRAIN
INSTRUCTIONAL AIDES BETTER AND
TO STOP FUNDING FOR PROFIT BASED
PROVIDERS WHICH IS OUTSOURCING.
ALSO TO SPEAK -- TO THE THREE
YEAR OLDS AND THOSE GETTING LOST
IN THE CRACKS IF I CAN -- I KNOW
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT SPECIFICALLY
STARTS THEM AT THREE WHERE ONE
OF THE FEW SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
DO THAT WHICH AGAIN IS A REASON
WHY WE NEED BETTER TRAINING FOR
INSTRUCTIONAL AIDES BECAUSE
THOSE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
SETTING THOSE. THREE YEARS ALL
OF THREE YEAR OLDS UP FOR
SUCCESS TO GO INTO THE CAN
DIFFERENT GRAMS WE OFTENTIMES
KEEP CONTINUITY OF CARE -- ALSO
TO SPEAK TO THAT WITH US DOING
ALL OF HOSE THINGS.
I WE HEARD EARLIER TODAY THAT
THERE'S FUNDING BETWEEN FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT DOLLARS
TO NINE OH EIGHT IF I HAVE THE
NUMBERS CORRECT WHEN I SAW.
THAT THE SPECIAL ED -- FORCE THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE WAS SPEAKING TO
WE GET ON THE LOWER SIDE OF FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY EIGHT THOSE
NUMBERS ARE NOT PROPORTIONATELY
DIVVY OUT.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT WE DO AND
HOW WE START YOUNGER AND HOW WE
KEEP THAT CONTINUITY OF CARE AND
EXACTLY ALL THE STUDENTS THAT WE
HELP WITH SPECIAL EDUCATION.
AND OUR NUMBER IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION THE PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS THAT WE HAVE WHY ARE WE
ONLY GETTING FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT DOLLARS I THINK THAT NEEDS
TO BE REVISITED.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME I APPRECIATE YOU.
SENATE ROTH CENTER ALLEN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND YOUR
SINCERE INTEREST IN THE TOPICS
TODAY IT'S VERY CLEAR.
I'LL BE BRIEF I WANT TO BUILD
UPON THE COMMENTS OF MISTER
ANDERSON FROM THE LA ELAM'S
PROVOCA FROM RIVERSIDE.
I REPRESENT FORTY SEVEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN KERN COUNTY -- THEY
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
EQUALIZATION PROPOSAL IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION -- AS MISTER BACCHUS
SAID SPECIAL IT EQUALIZATION OF
THE FOR THE 40% OF THE FUNDS
THAT ARE RECEIVED FROM STATE AND
FEDERAL.
ARE GROSSLY INEQUITABLE YOU
DISTRIBUTED IN THE STATE.
IT'S THE ONE PROBLEM THAT YOU
CAN REALLY ADDRESS AND FAX.
WE APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
GREAT IDEAS THE LEGISLATURE FOR
THEIR GREAT IDEAS WITH SPECIAL
EDUCATION BUT UNTIL WE CREATE A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD OR EVERY
DISTRICT CAN ACCESS ANY NEW
RESOURCES.
FAIRLY.
WE'RE COMPOUNDING THE PROBLEM
MORE EXACERBATING IT IS MISTER
BACCHUS AT SUITE -- JEW TO
SUPPORT EQUALIZATION IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION THANK YOU SIR NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME STEPHANIE
SHORTER -- EVER FOR THE SEX CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT JOHN
MORRIS THERAPEUTICS BETTER -- I
WORK.
EXCLUSIVELY WITH NEEDY KIDS I
CONSERVE MOTIONAL DISTURBANCES.
I AM VERY THANKFUL TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE BUDGET FOR
HOPEFUL FOR SPECIAL NEEDS BEING
ADDRESSED.
OF THAT SAID.
I REALLY MORE TRAINING NEEDS TO
GO AND ORDER FOR PRESS HER
PROFESSIONALS -- THREE ABLE TO
PROPERLY CARE AND EDUCATE THEM.
WE'RE THE ONES WHO TEACH THEM ON
THE TEACHERS AREN'T HERE.
WHEN THEY GO OUT FOR THEIR IP
MEETINGS OR ONCE UPS COME IN A
LOT OF THE TIME WE'RE STILL THE
ONES THAT DO?
THE HISTORY LESSONS OF THE MATH
LESSONS THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
KNOW THE ROUTINE FOR THE DAY --
WE NEED THOSE SKILLS THAT.
THE TEACHERS OF LEARNED BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO THE SCHOOLS.
I CAME FROM A DIFFERENT QUESTION
TIGHTLY.
WHEN I CAME AND I STARTED AS A
SUB FOR THE DISTRICT?
AND THEN I BECAME PERMANENT --
BUT THAT MEANS THAT I DON'T HAVE
THE SAME EDUCATION THAT A
TEACHER WOULD WHICH OBVIOUSLY
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE I'M.
JUST UP AND EIGHT BUT I'M NOT
JUST IN A BECAUSE I'M THE ONE
THAT.
FITS WITH THOSE KIDS ALL DAY
LONG I'M THE ONE THAT HELPS
TAKEN THROUGH.
STEP BY STEP MATH LESSONS THAT
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND AND TRY
AND BREAK IT DOWN.
TôI THEY'LL TO THE WAY THAT
THEY WILL UNDERSTAND IT.
KNOWING THAT I'M GONNA HAVE TO
GO OVER ANOTHER KID AND TEACH
THEM HOW TO DO THAT AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT WAY BECAUSE THEIR
BRAIN WORKS AND THEN TIE REALLY
DIFFERENT WAY -- AS MUCH AS THE
KIDS THING AT THIS MONEY WE NEED
THAT MONEY TOO SO WE CAN MAKE
THE GETS BETTER.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU COVERED YES
MA'AM.
ERICA OFTEN ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION FIRST OFF I WOULD
ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO VOTE SO
STATE MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS
OF MISTER ROCKET WITH THE
COMMENTS OF MEN'S UNDERWEAR.
THE NEED FOR EQUALIZATION LISTEN
SPECIAL IT IS VRY VERY
IMPORTANT ESPECIALLY AT A POINT
IN TIME.
WHEN FEDERAL FUNDING HAS NOT
KEPT UP IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR FORM
WITH THE PROMISED 40% -- CSPA IS
ONE ALSO OF A COLOSSAL COLD
SPONSOR OF AB FOR TWENTY EIGHT
SO WE APPRECIATE THAT -- CONCERN
AS YOUR AS YOU'RE TALKING
THROUGH ALL THESE ISSUES ONE
THING I DO WANT TO POINT OUT FOR
PRESCHOOL.
IN CALIFORNIA WE RECEIVED VERY
VERY LITTLE FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
PRESCHOOL UNDER -- ID A PART B..
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE BEEN-TRYING TO WORK ON AS WE'VE TRIED
TO INCREASE ALL THE REST OF IT A
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
BUT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY HAS HAD AN EXTREME EFFECT
ON SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
IN TRYING TO RAMP UP THESE
PROGRAMS WHICH IS THEN PUT A
GREATER -- EFFORT AND AND IMPACT
INTO LOCAL GENERAL FUND BUDGET
WE APPRECIATE ALL YOUR CONCERNS
WE LOOK FORWARD TO FOR THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU THANK YOU
MA'AM.
HI I'M CHRISTINA POLICY ON OUR
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND I'M ALSO ON AS THE I
REMEMBER.
MINE IS A BANK FOR FOR THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSING IN THAT WE
HAVE MONEY.
MY ISSUE IS THAT IF I HAVE TO
HAVE TAKE A DAY OFF FROM SCHOOL
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH ASSISTANCE
BECAUSE NOBODY WANTS TO COME TO
WORK FOR OUR DISTRICT BECAUSE WE
DON'T.
IT'S VERY HARD TO WORK WITH
SPECIAL ED BUT WE DO CONTRACT
OUT TO A LOT OF THAT
[inaudible]
OTHER.
YOU KNOW LIKE LEARNING SOLUTIONS.
THEY CAN MANDATE WORK WITH ONE
STUDENT ONLY WE HAVE TO WORK.
WITH ALL OUR STUDENTS AT THAT
TIME.
WE DON'T.
GET A CHANCE TO ACTUALLY WHEN A
TEACHER LEAVES AROUND TO
ACTUALLY WORK WITH ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS BECAUSE OF THE TIME.
WE ARE THE ONLY ONES IN THAT
CLASSROOM WE MIGHT HAVE AN
ASSISTANT THAT COMES IN FROM
ANOTHER DISTRICT ANOTHER IT'S
BEEN CONTRACTED INTO US.
THEY WILL NOT WORK WITH ANYONE
BUT JUST THAT WHEN STUDENT.
SARAH MIGHT IS IF THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY GET SOME MORE FUNDING
TO TRAIN SOME TRAINERS.
AND GET MAYBE SOME OTHER
ASSISTANCE THAT WOULD WANT TO
COME AND WORK FOR US.
AND LET SOME OF THESE
CONTRACTORS [inaudible]
LEAVE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU RICHARD.
YES SIR.
MY DILLON REPRESENT THE SAN
JOAQUIN COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION -- WE ARE ALSO LISTED
ON THE LETTER THAT MR BOCK
REFERRED TO IN A FEW MOMENTS SO
WE JUST WRONG THEY ARGUE A TO
ADDRESS IT ISSUE OF EQUALIZATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR YES SIR GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRIS FOR MIRACLE --
HEAD START CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING THE HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN GRANTEES OF THE STATE THAT
SERVE ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN.
TODAY WE'RE SHARING OUR REQUEST
OF FOR BUDGET ALLOCATION TWENTY
MILLION TO SUPPORT THE EARLY
CARE DENTAL MENTAL PHYSICAL
HEALTH THAT IS PROVIDED TO
CALIFORNIA'S MOST AT RISK
CHILDREN.
EIGHT ZERO TO FIVE WE BELIEVE I
REQUEST IS A CONSISTENT WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU EXCERPT.
YES MA'AM.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AARON EVANS
ON BEHALF OF THE SELF
ADMINISTRATORS IN CALIFORNIA TO
COMMENT ON THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
CONCENTRATION GRANT PROPOSAL OUT
WE ARE FIRST OF ALL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT -- TO
CHILDREN IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
I'M AS WELL AS WE ARE GRATEFUL
FOR ALL DOLLARS SPENT FOR
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES WE DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS HOWEVER WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- WHICH
YOU'VE HEARD BEFORE WHICH IS
ESSENTIALLY THE EXACERBATIONS OF
FUNDING INEQUITIES -- THAT THAT
YOU'VE HEARD IN SOME OF THE
COMMENTS PREVIOUSLY.
OUT WE HAVE OUTLINED A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW BEST TO
USE SOME OF THIS FUNDING.
AND WE'VE SUBMITTED THAT TO YOU
IN WRITING I WILL NOT BELABOR IT
BUT JUST HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF
THINGS -- WE WOULD RECOMMEND
USING PER EIGHTY A FUNDING FOR
PRESCHOOL STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IN LINE WITH THE A
BEFORE TWENTY EIGHT PROPOSAL.
WE COULD FULLY FUND AT THE A. B.
SIX OH TWO FAR FUNDING FORMULA --
BY ELIMINATING THE PREPARATION
FACTOR.
I'M OR WE COULD ADD ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO THE EXTRAORDINARY
GOSPEL ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
HELP I'M IN MANY WAYS -- SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ELAINE I'VE BEEN.
I AM OF FROM PENINSULA FAMILY
SERVICE IN SAN MATEO.
I'M THAT REPRESENTING -- ONE OF
OUR CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
CENTERS IN SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO.
I AND THE PROVIDING SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE FOR PRESCHOOL AND
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN.
I'M I AM HAVE A SPECIFICALLY
HERE.
IN SUPPORT OF THE ISLAND.
INCREASE IN THE RE IMPAIR
REIMBURSEMENT RATES SYSTEM.
AND ALSO IN THE IN IN SUPPORT OF
FIND.
OUT TEACHERS.
N. AND PROVIDING FOR PROVIDING
ADEQUATE I A HELP. FOR FOR FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO WHO CREATE THE
WONDERFULLY ENVIRONMENTS AND NOT
CHILD DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
I WITH HIGHER REGIONAL ALLIES
TRAITS.
TITLE FIVE CENTERS IN HIGH COST.
AREAS WOULD BE BETTER ABLE TO
MATCH THE LOCAL COST OF LIVING
FOR THEIR STAFF.
I'M SO THE STAFF OFTEN WOULD NOT
NEED.
TO WORK SEVERAL JOBS.
AND THEY WOULD ALSO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT SUCH AS COACHING
WHICH HAS BEEN PROVOKED PROVEN
TO BE VERY EFFECTIVE.
I AND THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
ASSIST TEACHERS IN FINISHING
THEIR DEGREES.
I AM CREATING A MORE APPEALING
WORK ENVIRONMENT FOR HIGHLY
QUALIFIED ON I EDUCATORS.
AT THE STABILITY -- THE WELL.
COMPENSATED WORKFORCE COMP
CONTRIBUTED CONTRIBUTES THE
CONTINUITY OF CARE FOR CHILDREN.
I IMPROVED QUALITY OF TEACHING
AND REDUCED PRO PROGRAM COST --
WHICH ARE OFTEN ASSOCIATED WITH
SUBSTITUTE AND HIRING PROCESS IS
AN INITIAL TRAINING.
I WHEN STATE FUNDED ARE EASY
EASY E. PROGRAMS.
HAVE ENOUGH TEACHERS THEY CAN
FILL THEIR CLASSROOMS AND SERVE
MORE ELIGIBLE CHILDREN.
THROUGH THESE REFORMS CALIFORNIA
CAN ACHIEVE A MORE EQUITABLE
SYSTEM. TO SUPPORT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
AND MAXIMIZE PUBLIC BENEFITS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
[inaudible]
NEXT.
I ROBIN LAYTON EDUCATIONAL
RICHMOND SYSTEMS FROM SAN DIEGO
WE'RE A NONPROFIT OR A CBO OR A
NON ELLIE AA.
AND I SERVE -- THROUGH MY
ORGANIZATION WE HAVE ELEVEN
HUNDRED LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
VINCE THROUGH ENTRANCED
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AND I ALSO
HAVE.
OF EMPLOYEE A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE PEOPLE OUR PRIORITIES ARE
THE RATES THE RATES MUST BE A
PRIORITY AS OUR PROFESSIONAL
TEACHERS.
ARE SUBSIDIZING THE TRUE COST BY
ACCEPTING LOWER WAGES.
WE NEED RATES BEFORE YOU
INCREASE LOTS WE NEED FACILITIES
BEFORE YOU INCREASE LOT.
COUPLE OTHER COMMENTS THAT CAME
UP TODAY WAS THE REGARDING
EXPANSION THE NON ELEAZAR CBO'S
ALREADY TO EXPAND.
AS EVIDENCED BY THE RECENT GRANT
EXPANSION APPLICATION.
ALSO -- I DO NOT SUPPORT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ANOTHER PLAN
WE HAVE ENOUGH PLANS WE KNOW
WHAT TO DO THE MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM IS IS IN PLACE WE JUST
NEED RATES EXPANSION AND THE AND
FACILITIES.
ALSO THE COMMON ABOUT THE INCOME
CEILINGS WHEN I STARTED THIRTY
FIVE YEARS AGO A FAMILIES COULD
STAY IN THE PROGRAM UNTIL THEY
WERE AT A 100% OF THE STATE
MEDIAN INCOME.
I RECOMMEND THAT WE IF WE WANT
TO HAVE THAT CONVERSATION WE GO
TO A HUNDRED OR A 150%.
AND THAT WAY WE CAN -- NOT
REALLY A NOT WE CAN REWARD
FAMILIES FOR MOVING UP THE
CAREER RIGHT LETTER RATHER THAN --
HAVING THEM STAY LOW INCOME
BECAUSE WHEN THEY INCOME OUT.
THEN THEY YOU KNOW THE WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER THAT THE OTHER
THING THAT WAS A LITTLE
CONCERNING OR CONFUSING THIS
MORNING.
WAS NOT GOING TO TALK ABOUT THIS
BUT IN THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
FULL DAY.
KINDERGARTEN.
TURNING INTO LET'S GROW TKA
MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
WITH FOUR YEAR OLDS BELONG IN
PRESCHOOL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SURE GOOD AFTERNOON LONG ISLAND
LONG FROM FACES SF -- CO WE RUN
A NON ELLIE A CAL.
CALPERS VISION IN SAN FRANCISCO
WE HAVE BY EIGHTY TEACHERS.
AND SURVIVE SIX HUNDRED KIDS
EVERY DAY.
LET ME GO THROUGH THE DOWN THE
PRIORITY.
LET'S REFORM OUR RATES TO THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATES.
PLEASE PAY THE TEACHERS FIRST
THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
AND THEN WE CAN MAKE SURE WE
HAVE FACILITIES READY AND SLOTS
WOULD BE LAST WE'VE BEEN IN THIS
BUSINESS FOR ABOUT SIXTEEN YEARS.
AND NOW WE THE PERFECT TIME THE
GOVERNOR LEGISLATORS.
US IN THE FIELD AND THERE'S
MONEY AVAILABLE SO YOU HAVE ALL
THE FOUR ELEMENTS LET'S MAKE IT
THIS YEAR THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE EXCITED ABOUT THAT.
EXACTLY.
YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME -- JOHN
BRASS WHO LOCAL NINE NINE MEMBER --
STUDENTS ETA MEMBERS CTA MEMBER
AND ALSO ANY A MEMBER.
FROM I JUST WANT YOU GUYS TO
APPROVE THE BUDGET -- WITH THE
GOVERNOR SAID -- AWESOME BUDGET.
ARM BUT THAT TWO MILLION DOLLAR
PLANNING I THINK THE PLANNING
SHOULD GO TO THE TEACHERS WE GET
A LOT OF TEACHERS IN A LET
PLANNING.
IF NOT IN THERE HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE LOCAL PEOPLE
THE COMMITTEE ACT WAS THAT
COMMUNITY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S
GOOD FOR THE COMMUNITY.
IS A COLLECTOR OF PEOPLE IN
DIFFERENT AREAS THAT NOTED FOR
THINGS OUT THINGS WORK IT A MOVE
A LOT FASTER A LOT SMOOTHER.
OWN SPECIAL EDUCATION'S BEEN
UNDER FUNDING FOR MULTIPLE YEARS --
I THINK WE ALL NEED TO SIGN A
PETITION TO START STOP SAYING IN
OUR WORK WE HAVE THAT GOING ON
RIGHT NOW AT CERTAIN SCHOOL SIZE
WITH ANY TO BE ADOPTED BY THE
WHOLE NATION.
SO WE CAN START WITH CALIFORNIA
BEING A TREND SETTER FOR THAT --
I DEAL WITH STORIES WITH PARENTS
CRYING BECAUSE THEY CAN GET
FUNDING FOR THEIR KID WITH A
DISABILITY OMITTED FOR FIVE
YEARS TO MEET THAT FUNNY WE NEED
TO HAVE A FASTER PROCESS FOR
THAT. FOR THAT OUR TO EVERYTHING
LOOK AT THE LEVEL EDUCATION
STARTING FROM THREE ALL THE WAY
UP TO JUNIOR COLLEGE SO WITH
WITH THAT BEING SAID I FEEL LIKE
WHEN THEY HAVE MORE TRANSPARENCY
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION.
AND WITH THE HELP OF YOU GUYS
AND THE HELP OF ALL THESE GREAT
PEOPLE BEHIND ME IN A PEOPLE TO
SMOKE FOR ME WE CAN GET THAT
DONE.
AND I KNOW WAS THAT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT WORK WOULD
YOU GOT TO LOVE IT WOULD SEEM TO
GET THAT BUDGET APPROVED THANK
YOU I KNOW YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED
TO SAY BUT WHAT IS THE R. WORD.
I WILL SAY IT ON BUT IS WHAT
THEY USED TO CALL MENTALLY
RETROVIRUS OKAY.
I'M SORRY I DIDN'T.
CATCH IT THANK YOU.
OKAY.
I AM I'M AGNES BRAGA I'M A
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY
ASSISTANT WORKING FOR LAUSD AND
I'M ALSO.
SEIU LOCAL I. N. MEMBER AS WELL
AS THE SECRETARY FOR THE E.
BOARD -- MY EXPERIENCE AS A
SPEECH LANGUAGE PATHOLOGY
ASSISTANT IS GOING TO DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS SITES AND SEEING THE
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN -- AREAS
LIKE THE WEST SIDE IN LOS
ANGELES HAVING THE SUPPORT OF
PARENTS WITH MONEY VERSES IN
EAST LA ARE SOUTH CENTRAL WHERE
PARENTS EVEN IF THEY WORK
THIRTEEN HOURS A DAY.
STILL CAN'T SUPPORT THE SCHOOL
SITE.
SO WHAT I'VE NOTICED IS THAT IN
THE WEST SIDE -- THERE'S FUNDING.
FOR YOU KNOW FOR WHATEVER THE
SCHOOL NEEDS.
AND THAT WAY KIDS ARE YOU KNOW
WHO HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS CAN BE
SUPPORTED.
AND I'VE ALSO DONE --
AUGMENTATIVE ALTERNATIVE
COMMUNICATION WHERE I GO TO
DIFFERENT SCHOOL SITES AND DROP
OFF THE COMMUNICATION DEVICES OF
STUDENTS WHO CAN'T TALK OR ARE
PHYSICALLY DISABLED SO I'VE SEEN
A DIFFERENT -- CENTERS THAT
THESE KIDS WITH DISABILITIES GO
AND THE LACK OF FUNDING MEANS
THEY DON'T GET THE EQUIPMENT
THEY NEED.
AND THROUGH THEIR I EP THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO GET YOU KNOW THE
SUPPORT [inaudible]
AND IF THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
FUNDING THEY FIND WAYS TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO SHORTEN THE AMOUNT OF
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED.
AND THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE
STUDENT AND THAT'S NOT GOOD.
IF WE'RE WORKING TO TO HELP THE
STUDENTS.
AND IN REGARDS TO MEDICAL
REIMBURSEMENTS WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
SEE TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
STUDENTS AS A SPEECH ASSISTANT.
AND THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO
DOCUMENT ALL THOSE STUDENTS ON
WELL AGENT WHICH IS THE SOFTWARE
THAT WE USE.
AND WE'RE SUPPOSED TO DO ALL OF
THAT BY.
TWO THIRTY AND WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
TAKE OUR LUNCHES.
AND OUR BREAKS IN BETWEEN THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH TIME TO DOCUMENT ALL
THOSE STUDENTS.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU KNOW THAT IS A PROBLEM
WITH A LACK OF FUNDING IS THAT
WERE EXPECTED TO DO THE WORK IN
A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME.
AND NOT PAY US FOR THE
DOCUMENTATION AFTER WORK THAT WE
DO.
SO THESE ARE THE THINGS THAT.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO REALIZE THAT
THE DISTRICTS THEY'RE DOING
THEIR THING TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY KEEP THE MONEY BUT THE
WORKERS ARE NOT GIVEN.
WHAT THEY'RE AND THEY'RE IN IT?
THANK YOU THANK YOU
.
FOR HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH PARK
I'M A SPECIAL ASSISTANT.
I WORK FAIRLY UST AT NIGHT
STREET ELEMENTARY.
I HAVE BEEN -- WORKING IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND I
CURRENTLY WORK IN A CLASS SO
WHERE WE ASSIST WITH BE ICE.
MICE SUGGESTION IS FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO USE THAT UTILIZE THE
MONEY TO HELP US SO THAT WE'RE
NOT.
ALLOWING THE NON PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO CONTINUE BEHAVIORAL SO MANY
TIMES WHERE THEY ARE FOR A
RECESS AND LUNCH WE HAVE TO
SUPERVISE THEM.
THEY CAN ASSIST THEM WITH THEIR
WORK.
WE HAVE TO GET ON A BUS WITH
THEM WE WILL HAVE TO BE THE
WANTED TO GET ON THE BUS WITH
THEM THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO DO
THE BUS RIGHTS WITH THEM.
SO THERE'S MANY THINGS THAT NOT
PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO DO AND I THINK IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAT THE MONEY IS
UTILIZED.
TO HIRE MORE OF US TO BE IN THE
CLASSROOMS IN TO GET THE
TRAINING THAT WE NEED SO THAT WE
CAN BE MORE SUPPORTIVE FOR
SPECIAL ED.
STUDENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU YES
THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COALITION FOR
ADEQUATE SCHOOL HOUSING TO SPEAK
TO YOU ON THE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES GRANT
PROGRAM ITEM.
CASH DOES SUPPORT THE SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
HELP WITH OUR KINDERGARTEN
FACILITIES.
WE KNOW THAT THE DEMAND IS THERE
WE ALSO KNOW THAT MANY OF OUR
KINDERGARTEN KIDS AND ESPECIALLY
OUR TKA KIDS ARE NOT ACTUALLY
CURRENTLY BEING HOUSED IN
FACILITIES.
THAT MEET THE REGULATIONS SO
THINK THE TINY TOILETS THE
LARGER CLASSROOM SIZE I HAVE A
KINDERGARTEN OR MYSELF AND I
KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE HIS LEARNING --
IT REALLY DOES IMPACT THE DAY
AND THEIR ABILITY TO LEARN -- WE
HAVE SORT OF A TECHNICAL ISSUE
THAT WE BELIEVE CAN BE RESOLVED
IT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED IN
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
REGARDING THE ADMINISTRATION OF
THE PROGRAM RIGHT NOW WHEN YOU
ADD A FACILITY -- THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM YOU ARE GOING TO END UP
BEING CHARGED AGAINST FUTURE
SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY BY ADDING THAT NEW
CLASSROOM THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY A PENALTY
AGAINST FUTURE SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM BUT IT DOESN'T JUST
AFFECT CANDOR IT'S K. THROUGH
SIX ELIGIBILITY WE THINK THAT
THIS CAN BE.
A PRETTY EASILY TWEAKED IN THE
TRAILER BILL.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO MENTION
IS WE APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION
ABOUT HOW BEST TO TO PARK AT THE
FUNDS AND WE APPRECIATE HEARING
ABOUT TARGETING THEM TO LOW
INCOME STUDENTS WE THINK THAT
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL REFINEMENTS
THAT CAN BE MADE IN THE PROGRAM.
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
KNOWLEDGE MEANT OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF FACILITIES FOR OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
YES SIR.
IN THE GARAGE WITH THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS ITEM
FIVE AN ITEM -- SEVEN ON ITEM
FIVE WE APPRECIATE THE DIRECTION
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT
LA U. S. D. ENCOURAGES.
ALLOWING THE USE OF FUNDS FOR
EXISTING EARLY EDUCATION
PROGRAMS -- WE'VE MADE SOME
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS IN EARLY
AND I INCLUDING AND STUDENTS WHO
WE DON'T RECEIVE A DA FUNDING.
FOR I. N. ON ITEM SEVEN I MEAN
YOU'VE HEARD IT FROM SOME OF THE
OTHER SPEAKERS WHO WORK AT LAUSD --
WE AGREE SPECIAL EDUCATION IT'S
SIGNIFICANTLY UNDERFUNDED -- WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WE BELIEVE THAT THE CONVERSATION
HE FOCUSED -- SHOULD BE AROUND
TARGETED FUNDING THAT'S BASED ON
NEED AND THAT FOCUSES ON
IMPROVING STUDENT PERFORMANCE
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON DEBORAH BROWN ON
BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW -- TAKING
ON ITEMS ONE THROUGH FOUR WE
REALLY WANNA APPLIED AND
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR COMING
OUT REALLY STRONG ON THE GATE ON
AN EARLY EDUCATION PROPOSAL
STARTING WITH -- PRESCHOOL
EXPANSION RECOGNIZING THE NEED
FOR THAT BUT ALSO ADDRESSING THE
WORK FORCE AND CAPACITY AND
FACILITIES NEEDS THAT WE ALSO
NEED TO ADDRESS.
AND ALSO JOINING UP MY EASY
COALITION COLLEAGUES AT YOU KNOW
ASKING FOR THE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS TO TELL TO ENSURE THAT
WE HAVE ACCESS TO SPACES FOR OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS ARE.
ZERO TO THREE POPULATION -- WE
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN BE EXPECTING
INCREASING ACCESS WHILE WE'RE
ALSO EXPANDING AND LOOKING AT
CAPACITY AND QUALITY OF PROGRAMS
ONE OF THE THINGS I ALSO WANTED
TO KNOW WAS AROUND THE ISSUE
AROUND EXPANDING THE WORK FORCE
QUALIFICATIONS.
JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT AS WE
THINK ABOUT THAT THAT'S NOT
WITHIN THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM'S
NOT WITHIN THE STATUS QUO THAT'S
ALSO BEING COUPLED WITH THE THE
RATE REFORM CONVERSATION THAT'S
PART OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS ASK.
BUT ALSO INCREASED -- AT
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENTS --
SCHOLARSHIPS AND ALSO ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR TEACHERS AS THEY
BUILD THEIR QUALIFICATIONS AWAKE
IT HAS TO BE PART OF THAT
BROADER SYSTEM EXPANSION WHEN WE
THINK ABOUT -- WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT THAT IT'S ALSO SUPPORTING
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS ASKS AROUND --
WORKFORCE EQUITY FAMILY FRIENDLY
POLICIES AND ACCESS TO CARE AND
THEN JUST A NOTE ON ITEM ON AN
ITEM SET SEVEN ON SPECIAL
EDUCATION JUST WHEN I PICK UP A
PLOT THE GOVERNOR AGAIN.
FOR PUTTING SOME MONEY TOWARDS
ADDRESSING A REALLY SPECIFIC
NEED IN AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
AROUND OUR AGAIN ARE EARLY IS
LEARNING LEARNERS AND FINDING
THAT DISTRICTS DON'T GET.
WHILE THE STUFF TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO LOOK FORWARD TO
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS AROUND
THAT POPULATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
JUST TO POINT OUT WE'VE GOT
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MINUTES AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF YOU YOU
ARE SO BREVITY IS APPRECIATED
BUT PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU MAKE
YOUR POINT YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON SERRA BOTCHES
THAT THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT OF ITEM FIVE HER FUNDING
THE FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
FACILITIES PROGRAM.
AND THEN ON ITEM SEVEN WERE ALSO
A CO SPONSOR BABY FOUR SIX A
FOUR TWENTY EIGHT ON THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING AND SO
ENSURING THAT ONE WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZING COMMEND THEM
MINISTRATION FOR FINALLY
PROVIDING RESOURCES TO THIS
NEEDED ISSUE.
ALSO AFFECTED NOT INCLUDE ORA
DRASTIC NATIONAL EDUCATION
DURING THIS DISCUSSION SO WE
REALLY NEED TO MAKE THE MOST
CONCERNED ABOUT FIRST INSURE
THAT WE ARE FUNDING AND
RECOGNIZING MANY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU YES MA'AM
YOU ALWAYS MENTION BREVITY RIGHT
BEFORE YOU SEE ME -- OKAY ALL
RIGHT.
CAN REALLY WAY THAT COMMITTEE
WAS WORKING WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION AS
A MEMBER OF THE EASY COALITION I
WANT TO PLUG ONE MORE TIME THAT
RELEASE PART OF THAT PROPOSAL OR
ALSO I THANKFUL FOR THE
INCLUSION OF TRAINING AND
APPRENTICESHIP IN THAT ASKED --
I ALSO ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY MEMBERS THAT CAME HERE TODAY --
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING BUT WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE A DIRECTED TOWARDS
OUR CLASSIFIED WORKERS JUST
DOING ONE TIME FUNDING FOR B. I.
TRAINING OR TARGETED TRAINING.
ALLOWS DISTRICTS TO KEEP THE
MEMBERS IN THE HOUSE WHICH
PROVIDES LONG TERM SAVINGS
INCREASED ABILITY FOR THESE
STUDENTS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
SENDING ME EVENTS WITH MISSION
NEIGHBORHOOD CENTERS OUT OF SAN
FRANCISCO SERVING OVER FOUR
HUNDRED FAMILIES AND CHILDREN.
IN EARLY CARE HEAD START EARLY
HEAD START -- WITH CD FUNDING AS
WELL AND I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S BILL --
SUPPORTING TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FACILITIES
MISSION EVER HEARD CENTERS IS
SHOVEL READY ON TWO PROJECTS.
AND WE'D LIKE TO GET THOSE
FACILITIES GOING AND HAVING
MALES -- I FACILITIES AVAILABLE
FOR CHILDREN AS SOON AS POSSIBLE
WE LOOK FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THAT.
MAKE THEM THANK YOU THANKS FOR
JOINING YES MA'AM.
I AM KELLY WHEATLEY AND I AM A
PRESCHOOL TEACHER AT MISSION
NEIGHBORHOOD CENTERS IN SAN
FRANCISCO -- I AM.
ASKING FOR FUNDING FOR WORK
FIRST DEVELOPMENT IN ADDITION TO
ME BEING.
A FULL TIME TEACHER I AM ALSO A
FULL TIME STUDENT.
AND I'M DEDICATED SERVER GROWING
MY PRACTICES -- MY QUESTION OR
MY CONCERN IS IS IT HELP LAY THE
FOUNDATION FOR BRIGHTER FUTURES
FOR OUR CHILDREN.
BUT WHAT ABOUT MY OWN FUTURE
WHICH IS THE KING LIKE STUDENT
AT THANK YOU.
WE'LL GET TO WORK ON THAT WILL
WORK ON IT.
THANKS FOR JOINING JUST MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEX TO CAPRI ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
ONE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE OF THE EASY COALITION WE
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
EARLY CHILDHOOD CALIFORNIA FOR
ALL BUDGET WITH THE ADDITION OF
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE REFORM.
SERVICE EXPANSION AND WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT THAT THE EASY
COALITION IS PUT FORTH BUILT FOR
THE CONTINUING OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THESE
PRIORITIES ARE INCLUDED. TO
EXPAND HIGH QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT IS AFTERNOON BEVERLY ON
BEHALF OF YOU W. ASKED ME LOCAL
THREE NINE THIRTY WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
PROPOSAL STAND FOR THE EASY
SYSTEM AS WELL AS THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSAL FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
AS PART OF THE EASY COALITION WE
ARE STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND SLOTS OVER
THREE YEARS -- TO INCREASE
ACCESS FOR OUR STATE'S EARLY
LEARNERS.
WE ALSO URGE FUNDING IN THE
BUDGET -- FOR EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT REMOTE PHILLY
MEMBER FOR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
TO ENSURE PATHWAY FOR QUALITY
AND ACCESSIBLE CARE AND ARE EASY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION OF HIS BRIEF AS I CAN
AND IT BECAUSE QUICKLY IF I CAN
ON THESE PROPOSALS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY.
FIRST OF ALL AND WE SUPPORT
SENATOR LABOR'S PROPOSAL THAT
SHE PRESENTED PROPOSAL FOR MORE
SLOTS FOR STATE PRESCHOOL LYCOS
SERVES ONE THOUSAND FIFTY THREE
CHILDREN AT THIS TIME.
A IN THIS PROGRAM WE ALSO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION INVESTMENTS BUT
SUPPORT THE EQUALIZATION
PROPOSAL AS REPRESENTED IN AB.
FOR TWENTY EIGHT AND ALSO LASTLY
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR INCLUSIVE EARLY LEARNING AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND ADMINISTRATION THANK YOU
MA'AM YES SIR.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN
HICKEY JEWISH VOCATIONAL SERVICE
SAN FRANCISCO I'M HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR EARLY
LEARNING. TO INDOORS TO KEEP
PRIORITIES INCREASED INVESTMENTS
IN E. C. E. WORKFORCE TRAINING
WITH AN EYE TOWARDS THE NEED OF
OUR DIVERSE NEED OF OUR EARLY
LEARNERS.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE LABOR THE
LABOR MARKET IS STARVING FOR
QUALIFIED TEACHERS AND WE HEAR
FROM EMPLOYERS ABOUT THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT OF CONSISTENT
CHILD CARE ON BUSINESS
OPERATIONS -- I HEARD EARLIER
THE TALK ABOUT ALIGNING
WORKFORCE TRAINING WITH C. T. E.
I WOULD ALSO LIFT UP THE IDEA OF
A LINING THE STATE'S WORK FOR
HIGH ROAD HIGH WAGE -- WORKFORCE
WITH EASY AS WELL WHICH LEADS ME
TO MY SECOND PRIORITY WHICH IS
INVESTED IN AND MODERNIZING THE
COMPENSATION SYSTEM -- I WORRY
EVERYDAY THAT OUR WORK TO TRAIN
EASY TEACHERS IS LEADING TO A
PATH OF POVERTY RATHER THAN SELF
SUFFICIENCY.
AND THEN LASTLY THE PUBLIC
POLICY INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA
RELEASED A SURVEY JUST TODAY
THAT NOTES EASY IS IMPORTANT TO
MOST CALIFORNIANS AND A SOLID
MAJORITY SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR
SPENDING PLANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
YES MA'AM HI GOOD AFTERNOON
ANDREA BALL HERE TO SPEAK ON
ITEM SEVEN SPECIAL EDUCATION
FIRST ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
DOCTOR I'M A HARSH
SUPERINTENDENT.
REALLY APPRECIATED THE
DISCUSSION AROUND SPECIAL ED THE
FOCUS ON HOW TO TAKE A HOLISTIC
APPROACH AND BRIDGE GENERAL ED
AND SPECIAL LEAD.
EARLY IDENTIFICATION AND
INTERVENTION I JUST WANTED TO
HAND OUT SOMETHING THAT WAS
RAISED IN THE GREAT STAFF
ANALYSIS IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT IN THE MULTI TIERED
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT AND WHAT IS
THAT DOING TO SUPPORT SPECIAL ED.
AND IT REALLY DOES HELP BREAK
DOWN THE SILOS INSTEAD
FRAMEWORKS FOR GENERAL ADD
SPECIAL ED AND REALLY ALL THE
DIVISIONS TO HAVE A SYSTEMIC
APPROACH. FOR EARLY INTERVENTION
AND SERVING KIDS.
SECOND OF FOUR TO OTHER GROUPS
THE CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
REALLY SUPPORT THE LOOKING AND
DISCUSSING EQUALIZATION OF
SPECIAL ED THOSE ARE.
DISTRICTS AROUND THE STATE WITH
A VERY.
DIVERSE LEVELS OF FUNDING BUT I
WOULD SAY THAT FOR ALL OF THEM
THEY DO SUPPORT LOOKING AT AND
SUPPORTING OUR ESTABLISHING
FUNDING TO SERVE PRESCHOOL AGE
CHILDREN WHO COME WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
SIR.
HI RJ YOUNG WITH COMING HIS
STUFF ON A SEMI CISCO MAIN THANK
YOU FOR THE FOR THE SONY AND OF
WE SUPPORT FOR THE THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR.
THE FACILITY FOUND NOW WHAT A
LOUSY DEALS TO CREATE A MORE
SPACE TO SERVE MORE CHILDREN.
I WOULD ALLOW US TO CREATE THE
BETTER YOU MY MAN FOR CHILDREN'S
LEARNING AND FULL STAFF MANY OF
THEM THAT DON'T HAVE TIME FOR
LUNCH THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE CON
AS SPACE TO SIT DOWN FOR LUNCH.
SO PLEASE I WOULD AT LEAST
ADVOCATE FOR THAT THANK THANK
YOU SIR THANKS FOR JOINING US
JUST FROM.
GOOD AFTERNOON ANGIE LEAVE
REPRESENTING WANT ME SCHOOL A
NON L. E. A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
SO WE OFFER FOUR PROGRAMS
SERVING ON CLOSE TO THREE
HUNDRED CHILDREN AND FAMILIES.
ON A PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IS STATE
FUNDED TITLE FIGHT PROGRAM AND
LOCATED IN THE CITY'S PO ORDER
YOU WANT THIS RIGHT.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE
WERE GRATEFUL TO RECEIVE AN
EXPANSION GRANT FROM THE STATE --
WE HAVE BEEN LOOKING FOR
LICENSABLE FACILITY FOR FIFTEEN
MONTHS BUT WE HAVEN'T BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AN ANKLE CURRENTLY WE
HAVE BEEN NOTIFIED BY OUR
LANDLORD.
WHICH WE HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR
FORTY YEARS -- THE INTENTION OF
SELLING AND THAT PUT US IN THE
MEDIA RISK OF DISPLACEMENT.
SO -- WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S EFFORT I'M TO
INCREASE ACCESSIBILITY BY
RAISING THE NUMBER OF SLOTS AND
AB RATE HOWEVER IF WE DON'T HAVE
ADEQUATE AND LICENSABLE FACILITY
WE JUST CANNOT SERVE TO FAMILIES
THAT.
ARE DESPERATELY IN NEED FOR
QUALITY CARE THAT THEY DESERVE
SO THEREFORE WE SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S.
YOU SEE BUDGET PROPOSAL -- THAT
ALLOWS FIND TO BE GRANTED TO
COMPANY BASED ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
OURS FOR FACILITY ACQUISITION
AND BUILT UP THANK YOU FOR IT
THANK YOU.
SIR I GET AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PATRICK MORE TERM WITH MISSION
READINESS AND FIGHT CRIME INVEST
IN KIDS.
MISS FRANCIS MAYOR FAMILIARS
RETIRED MILITARY LEADERS AND
FIGHT CRIME REPRESENTS LAWN
FORCING MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE'RE HERE -- WITH THE C.
COALITION AS WELL.
TO APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR HIS
ASK FOR REALLY TRIED EDUCATION
PRE K. AND PRIORITIZE NOT
FUNDING.
THANK THE LAST THING YOU DO WHEN
YOU GO TO BED AT NIGHT OR WAKE
UP IN THE MORNING IS THINK ABOUT
CHILD CARE OR PRE K..
BUT WHEN YOU WHEN YOU'RE PUTTING
TOGETHER BUDGET THIS YEAR THIS
YEAR.
WE NEED THIS MONEY -- YOU KNOW
AS YOU NON PREACH TO THE CHOIR
ZERO THREE IS A HUGE TIME FOR
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT SKILLS FOR
THESE KIDS.
GETTING THEM OFF ON THE ON THE
RIGHT FOOTING -- MAKE SURE THEY
STAY IN SCHOOL OF THEIR MORE
ENGAGED AND THAT THEY END UP
GRADUATING STAYING AWAY FROM
CRIME -- AND NOT ONLY THAT YOU
KNOW FOR THE TEACHERS FOR THE
PARENTS FOR THE KIDS IT ALSO
AFFECTS THE STATE IN THE STATE'S
ECONOMY.
SO I WANTED TO GIVE YOU SOME
QUICK STATS OF THE COST FIVE
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
LOSS OF WAGES FOR PARENTS WHEN
THEY HAVE -- TO FIND.
RESOURCES OUTSIDE OF CHILD CARE
FOR THEIR KIDS TO BE TAKEN CARE
OF ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS FOR BUSINESSES LOSS OF
PRODUCTIVITY WHEN THE PARENTS
ARE OUT OF WORK LOOKING FOR CARE
FOR THEIR KIDS.
AND ONE MILLION DOLLAR. ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER
REVENUE WHEN THE PARENTS ARE OUT
OF WORK AND THEY ARE PROVIDING.
I INCOME TAX INTO THE STATE.
AND ONE OF THE SHOCKING
STATISTICS WE'VE HEARD IS OVER
ONE IN TEN PARENTS -- HAS FACED
REPRIMANDING OR BEING FIRED
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ADEQUATE
CHILDCARE.
WHICH IS TERRIBLE FOR THE STATE
WE NEED.
TO ENSURE THAT THESE PARENTS
HAVE CHILD CARE FOR THEIR KIDS
OTHER MORE SLOTS AND THAT
THERE'S MORE MONEY FOR
PRUDENTIAL CARE SO I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
TIME HERE WITH US MARTHA
GUERRERO REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
WE ARE VERY GRATEFUL AND SUPPORT
OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL FOR FACILITIES
WORKFORCE PLANNING AND SLOTS --
WE WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT ON THE
SLIDE SO WE'D LIKE TO EXPAND --
INCLUDE INFANTS AND TODDLERS
FROM -- ZERO TO FIVE IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY -- WE HAVE THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
FIVE SEVEN CHILDREN IN THAT
RANGE AND 79%.
IN THE LOW INCOME RANGE AND 79%
DO NOT -- HAVE ACCESS TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND YOU
UNDERSTANDING HEARD THE NEEDS OF
HAVING ACCESS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES WHO WE URGE YOU TO FUND --
AND PROVIDE.
ON THE EXPANDED ACCESS RESORT OF
BY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MICHELLE SO VERBINSKI FROM
CANANGA WHICH AN EARLY LEARNING
NONPROFIT -- REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS -- THIS HEARING -- WE
SUPPORT -- THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS AND AN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION AND THE ECU COALITION
I'M PRIORITIES AND I JUST WANNA
CALL AT TWO THINGS -- AS WE ARE
EXPANDING -- HIGH QUALITY
PRESCHOOL REALLY THINKING ABOUT
THE WILL OF THE WORK FORCE AND
HOW WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
SUPPORTING OUR TEACHERS WE HAD
ONE OF THEM HERE EARLIER. TO
REACH HIGHER QUALIFICATION --
QUALIFICATION THEN GO BACK AND
GET THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION AS
WELL AS PUTTING THEM ON A PATH
TOWARDS PARITY -- WITH
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS SO THAT --
WE KNOW THAT THAT KIND OF HIGH
QUALITY -- WORK FORCE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE OUTCOMES THAT
WE SEEK -- AND THEN I WANT -- TO
HIGHLIGHT REEL THE REAL
IMPORTANCE OF INFANT TODDLER
CHILD CARE -- AND EXPANDING
ACCESS TO THE HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW MAKE A
DIFFERENCE -- IN OFTEN FOR
STARTING BY PRESCHOOL THAT'S TOO
LATE -- FOR FOR REALLY CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP LIKE WE WANT
TO ON AND MEETING THE NEEDS.
OF WERE ARE WORKING FAMILIES AND
SO THERE'S A PROPOSAL THAT
ASSEMBLY WOMAN RUBIO HAS ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE TO EXPAND --
ACCESS TO TWENTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL -- INFANTS AND
TODDLERS WITH HIGH QUALITY
SERVICES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
THAT AFTERNOON I'M EXCITED TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT YOU'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO LEAVE SOON MAYBE.
POSSIBLY.
SO MY NAME'S MARTHA HANSON I
LIVE RIGHT ACROSS THE RIVER AND
I WILL BE CHANGING MY SHOES
RIGHT AFTER THIS AND WALKING
HOME FOR OVER FIVE MILES.
I CANNOT AFFORD A VEHICLE NOR
GAS FOR A VEHICLE BECAUSE I AM A
FULL TIME ADVOCATE FOR MY NOW
NINE YEAR OLD SON.
WHO I HAD A FIGHT FOR THREE
YEARS TO GET INTO SPECIAL
EDUCATION THOUGH HE WAS ON TOP
OF A DESK TO WIN ON A SHOE ALL
OF LAST SCHOOL YEAR?
THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FACE BECAUSE OF
FUNDING.
AFFECT FAMILIES AND MANY MORE
WAYSTHAN YOU CAN IMAGINE I
CANNOT WORK I AM A FULLY CAPABLE
PERSON AND I AM ON WELFARE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH.
I AM FULLY CAPABLE I AM EDUCATED
AND I AM SMART.
I SERVE ON COMMITTEES AND BOARDS
BUT I HAVE TO WATCH PEOPLE EAT
LUNCH BECAUSE I CAN'T AFFORD.
ONE DURING THOSE MEETINGS.
THE ONLY REASON I CANNOT DO THIS
IS BECAUSE I HAVE TO BE A FULL
TIME ADVOCATE FOR MY NOW NINE
YEAR OLD SON WHO ONLY KNOWS
FOURTEEN LETTERS OF THE ALPHABET.
AND WHO IS CURRENTLY BEEN OUT
HAS CURRENTLY BEEN OUT OF SCHOOL.
FOR ALMOST EIGHT WEEKS NOW
BECAUSE HE IS NOT SUITED OR FIT
FOR THE CLASSROOM SETTING RIGHT
NOW.
SO I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE
THE AN APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
I'M ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT AS
WELL FOR CHILDREN LIKE MINE.
AND FOR PARENTS LIKE ME WHO ARE
FULLY CAPABLE BUT SITTING ON
WELFARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
IS THERE ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT.
SAYING THAT I WANT TO THANK
THOSE OF YOU WERE STILL HERE WHO
WERE HERE FOR THE HEARING ON
ESPECIALLY THANK OUR PANELISTS.
FOR AN INTERESTING AND
STIMULATING DISCUSSION AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESSES
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE IS
ADJOURNED